meet joey a digital marketer he works as
the head of digital marketing for amazon
but how did joey get here a few years
ago joey began to see a large number of
opportunities popping up in the field of
digital marketing to begin his entry
into the field he needed to understand
what exactly digital marketing was and
what was so great about it
first joey learned that digital
marketing was a form of marketing
through which you could advertise to
people digitally digital marketing
leveraged different channels like search
engines websites social media platforms
emails and mobile applications
it would give marketers the opportunity
to interact with and understand their
audience better and to increase the
trust in their brand
digital marketing would also show
marketers advertisements to people based
on their actions and preferences on the
internet while being less expensive than
traditional forms of advertising after
understanding the main concepts of
digital marketing joey realized there
was more to digital marketing than he
initially thought there were also many
types of digital marketing types like
content marketing search engine
optimization pay-per-click social media
marketing email marketing and affiliate
marketing and once he understood those
types he set up a digital marketing
campaign for his uncle's e-commerce
website let's have a look at what he
came up with
first joey created content like blogs
videos infographics and case studies so
that he could generate audience interest
in the brand's products or services
this was content marketing
next he needed his audience to actually
see his content the first step was to
create content on specific search
keywords that were relevant to the
target audience
joey would make optimizations on the
website and have credible websites
linking back to the content and lo and
behold the website began ranking on the
first page of the search results by
continuous optimizations joey would
continue to improve the ranking and
ultimately make the website rank at the
first position
this was seo or search engine
optimization and joey could do all of
this without spending a single penny he
could also drive traffic to the website
with advertisements
but for this he would have to pay a
certain fee each time the ads were
clicked he could have text ads that show
up in search engine results image ads
and video ads that show up in websites
and much more
this was possible with the help of ppc
or pay-per-click
however joey wasn't done yet to reach a
larger audience he needed to tap into
social media platforms
he would use social media platforms like
linkedin youtube facebook and instagram
to advertise the brand's content he
would use these platforms to advertise
the brand's products or services with
posts images videos and more to bring
out the brand's story and engage with
the brand's audience who spend a lot of
time on social media
like pbc he could use the platform to
advertise the brand's products or
services with text image and video ads
which needed to be paid for
that's social media marketing
joey realized that a large amount of the
audience weren't visiting the brand's
website a second time he needed to keep
them engaged nurture them to make sure
they purchased the product
for this he would send them emails that
help them better understand the products
they visited on the website and assist
them in the buying process he would also
send emails to advertise his products or
services to potential customers that is
with email marketing and finally
although joey was able to grow the
brand's funnel he wanted more traffic
from third party websites this could be
achieved with affiliate marketing
affiliates would promote the brand or
product to their audiences for a fee
with the help of email signups
registrations conversions subscriptions
etc
after setting all of this up joey had
the hardest part of the process to get
through the weight
[Music]
hi guys welcome to part one of the
digital marketing full course video by
simply learn in this video we'll be
covering everything you need to know
about digital marketing we'll do this
with the help of our instructor rob
sanders so let's start with an
introduction to digital marketing a
digital marketing course video and some
of the best digital marketing tools
we'll also have a look at what is seo an
seo tutorial seven tips and tricks for
seo how to perform keyword research how
to rank number one on google and google
tag manager greetings everyone this is
rob sanders and today we're going to
talk about what is digital marketing so
thanks for joining us here at simply
learn and let's get started let's start
talking about why digital marketing is
important so let's start there on the
why so we're just a fly on the wall and
we're in an office environment we're
looking at two friends having a
conversation about digital marketing so
really if we're listening in
everybody every marketer is using
digital marketing for his or her
business now digit marketing has become
more popular than traditional marketing
that's not a surprise
so in response hey over the past few
decades digital marketing has evolved at
a rapid pace these days a lot of people
spend most their time on the internet so
what happens in the internet every 60
seconds well a lot happens every 60
seconds so according to social media
today i mean there's a lot of snaps
there's a lot of clicks there's a lot of
text there's a lot of videos watched
there's a lot of pictures being taken
there's a lot of
voice activated activity going on a lot
of tweets emails swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and so the one gentleman says hey can
you also mention a few differences
between digital and traditional
marketing systems and then the expert
responds of course i can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say
what the differences are between
traditional and digital and let's look
at that okay so on traditional marketing
we're talking about print radio
billboard newspaper tv
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know with traditional
marketing reach is limited
with digital marketing reaches maximum
and what we mean by that is hey when you
print something you're printing it for x
amount of people if you're trying to
promote an event and you
basically create a thousand flyers okay
you figure it's going to a thousand
people maybe they'll share it so you're
looking about 2 000 people maybe just to
be generous well digital marketing we're
promoting an event we can promote it to
a whole lot of people depending on the
platform so 2000 is nothing when you're
targeting an audience on facebook or
google search traditional marketing
non-versatile and with digital marketing
very versatile so again going back to
our flyer printing an eight and a half
by eleven okay that's it you know with
with digital marketing you're running
display banners you have 468 by 60 200
by 200 250 by 250 300 by 300 i mean the
list goes on on the types of different
display sizes not to mention text ads
not to mention video or multimedia
so there's a lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so
meaning if you're trying to get that tv
spot there might not be a spot open
until one in the morning okay well with
digital marketing there is no hours okay
you can certainly get your point out
there and have people see it
instantaneously so with traditional
marketing there's a lack of real-time
results i mean this seems like uh it's
obvious but you know digital marketing
that's one of the biggest benefits
instant real-time results instant okay
nowadays we're going analytics you can
look at real-time reporting okay so we
could see real-time results okay
traditional marketing can be very costly
i mean if you're not only doing
postcards and printing postcards but you
have to mail those postcards so there's
postage fees where with digital
marketing it's very very very cost
efficient i mean meaning you could pick
and choose who you want to target when
you want to target where you want to
target what you want to target and if
you're doing search you can put your
bidding in place you can put your hours
in place you can really control how much
you actually spend so that to me is one
of the biggest advantages to digital
marketing not only do you get real-time
results but you can control costs and
then obviously optimize based on the
amount of cost you're spending based on
those real-time results with traditional
marketing it's difficult to reach a
target audience you know with digital
marketing it's easy to reach a target
audience i mean you know i don't wanna
bash traditional marketing too much i
mean if you're gonna put a tv ad in
place you know you're gonna do it on a
tv show that tends to gear more towards
your target audience but that doesn't
guarantee anything here we can simply go
to facebook or twitter or linkedin and
just pick and choose specifically who we
want to target when we want to target
them so it just becomes a lot easier to
reach a targeted audience on a digital
marketing platform and then with
traditional marketing poor campaign
measurement with digital you have easy
to measure and optimize campaigns and
what we really mean by that is because
you get instant time results because you
can control cost because you can reach
your target audience more easily all
those a result of okay you can measure
and optimize based on what our audience
is seeing and how much they're spending
to see it we can quickly make
adjustments in order to optimize the
campaign for better performance so
that's generally that means that's a
culmination of pretty much everything
that we've listed as a benefit for
digital marketing okay so now
why digital marketing has been answered
with all the benefits that
it carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so
you know that
you know you want to do digital
marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just define it
digital marketing it's just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device and when
we talk about technology it could be an
app it could be
you know a cloud-based platform okay it
could be a piece of software okay so
a lot going on on the digital side in
terms of variations and what you can do
but that's in a nutshell what digital
marketing is you're really just using
technology to promote your product or
service so we know because of the
benefits in digital marketing you can
promote your campaign on different
platforms okay so all these benefits we
mentioned about instant real-time
results cost efficiency
optimizing campaigns you could do that
on search you could do it on social via
email on mobile apps etc so that's what
we mean by with the help of digital
devices and technology well these
digital devices and technology come in
the form of search engines and emails
and mobile apps etc so
when we want to go
and promote our product or service using
a campaign we have different options so
there are different types of digital
marketing channels that we can choose
from and let's just go through that list
of digital marketing channels and the
first one is what i consider the king of
them all and that's seo so seo stands
for search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with seo because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic
on the search engines including google
so depending on where you're located in
the u.s market google tends or has a
large market share so you want your
pages on your website to be found and
clicked on organically and so that means
that somebody types in a keyword you
want that relevant page to show up first
on google so somebody can click on that
link okay and we know that millions of
people
specifically in the us but worldwide you
search on a daily basis so if you're
ranking for those relevant keywords you
can imagine how much traffic you can get
okay so that's seo okay and here's an
example so you type in online shopping
well you can see the first listing here
is a paid search ad and we're gonna get
to that in a minute the second
organically is amazon okay so online
shopping you think maybe walmart you
think maybe
alibaba or you're thinking probably
amazon okay so no surprise amazon's
ranking for the keyword online shopping
and so if somebody clicked on their
listing that's traffic for amazon let's
move on to search engine marketing you
know known as sem or pay per click or
cost per click or ppc or cpc or
sponsored search or google ads i mean
there's a lot of different names
synonymous with sem so search engine
marketing is really just using paid ads
on search engines just as we saw the
previous example if you want to be found
for keyword
you don't have to worry about organic if
you're willing to pay for it you just
bid on that keyword and voila you have
the opportunity to appear number one in
the search results at the top of the
page for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay google if
it's google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well
myus.com
is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happened to click on that listing then
myus.com is going to pay google
something
depending on what the cost per click is
and so that could be anywhere from one
penny to a hundred dollars it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location depends on the time of
day
depends on quality score a lot of
factors involved and regarding what you
pay however
the benefit of sem is visibility and
getting traffic to your website for
keywords you're not found for so that's
why sem's such a popular choice for a
lot of companies okay let's talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time you know we all
send emails on a daily basis and we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis this is an effective way to
capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you could
send your emails to a segmented audience
okay so if you have emails from
females who are 35 years of age to 44
that live and say this southern part of
the united states you can segment that
and send them an email and cater that
email directly to that audience and of
course you can put some nice call to
action in there you could design it
really snazzy and you could track it
just like you can any other digital
marketing channel so email is a very
effective way to really reach a target
audience because everybody for the most
part has a functioning email account so
basically here's an example of an email
that could go out you're selling a
product and the products promotion is
about to end well you know get that
email out to your target audience let
them know hey you have until tonight to
purchase a product and if you purchase
it you're going to get 30 off and you
can put the coupon code right in there
with a nice call to action and you can
measure how many people click on that
email go to that webpage and purchase
the product using that coupon code so
that's an example of email marketing
okay we have affiliate marketing so
affiliate marketing is an effective way
for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting
merchants to promote your products and
services and you're using usually a
third-party broker like commission
junction or cg.com as an example to
introduce you
the the person selling the product the
merchant with the affiliate so that
affiliate could likely be a merchant him
or himself and they can basically be a
good partner of yours by publishing your
product or service on their website so
that they can sell in order to get
commissions so it's all based on a
commission so you basically are going to
use a third-party affiliate like cj get
all these affiliates to work for you
they're going to promote your product or
service if they do sell your product or
service you're going to pay them a
commission that's more or less how it
works with affiliate marketing and you
know with affiliate marketing to me it's
a good way to you know really promote
your product or service and you can pick
and choose the affiliates or the
publishers of whom you want to work with
so here's an example
of affiliate marketing at work okay you
basically see a banner basically you can
see earn up to 12 advertising fees with
a trusted e-commerce leader okay so if
somebody clicked on that purchase for
example or joined you could pay off that
commission okay let's turn our attention
to social media marketing so social
media marketing you know i would say
it's fairly new i mean if i think about
it we're in 2019
and i remember talking about facebook
back in 2006. so you're talking about 13
14 15 years of social media it's
definitely evolved over the years and
but the concept remains the same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on pinterest or
instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're going to promote but
we know social media can be effective
because people use social media i mean
facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you can
certainly pay to have an ad on facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your social platforms
like linkedin and twitter and facebook
and pinterest and instagram they'll have
a paid form of advertising that you can
use to promote your product or service
or
you can go the organic route and
you know post content organically in
hopes of driving traffic back to your
website so with social you do have two
options here but social is interesting
because a lot of different social media
platforms out there really depends on
your product or service okay so an
example of social media marketing
especially on facebook with facebook you
got mobile and desktop and you obviously
have the opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you could post
an app and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing so
content marketing is really an effective
way of really distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an an infographic or it could
be an image okay there are lots of ways
to create content these days especially
in digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so
if you're trying a targeted audience on
say instagram then you know who your
audience is and you know what the type
of content you're going to post on there
so it could be in the form of a video or
infographic or just a graphic and so
that's the beauty of content marketing
really putting yourself out there
and
depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example we look at
youtube you can see this video here
about digital marketing certified
associate well hey you don't need to
always write the content you can produce
the content in the form of a video and
post it on youtube this is a form of
content marketing so that's content
marketing and then let's talk about
mobile marketing so content marketing
again different types but if we go now
to mobile marketing you can kind of
segue from content to mobile because the
only difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so
mobile marketing is really a strategy on
its own that helps you the company
promoting your product or service to
reach your target audience through a
mobile device and that includes tablets
and how you could do that is via
messaging you could do it via email or
you could be do it via an app okay so
you have different ways of getting your
content out there to people okay so as
an example you can use basically sms or
instant messaging via mobile devices to
promote your product or service here's
another example
of a mobile marketing via app install
and so you can even compound that by
running a say google ad as an example
and running your google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bid adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service via mobile marketing
okay let's talk about the customer life
cycle
so we know why we want to do digital
marketing we want to know we want we
know
what the digital marketing channels are
because we just talked about them from
seo to social to affiliate to mobile to
content to sem okay you have a lot of
different digital marketing channels at
your disposal so now how do we go ahead
and approach our customers so that's
what we're going to talk about first so
we're going to talk about different
stages of the customer life cycle okay
and the first one is the awareness stage
so we need to get our customers aware of
what we're selling what we're promoting
okay so the awareness stage is really
what product does your brand offer
that's a question we want to get out
there and we want to answer okay what
does a customer need your product or
excuse me why does a customer need your
product that's a question we want to
answer with digital marketing okay what
solution does your product provide okay
that's an answer to a question we want
to make sure people understand so these
are questions that we want to be able to
answer in the form of digital marketing
whether that be mobile or content okay
so getting our information out there
that answers these essential questions
and if we could do that then somebody's
gonna become aware of our product or
service okay so what product is our
brand offer why does a customer need it
and what solution does it provide okay
those are some key questions that people
tend to ask themselves when they look at
a brand okay and when they look at a
product hey do i really need this is it
gonna help me in my life okay and who
who is selling this i mean who is this
brand i mean that's those are just
things that run through people's mind
intuitively that with the right
messaging
the right channel the right type of
asset the right targeted audience you
can quickly make somebody aware of your
brand's product or service in this stage
it's help potential customers discover
your brand with the help of these
different marketing channels so
in the awareness stage you know content
is key so it's to me if we have a
website we need a blog because if
somebody does come to our blog from say
organic search seo then we can write
about that product or service via blog
and talk to our customer talk directly
to our targeted audience through that
blog and if we're not ranking
organically we can use paid search to
promote it because paid search on google
for example basically we can be right at
the top of the search results and so
somebody can actually see when they do a
search because we know millions of
people you search on a daily basis you
could do
social media marketing okay so you can
publish that product or service on
facebook while you're building your
community and you can use affiliate
marketing to help get the word out by
using cg.com as an example build up a
sales force of people these publishers
that are going to put your product or
service out there so to me in the
awareness stage these are the the
digital marketing channels you could
focus on now i will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority in the awareness stage
display
ads mean that if you're on google's
display number you could pick and choose
your sites your demographics keywords
topics an audience you could focus on
all those different demographics to
really attract a large number of people
so low priority but it's probably also
good to focus on in the awareness stage
okay so content marketing you must
create a high quality content that
people are searching for without content
it's hard to get found
and so to me this is you know where the
blog comes in seo take that content get
it optimized okay sem if we're not
ranking organically we can make sure
we're at the top of the paid search
results or the the search results for a
particular keyword we want to be found
for and then social media marketing
using different channels depending on
the channel if we're selling you know
training like simply learn does you know
linkedin is a good platform for us okay
and then affiliate you know basically
building up a nice network of publishers
to get the word out so these are all
good channels that we can focus in on so
traffic sources may include paid unpaid
social referral display email or direct
so they they could come in the awareness
stage from all different types of
channels even though you're focused on
content i mean you can still get traffic
from mobile or email so now that we get
the word out via all these different
marketing channels there's that
consideration stage so
you know people are aware of us now
they're considering us and that's kind
of the next stage in the process okay so
a few essential questions to address on
the consideration stage hey what
features make your product valuable to
others and how will i increase customer
engagement towards my product so those
are answers to questions you want to ask
okay what features make your product
valuable you want to basically separate
yourself from the competition basically
that's what you're trying to answer okay
so if you're promoting your product or
service on paid search and other people
are bidding on the same keyword how are
you going to stand out and then how will
i increase customer engagement towards
my product so for example if you're on
facebook okay and you're trying to get
people over to your site to purchase
your product then how are you going to
improve that engagement you got to
create something really snazzy or really
it's going to be attention grabbing or
something that's going to get them to
become aware of it that's going to
separate your posts from all the other
posts that are in somebody's facebook
news feed okay so you really have to
work hard to really convince somebody to
get their consideration towards your
product or service so in this stage your
customer considers your product so help
them understand how your product is
valuable okay to me email works really
good here because if you have a targeted
audience this gives you the opportunity
to really answer these questions in that
particular channel email you could
support that with the promotion and
display i think display is a good option
here too because even though you know
people are trying to become aware
you know you can really hone in
and really
get them to take that next step okay
with display you can even do remarketing
so if somebody's been to your site
because they're aware of your product
they're curious you can cookie them and
remarket to them via display so display
to me is a good a good channel to use
here okay so you have email mobile
display you know sem these are all you
know good channels to use on the
consideration stage especially on search
because somebody's looking for something
and they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so
people are aware we're moving them
further along the funnel with email
marketing we have the opportunity to
promote the product by sending an email
directly to our audience so with this
stage plan your campaigns around
welcoming emails newsletters we can talk
about product descriptions add ratings
and reviews in the email you know we
really just want to encourage people to
purchase the product that's we're trying
to sway them over so email is a good
source to allow us to do that so with
mobile marketing we can promote the
products by sending relevant messages to
our target audience display again
retargeting because we can retarget an
audience that has been to our website
already did some research about our
brand our product or service and now
we're going to reach back out to them to
sway them so
remember we want to encourage customers
to buy a product by creating detailed
articles about the product that always
helps and that's content okay we want to
opt for a customer testimonial okay that
helps sway people and add some guest
blogging okay we can have ambassadors
blog on our behalf or we can go out and
blog on somebody else's site okay so
blogging works both ways it's ways of of
showing yourself and telling people hey
we know you're looking for this product
here's why you want to choose us okay
moving on from the consideration to the
purchase stage so they're aware of you
they're considering you
and now we're on to the purchase stage
so the questions we want to really make
sure we address here are how are my
prices compared to my competitors and is
my brand more credible than others okay
so they're considering you but
that price point and it may not even be
the price it could be the shipping for
example the price could be good but the
shipping cost could be high so you
really want to do some due diligence and
research on what your competitors are
doing credibility that goes back to the
consideration stage and testimonials you
want to make sure you have reviews and
testimonials to really elevate what
you're trying to tell customers and that
that is hey i have a good brand i have a
good product i have a good service come
buy my stuff come buy my product and
service but you really need to support
that claim you just can't go out and say
it and so supporting that comes in the
form of what other people say and that
could be reviews that could be comments
on a social media platform it could be
you know stars on say yelp or google my
business you know make sure you do your
due diligence and make sure
you get people to you know review you or
provide testimonials because people are
going to do their due diligence before
they purchase especially if it's on
google my business or yelp or trip
advisor or whatever it is you're trying
to sell they're going to be able to see
those reviews and so do your due
diligence to get the reviews and if it
is a negative review hey that's okay you
can't please everyone you're gonna get
them that's the world we live in just
make sure you show your upper hand and
respond even to the negative as well as
the positive reviews that you get that
actually bodes well to some people
because hey it shows that i made a
mistake and you're willing to correct it
and so people actually see that that
could be the tipping point to getting
them to purchase hey look hey this brand
really cares because they're really
responding to people they're not
ignoring negativity okay just those
small things that can get people to
change their mind now with the purchase
stage according to e-consultancy 83 of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
it could mean providing a promo giving
them that extra incentive you know if
you don't offer promo consider it
especially on the email and the example
we looked at earlier sending out an
email
means that if the promo is going to end
at midnight send that email out and tell
people they have until midnight and if
they purchase today you'll even increase
it to 20
and email is a good channel for that
mobile can reach a lot of people through
sms okay social media reaching people
instantaneously
and then you know really with the
purchase stage it gives prop prospects
an offer to help them make that purchase
so you have plenty of channels to choose
from in fact most of these channels the
only one really that doesn't fit the
instantaneous mode is seo but you can
really focus on affiliate even though
that's a low priority here you can
really you know coordinate with your
publishers who especially those
publishers that have proven their worth
and have sold your products in the past
you get them to help promote it and
incentivize their audience so let's move
on from the purchase to the purse post
purchase stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could i sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to not push a product on your
customer but think about how you can
complement that purchases that
purchasers or customers product and then
how to improve the customer buying
experience
so again
this goes back to you know what we just
said about reviews get somebody to offer
a review and if they don't give you
a full compliment of five stars they
only give you three and a half stars
then you know what that's great feedback
because then you can learn from that and
then the other question is will the
customer refers to others and if so why
so that's definitely something you want
to be able to address in the post
purchase stage so let's take a look here
so with post purchasing stage you know
it's me emails at the top of this list
because if somebody purchases something
you can send a nice thank you email
because if they purchase they're giving
you their email in return because you're
likely going to be sending them the
receipt via email so email to me is a
nice
channel you send in a nice message even
you know social media you know you can
thank your community for supporting you
on this recent campaign that you ran you
know even throwing an extra five or ten
percent on a future purchase is a thank
you and that's easily done on social
media
you know you could even post a blog you
know promoting you know the success of a
product and then offering a promotion
okay so there's a lot of things you
could be doing here on the post
purchasing stage so to me even looking
at content again you could even you know
put a survey together you could even put
a survey together for your affiliates
okay you could even post a poll on
facebook so it's just working in with
these different channels to get some
feedback about your product and service
so with email mobile you can engage
customers with follow-up emails or
customer care content you know with
mobile if you have somebody's mobile
number hey text them a simple thank you
goes a long way you know you could say
hey look if you're satisfied let us know
give us a call you can even in the ee
mobile text message you can put a link
to a survey send emails to active
subscribers give rewards for customer
feedback so if somebody does provide
feedback give them an extra 10 off you
know you want to be able to reward
loyalty loyalty comes in the form of a
partnership if you're giving somebody
discounts and you have a good product or
service
then they're going to recognize that
they're going to say hey look i really
like this product and they're giving me
10 i'm going to go ahead and purchase
from these guys again so give those
discounts to those active customers or
on the affiliate network give referral
opportunities to your customers so
if it's an affiliate publisher hey if
they're getting people to your site you
know reward them or if it's an email and
you put a four to a friend get an extra
10 off it doesn't hurt because you're
incentivizing people to help you sell
your product so with social display and
content use those banner ads or
use that content that you display on
social or the blog you're going to write
to give customers advice in order to
maximize the value of the purchase so
again you can use these platforms to
also enhance
what they purchased so hey you just
purchased this product thank you very
much did you know you could do this this
and this with it and so that's the idea
of a post-purchase stage is to maximize
these channels to be able to answer
those essential questions about what
else could they purchase you know do
they like how do i get these people to
become loyal customers okay so with the
first purchase stage if a customer has
bought a pair of sports shoes for
example running shoes you can recommend
cross product sale or cross sale it
could be a pair of shorts or a water
bottle or an accessory with an exclusive
discount so that's another example what
you can do on the post purchase stage so
in today's world everywhere you go it's
all about digital so today this lecture
is going to be about all the different
marketing channels available piece them
together kind of put together a little
digital marketing course for you so
first off before we get started we're
going to talk about what is digital
marketing and really digital marketing
covers a lot of areas it's very broad
and really what it refers to just
marketing
that
a company does a person does an
individual a group an organization and
they do it in the form of an electronic
device or with the aid of the internet
that's really what digital marketing is
it's just having something digitally not
something tangible like a billboard or
newspaper or tv and with that there are
lots of places where you can apply
digital marketing and so
electronic devices we think of mobile
devices and so you could certainly use
mobile as a form of digital marketing or
to help you with your marketing efforts
digitally okay you can create apps you
can run advertising on mobile you can
communicate with different people your
target audience
via different devices like whatsapp and
messaging okay uh there's also search
engines search engines is where a lot of
people get their information from at
least start to do their research to get
information you got social media lots of
different social media platforms all the
way from you know tweeting to blogging
to
a social sharing to social content okay
so a lot of of platforms under the
bucket social media you also have
traditional forms of digital marketing
like email you can use different email
platforms to send out emails so
lots of different ways to communicate
your product your service your message
to a large number of people that are
really targeted to your efforts how is
digital marketing useful well we know
provides different metrics why do we
know it provides different metrics
because it's all digital okay so anytime
you send out an email or post something
on facebook you're going to get data
back when you get data back you could
take that data to determine how well
that post or that email performed and if
it didn't perform up to expectation you
can make changes to improve performance
that's called optimization okay so
that's the great thing about digital
marketing it's useful in that we get
data in some cases instantaneously and
we're able to make changes in order to
optimize that campaign we can also
you know provide personalized user
experience so meaning if we know who our
target audience is on say twitter or
linkedin or facebook we can really cater
our messaging to that group probably
most importantly is that digital
marketing compared to traditional forms
of marketing allow us to really reach
a global audience very easily very
easily at a very low cost that's the key
so if i want to target people in india
or or nepal or pakistan i can certainly
do that and i can do that with the snap
of a campaign and i get data back and
based on the data i can tailor that
experience even better really just
allows us to really hone in on a
particular audience anywhere in the
world very quickly so these are just
three of the main reasons why digital
marketing is useful some other
experiences or uses for digital
marketing again it provides a
cost-effective alternative to
traditional marketing so you know for
those that are familiar with purchasing
advertising on say tv or radio you have
to pick a spot you have to pick a
program and then pick a time slot
associated with that program so
somebody's watching a program and and
that program tends to draw on a specific
target audience then you want to show
your ad around the time when that
program is slotted to air on tv
because you know you're likely going to
reach your audience however to purchase
that time slot could be competitive and
could be very costly where there are
forms of of advertising and paying for
advertising digitally and those forms
are cost per click or cost per
impression and so using a cost per click
or cost compression model allows you to
really go head-to-head in kind of an
auction style format where you can
control how much you pay and potentially
get that prime spot in front of your
target audience so it really does become
cost effective and it allows you to make
small investments to get a really
substantial return on roi so let's just
say your cost per click is only 10 cents
but you're selling a product for 10
well all you need is one click and one
sale to generate a very substantial
return on investment and so knowing that
you get metrics back on a campaign you
could slowly or quickly optimize that
campaign towards a very positive roi and
then another use for digital marketing
just enables targeting users based on
their actions and preferences so again
we can really hone in on who we want to
target it really depends on the platform
but if you take google ads for example
and you want to target the display
network well we know we have
demographics we know we have topics we
know we have interest we know we have
retarget audiences in segment audiences
we have age we have gender so you have a
lot of options available to choose from
to really hone in on who you want to
target and we talk about remarketing is
another form of digital marketing so you
can set up a marketing campaign so if
somebody comes to your website and does
not purchase the product or service that
you're offering you could take action on
that behavior so i can re-target a group
of people who didn't purchase that's
retargeting or you could do it via
remarketing and
basically that's the beauty of digital
marketing allows you to really target
users based on their actions some other
uses for digital marketing it helps
build brand awareness and reputation of
your business so we say brand awareness
if you're just launching a company and
nobody knows who you are if we use
google ads as our preferred method of
digital marketing and establishing
campaigns we can choose that display
network that display network on google
ads reaches a large amount of people so
you can really get your name out there
and really target your intended audience
and allow that targeted intended
audience to really understand who you
are because they're going to see your ad
in the form of a banner or in the form
of a video or in the form of text and so
that's the beauty of digital marketing
you can really reach a lot of people and
a lot of people who might be interested
in your product or service and then
digital marketing provides a platform
for you to be interactive with your
audience helping you stay relevant and
competitive and the best example i can
give here is youtube and so youtube's a
really it's a search engine for videos
but it's a video sharing platform and so
if i upload a video
then i can entice people to comment on
that video or like the video or share
the video and i can really interact with
that audience by responding to their
comments or you know putting together a
playlist or giving them more videos okay
so i can really interact with my
audience and i could do that on multiple
platforms not just youtube and video i
can blog and and interact based on
somebody's comments i can have a website
and have live chat and interact with my
audience so there's lots of different
ways to interact with an audience and
that's what digital marketing provides
so i already mentioned a few examples
based on the uses of digital marketing i
mentioned google's display network i
mentioned youtube and blogging and
social media platforms like facebook
well there are lots of different types
of digital marketing channels out there
and we're going to talk about a few of
them today we're going to start with
search engine optimization and so search
engine optimization
as you probably know from the name
involves search engine and it involves
really making your site relevant in the
eyes of that search engine so if you're
in the united states you know that
google has a large market share meaning
a lot of people use google on a daily
basis so we want to make sure we do
everything we can to optimize our site
in order to make our site relevant for
those coveted keywords now why do we
want to make ourselves relevant for
those coveted keywords that we want to
be found for on search well because a
lot of people use search and when a lot
of people you search and you're found
for those keyword queries then it's
going to increase the flow of organic
traffic to your website so the higher
you rank in theory the more traffic
you're gonna get and so when we talked
about optimization okay how do we
optimize our site in order to be
relevant in the eyes of google well it
really comes down to a two-pronged
approach you have on-page seo you have
off-page seo on-page has everything to
do with your website in order to make it
relevant off-page has everything to do
with your website but not on your
website it means that how can we become
relevant by linking to other websites
for example how can we become relevant
by getting our content on other
platforms so we become relevant in the
eyes of google so that's off page seo so
seo is always going to be two prong what
you do on your website and what you do
off the website to make sure your
website your domain whatever that domain
is dot com or dot org is relevant in the
eyes of google and so let's take a look
at on-page seo first so like i mentioned
it involves optimizing your website and
when we say optimizing your website
there's a lot of things you can do on
your website to make it relevant in the
eyes of google and we can look at the
content okay we can look at the source
code and so there are a lot of different
components to be looked at here so you
have the header tag you have the meta
description you have the alt tag you
have how fast your page loads you have
internal linking you have a site map you
have lots of different things going on
here and so for me
one of the first things you should do
when you create a page on your website
is to make sure the title tag is unique
and includes those keywords so if we
look here at this example the title tag
is important because that's what shows
up in search results here you can see
the title tag on google is up to 65
characters so you always want to include
that keyword in the title tag then you
have your url and then you have what you
call a meta description so that's
underneath the url underneath the title
tag and again this is in search results
so organic search results somebody types
in a keyword you want to be found and
you want your title tag to stick out and
you want your meta description to
specifically describe what it is you're
offering okay so again if somebody's
looking for stock imagery then you want
to make sure that you know that person
who's looking for stock imagery can come
to your website and they can in this
case search for millions of royalty free
stock images photos videos and music and
so you want your description to really
get that person to click on your listing
an organic search that's the whole point
so that's the point of a title tag and a
meta description is you really want to
be found for what somebody's searching
for and you want to be able to show them
that you have what they're looking for
you have something here underneath your
organic search results called site links
and site links are just other are links
to pages on your website and so
unfortunately this is not necessarily in
your control this is in the control of
google so if google wants to offer up
site links underneath your title tag
meta description they will add them and
it's based really on the amount of
content you have and that goes with site
search so you can see also their site
search there underneath the meta
description all of that is contingent
upon your website do you have a lot of
content and if you have a lot of
relevant content then google will
naturally add in site links underneath
your organic listing to links to other
pages on your site so that's on page seo
and now we're going to look at off page
seo okay so off page seo involves using
promotional methods beyond just
optimizing your site for example
optimizing your title tag and meta
description might not be enough to get
you to rank for that coveted keyword
query so we need to do
some link building we need to get our
name out there on other websites okay so
we need to be able to establish some
external links or backlinks from high
quality relevant sites to our site and
it may not just necessarily have to be a
link because google recognizes linkless
backlinks so just having a reference on
a high quality site may be good enough
to get you in the eyes of google to
become more relevant okay so that's
off-page seo in definition so really
what we want to do is we want to
establish a way to get links from other
websites to our own or references on
other websites to our website we want to
build those links to help us gain in
ranking so there's lots of ways to do
that you have social media again you
have social content sites like reddit
medium quora you have blogging okay
there's lots of ways to establish
yourself out there on the internet you
just need to make sure they're quality
sites and you need to make sure they're
relevant and so when you do get a link
on an external site pointing back to
yours you want to make sure it's a
follow so you want to make sure that
google knows to follow that link from
that site to yours so if you're out
there establishing content on a
third-party website or another website
and they're going to link back to you
just make sure that it's a follow do
follow not a nofollow okay and i'm going
to show you an example of what that
looks like here so if you're not sure
what the difference is here i'm on
backlinko.com
and
really a no-follow versus they do follow
is simply in the href so
in the href if you don't have anything
in there other than the link then the
search engines are going to follow that
link from that external site to yours
and
if you have a no follow in that link
then the search engines are going to
ignore the link so you're not going to
pick up the backlink or external link to
your site and that's simply that site
just adding the rel equals nofollow okay
so if you see that in the link pointing
to your site from that external site
then that means you're not going to get
credit for that backlink so you always
want to shoot for
a do follow link because that means
you're going to get credit for the
backlink okay so again do follow links
allow searching and crawlers to follow
the link and if they can follow it
you're going to get what they call link
juice and that's going to establish some
reputation to your domain a no follow
link basically doesn't allow the search
engines to follow that link so
it doesn't pass on the link juice now
again search engines like google are
smart enough to pick up the association
between a website that talks about your
website and your website so meaning if
you don't have a link and you don't have
a if you have a nofollow link on that
site don't fret because you know google
has come a long way they're not
necessarily focused on links though it
does help so for example if you are on a
very prominent site and there's no link
then you still may get credit because
google does recognize linkless backlinks
and that's what they call a linkless
backlink it's just having a reference on
that site but you always want to try and
get that follow not the do not follow
okay so
here you can see an example of off page
seo okay like tripadvisor would be a
good example a link that redirects from
tripadvisor to
you know the oprah magazine as an
example so the oprah magazine is going
to get a
back link from tripadvisor to the site
so if google crawls tripadvisor then
they're going to be able to see this
link and if it's a follow link they're
going to give the oprah magazine that
domain credit from tripadvisor so for
seo because there's a two-pronged
approach involved you have on-page and
off-page a lot of tools here a lot of
tools so let's take a look at some of
these tools we're gonna look at google
keyword planner we're gonna look at moz
ahrefs look at some tools that will help
you with both on-page and off-page seo
so let's start with google's keyword
planner so why are we using google's
keyword planner because we want to find
keywords okay so we can't do on-page seo
we can't optimize our title tag and meta
description without a good keyword that
we want to be found for so what we want
to do is we want to go into google ads
now that's a pay-per-click platform okay
so if you want to be found via paid
search you're going to use google ads
but from an organic search perspective
we can use google's keyword planner so
we need a google ads account we have a
google ads account then all we need to
do is go to tools then we need to go to
keyword planner and the keyword planner
is a good tool because it allows us to
find those coveted keywords so we can
discover new keywords and that's exactly
what we're going to do so for example
we're going to find you know use the
keyword mail delivery if we have a
business that delivers mails to people
what keywords do we want to optimize for
so we're going to be in google ads we're
going to go to tools we're going to go
to keyword planner we're going to
discover new keywords and we're simply
just going to type in a keyword so we're
going to click get results and google's
keyword planner is basically going to
give us some information so the keyword
we chose was mail delivery and they're
telling us that on average over the last
12 months there's 22
200 search queries on average over the
last 12 months okay so i could see if i
click hover over the graph here i'm
going to be able to see
the average over 12 months okay so here
i can see the average over 12 months
from july to june 2019. so here what do
i want to do i want to look for trends
because here i can see the averages go
up and down a little bit but 22 200 is
the average over 12 months and then
google's keyword planner also tells me
how competitive that keyword is so
if it's highly competitive but it's got
a lot of search volume it could be a
keyword i may want to covet but the
beauty of the keyword planner is that
they also give you other keywords to
look at okay so mail delivery service
that's 49 500. okay so here you got some
other ones best food delivery service
9900
again some of these are very competitive
but some of them aren't and so you want
to be able to
do your due diligence do some analysis
and figure out
what keywords work best for you that
aren't going to be competitive but at
the same time
give you some search volume so if you do
rank for that keyword you should expect
x amount of clicks on that keyword based
on the volume so that's google's keyword
planner alternatively you can use a tool
like moz.com so if i log into moz we
have a tool called keyword explorer and
so here i can just type in that same
keyword mail delivery
targeting the united states in english
and moz is going to give me some
information on the keyword so here
they're going to give me a range in
terms of the monthly volume and they're
going to give me a difficulty score so
they're going to tell me how difficult
this keyword is so out of a score of 100
it's 53 and they're going to tell me
what my expected click-through rate
could be if i'm ranking for that keyword
more importantly they're going to
give me some other keyword suggestions
just like google's keyword planner so
here i can see prepared mail delivery
mail delivery service mail delivery
companies so there are a lot of
different suggestions of keywords that i
can choose from and if we scroll down we
could see
basically some mansions we could see the
analysis who's ranking for these
keywords so we can really get some
insight as to who's ranking how much
volume how difficult it is what my
estimates could be if i'm ranking etc so
a lot of information built into moz's
keyword explorer tool so moz's keyword
explorer tool could be a good option for
you if you don't have access to google
ads and google's keyword planner so if
you're working on seo for a website and
you curious is about what the off-page
seo situation looks like well you can
use a tool like age reps it's free tool
you can go here if you're working on a
specific domain and you're focused on
off page you could simply type in that
domain here and then you can check the
backlinks for that domain okay so i'm
going to go ahead and type in my my
domain and now i'm going to get a sense
of what my backlink profile is for my
domain so here i can see the number of
backlinks the total backlinks and notice
85 percent of them are do follow links
so google is able to recognize those
links and then i could see
referring domains so i have a 124
different domains pointing to my website
and so here i can get a snapshot of the
top 100 backlinks pointing to my website
and so this just gives me a snapshot of
what's going on with my off-page seo
performance again it's a free tool it's
good to use because it gives you an idea
of what your off-page seo situation
looks like okay another tool you could
use is pingdom okay you can set up a
free
trial here it's good for 14 days and it
allows you to
you know look at page speed it allows
you to monitor
the site itself in terms of you know
visitors maintenance etc so you can use
pingdom as well uh however it's only a
14 day free trial but it does give you
some good insights into seo now page
load time is one of those on page seo
factors and so if you're doing on-page
seo for domain you certainly want to go
into google analytics and you want to
measure the page load performance of the
pages on your website
and so here if i go to google analytics
and then i go to behavior and i go to
site speed and i go to speed suggestions
here i can see the pages how many pages
i've received over a period of time and
the average page load time now if you
see the average page load time is slow
and in my opinion anything over two to
three seconds is going to be slow
you need to be able to
take action and so the great thing about
google analytics the page load time
reporting is it actually gives you some
suggestions so page speed suggestions so
all you need to do is click on the link
here in this case this particular link
or url on my website has seven
suggestions if i click on that then page
speed insights is gonna open up and
what's gonna happen is google analytics
slash page speed insights is gonna
analyze this page and give me some
feedback on how the page is performing
not only on desktop but on mobile as
well and so here i can see if i analyze
this page i can see
some of the opportunities to improve the
page load time on desktop and again on
mobile here so here you can see a lot of
the opportunities and a lot of the
issues i have that i can address now if
you're going to manage seo for a website
then you're going to need an seo
platform so again moz is a good example
because we showed you the keyword
explorer but they also have many other
tools available built right into the
platform for example rankings okay you
can get crawl information so when the
bots crawl aside what kind of errors are
coming up here i can get some page
optimization so i can choose a keyword
and
i can choose a page and moz is going to
be able to give me feedback to see what
more i could do to improve my on-page
seo performance okay we mentioned
keyword explorer in terms of looking for
keywords okay you also have something
called link explorer as well so if i go
back and choose link explorer from my
list here then i'm to go to a link
explorer and i can type in any domain
again just like on the age wraps except
mods goes a little bit deeper here okay
so they're telling me how many linking
domains and what my keywords are ranking
okay and then i have some other reports
that i can leverage for off-page seo i
can look at spam scores for certain
websites that are linking to me because
you can disavow yourself from us being
associated with those sites here you got
a link intersect tool so you can compare
one domain against another
to what links are pointing to that other
website so a lot of different
reports and tools available to you for
off-page seo under moz's link explorer
so moz has a lot of different tools
available and again my recommendation if
you don't use moz there's semrush
there's bright edge there's a lot of seo
platforms out there to use but if you're
going to focus on seo you are going to
need
an seo platform now if you have any more
questions on seo you feel free to go to
simply learns youtube account you'll be
able to find a video there for seo
tutorial for beginners you know take a
look at the video it goes really in
depth about everything we just covered
about on page and off page seo so take a
look at the video
and if you have any comments about
everything we covered with seo feel free
to comment underneath this video here
and we'll be sure to respond accordingly
especially if you have any tips and
tricks that you do for seo so let's move
from search engine optimization to
content marketing and so content
marketing is a form of marketing that
involves
simulating interest in a brand's
products or services by creating and
sharing online material so we talk about
online material that can come in many
forms or assets so some examples are
blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
ebooks all of this is content generated
it's just in different forms and so you
want to be able to take any one of these
forms of content and be able to
distribute that in some form or fashion
okay so for example blog can be part of
your website a video could be something
you upload to youtube an infographic
could be something you actually share on
linkedin so all these other assets could
be integrated throughout they could be
shared or used on your website okay for
people to grab and share and use and
comment on okay so that's what content
marketing is you need to be able to push
out content so that people have a better
understanding of your product or service
the process of content marketing is you
really want to decide what goal you want
to achieve with your content marketing
campaign you want to define your buyer
personas to determine the audience best
suited for your content okay so what are
you creating who is it for and then you
want to run content on it to determine
the best type of content that can be
used and when we talk about content
audits we're talking about you know
content that's already been posted are
people sharing it are people downloading
or people viewing it and so you want to
be able to understand over time what
people are reacting to so that you can
reuse or continue to use that content
that seems to resonate with your target
audience so you want to choose an
appropriate content management system so
if it's a blog you want to use wordpress
maybe so you want to start brainstorming
for ideas for new content ideas so in my
opinion maybe put together a content
calendar and jot some ideas on that
content calendar then you want to settle
on a particular type of content you want
to create and then you want to be able
to publish and manage your content so
some top popular tools used for content
marketing you have buffer you have
buzzsumo followerwonk hootsuite so let's
go ahead and take a look at an example
of a content marketing management system
and
we're going to use wordpress and so if
we go into wordpress here
on the back end we're logging a login
and so the reason why we use wordpress
is because we can post blogs so
in wordpress if i go to post here i'm
going to be able to see all the
different posts that have been posted
over a period of time and the great
thing about wordpress
is you can optimize it for seo so if i
go in here and look at this recent blog
post that has been posted i can go ahead
and edit it and when i edit it okay i'm
gonna be able to look at this blog post
in a visual format and i can also look
at it in html form so notice i the great
thing about wordpress is i can use
imagery i can insert videos i can insert
infographics i can attach a white paper
case study to it and then again we have
something called yoast seo plugin so
we've installed a plugin here so that'll
help us
with optimizing that particular blog
post for that particular keyword we're
trying to target and so here you can see
our focus keyword is remarketing and
retargeting okay so we have that in the
title tag okay we also want to make sure
it's in the meta description and so here
we have an internal link we have it in
the introduction okay we have it you
know spread throughout the content so
yoast does a good job of allowing us to
make sure we're integrating that keyword
into our blog post but the key to blog
posting is we want to again follow the
process we want to be able to choose
content for our intended audience in
this case with a blog post we can write
up to
you know 500 to 3 000 keywords and the
whole point is we're trying to introduce
our audience to a particular topic that
resonates with our product or service
and so that's the great thing about
blogging that's the great thing about
wordpress is that you know very easy to
use
you can integrate it with seo
you obviously have commenting you have
different plugins that you can add in
there
very easy to edit and so a lot you can
do here with wordpress and blogging so
another example of content marketing is
video
so with video you have the ability to
upload this video to
popular video sites like youtube or
video and you can optimize that
particular video with title tags and and
hashtags and descriptions and you could
see the interaction here so you can see
how many views how many likes shares the
ability to share the ability people for
saving it and there's just a lot of
interactivity when you have video you
can also use video as i mentioned on
your blogging platform if it's wordpress
you can also use video and social media
platforms like twitter linkedin
and facebook so video is a very popular
form of content marketing lots of good
video tools out there to create a video
a high quality video is what you want to
put your product at service in the best
forefront okay so that people can react
they can share they can comment they can
follow they can like okay so that's what
you want to do is think about video
because video is very versatile and
powerful in terms of getting your
message out there so let's move from
content marketing to social media
marketing and
social media marketing really involves
creating content if it's that blog if
it's that video that you created for
content marketing and really using
different platforms to increase your
visibility whether that be traffic
whether it be engagement whether it be
brand awareness or any other marketing
goals that you have that's what social
media is good for because social media
will take that content take what you're
trying to get out there and really allow
you to hone your marketing goals against
that okay so if it's facebook and you
got some videos that you want to post up
there okay what's your goal is your goal
to then post the video to get traffic to
your website or to build brand awareness
or to just get people to react by
sharing or liking and so that's what
social media is good for it's really
good for taking content and really
distributing it to your target audience
okay so
sharing content allows you to you know
generate user generated content or it
allows you to create interactive content
and again you can use infographics or
you can apply content with imagery or
post videos or do things that are
interactive like polling and contest so
a lot of flexibility in terms of the
content that you could share on social
media and so you want to establish a
process for social media marketing so
this is the digital marketing course of
it so you want to be able to have a
process and you want to be able to set
up goals that you want to achieve with
your social media campaign because just
posting content for content sake is
really not going to generate anything
for you so you want to set up those
goals ahead of time then you want to
understand what content would be best
suited for your target audience so if
our goal is to generate brand awareness
then maybe
an infographic is what we want to do
okay maybe that's the best choice of
asset for
our target audience based on the
platform with social media we also want
to research what the competition is and
find out what works for them so it's
very easy to do on social so if you
already have a competitor on facebook
you can always go to your competitors
website and you can always see
you know what they're posting and what
kind of reaction engagement they're
getting for a particular post so it
doesn't help before you go live to do
some due diligence about your
competition you can also conduct a
social media audit and again what we
mean by audio just like on the content
side we want to be able to see what's
worked and what's not worked in the past
and with digital marketing recall you
can get instant metrics back so if you
posted something last year and you're
thinking about posting it again you
probably want to do an audit to see
over the past year what posts have
worked and have not worked for you then
you want to pick and choose the social
media channels or platforms and to find
a strategy for each of them because if
you have a video then the video may work
on say youtube or instagram but may not
necessarily work for linkedin and
twitter and so you want to be able to
pick and choose the asset the strategy
and align it with the appropriate
platform then you want to take
inspiration from case studies and other
famous brands so again continue to learn
i mean that's the beauty of social media
marketing most big companies
medium-sized companies even smaller
companies that have performed well
are out on social media so take a look
at some other companies that inspire you
or some other companies in your industry
or even again your competitors and see
what they're doing and what they're
posting and what kind of engagement
they're getting so you should always you
know be able to seek out what others are
doing on social and to me this is
important create a social media content
calendar and this isn't necessarily the
very end of the process this goes back
to the beginning of the process so when
you're establishing goals and you're
establishing what kind of type of
content you want to use that should all
be part of a social media content
calendar and i'm going to show you an
example of one here shortly and then
again you want to be able to
test evaluate and adjust your strategy
because again you're getting metrics and
if you post a video on facebook and it's
taking off then meaning in terms of
likes and shares you probably want to
consider maybe doing another one that
complements that so here's a broad
example of a content calendar again it's
in a spreadsheet again by no means
there's one size fits all but just to
give you an idea if we're blogging what
we want to do is we want to pick our
target audience maybe that be country or
particular demographic and you want to
come up with some topics ahead of time
here and you want to maybe put the
status up there of you know it's just a
draft or an idea when it actually does
go live you want to turn it on live you
want to pick your date add some comments
okay create your content and you know
what's good about a content calendar you
can also work in seo so you can assign
keywords and then you could add those
keywords to moz for ranking uh you can
create your title and meta description
then you can carry that content forward
and choose a particular social media
platform to post to so
that's the beauty of a social or excuse
me a content calendar is it allows you
to think about things front and then
prepare the content accordingly so you
can optimize it for organic search and
post it on social media for off page seo
and for social media marketing and so
you just want to get organized ahead of
time using a spreadsheet in this case
google sheets to lay out the topics
ahead of time so you can write the
content for your intended audience that
to me is the way to go now remember
there's lots of different forms of
content that you can use with social
media marketing here we have video so
you can see this video can be posted on
youtube or linkedin or wherever and the
whole point is you want to be able to
measure engagement here you can see this
is just an image it's just a file and
this has been posted on facebook so here
we can see many likes and comments and
then shares and so you want to be able
to leverage different forms and
different assets across social media to
see actually what works and what doesn't
work and again look at what other
companies have done whether they be
competitors or not see what type of
assets they're posting and what's
working for them now when it comes to
social media marketing there are lots of
tools available okay you got buffer
hootsuite sprinkler post planner later
sprout social i mean the list of social
media marketing tools is endless and
just like seo you will need a platform
to work with so with seo we showed you
moz as the seo platform with social
we're going to show you sprout social
because with sprout social if you have a
content calendar if you have a lot of
different assets you want to be able to
organize those assets and content across
multiple channels and the great thing
about using a social media calendar is
yes you can publish and organize your
post accordingly you also have most
social media platform tools have
listening so you can listen in on
keywords and audiences different brands
and industries and conversations that
are being had about a specific topic
okay and again most social media
platforms if not all have reporting and
so this is important because you can
actually see
you know what how your post or different
assets are performing in terms of
engagement and so to me that's important
if you're going to focus on social media
as a platform as a channel you want to
have a social media platform tool that
will help you organize your content
publish it accordingly listen in and and
get that report to help you figure out
what's engaging and what's not engaging
again so that you can you know react to
the content that you're using and
sharing so that's sprout social as an
example but you will need a social media
platform now the other benefit to
social media is in some cases you could
actually pay to have your post out there
and so for example on facebook we could
set up a paid campaign to target our
intended audience and so with facebook
facebook owns instagram so you have the
ability to really put your content out
in front of your target audience on
facebook and instagram and so
what you need to do is go to facebook
ads manager and simply just create an
account or campaign um you want to be
able to create a campaign and by
creating a campaign that means you're
gonna have to go
through a particular process here so
if we first we want to do is choose our
objective okay so you always want to
have an objective for your campaign so
is it going to be brand awareness is it
going to be to drive you know traffic is
it going to be to drive conversions so
you want to choose a goal or objective
if you're advertising really on any
platform then you want to be able to
choose your audience so who are we
trying to target so with facebook you
know you can target any specific age
gender demographic based on interest and
behavior so you can choose specific
placements and you can assign a budget
okay and then on the ad side you have
different types of ads that you can use
you can do a single image or video you
can do a carousel okay meaning you can
rotate different images as a collage or
different videos as a collage and again
you can choose exactly where you want
your ad to be shown for example desktop
or mobile news feed
facebook in-stream video
you got instagram feed you got even
messenger so you have a lot of options
available to you on where your ad or
video is going to be shown and then you
can support that with a headline
description and you can send that
traffic back to your website you can
even test call to action buttons okay so
you can append your ad with a call to
action button and so you can do a lot
here this is just facebook you can
really do a lot of specific targeting
now with facebook advertising it's a
cost per click model so anytime somebody
does click on that ad you're going to
pay but it allows you to really
get your content out there in front of
your intended audience if you're not
doing it organically meaning you're not
posting on facebook on a regular basis
or maybe you want to supplement those
organic posts then
doing this is a good way to really get
your brand out there if it's awareness
if it's to drive traffic or to convert
facebook is a good option linkedin
twitter all these social media platforms
offer that up that option up to do paid
advertising now if you want more
information about social media we have a
great video on youtube already how to
start social media marketing it really
goes into the details about organic
social and what i just covered with paid
social specifically on facebook so take
a look at that video and again if i
missed anything on the social media side
feel free to comment or add in your best
practice whether that be part of the
process or a different platform that you
use for social media okay let's switch
to our next digital marketing channel in
search engine marketing so search engine
marketing is an advertising model
that is good for driving traffic to your
site because you're paying each time
someone clicks on your advertisement now
how is that an equal trade well
because you can advertise on channels
like or search engines like google or
bing or adroll which has a a big network
that includes google you can actually
pay your way to the top of search engine
rankings and so if you're at the top for
paid search
and somebody searches something like
shoes or something to that effect your
ad can appear at the very top even above
local search even above organic search
and so the visibility is there it's a
good way for you to then get that
traffic that uh that you you'll covet
for certain keywords and because you're
getting traffic or have the potential to
get traffic you're gonna pay each time
somebody clicks on these ads so
you have multiple choices on the type of
asset you want to use including text
image video etc so
there's more to it than just google bing
ad role i mean you have linkedin you
have twitter you have facebooks you have
lots of different ways to advertise and
get your ad in a more prominent position
you just have to pay for it and i just
showed you that under social media
marketing facebook you can create an ad
have your ad targeting your audience and
in return you're going to pay facebook
works the same way for most of these
networks okay so when you actually set
up a campaign
like anything you do when you set up a
campaign you want to determine the goal
you want to achieve for the campaign you
want to do that up front especially when
you're talking about paying per click if
you're paying per click then you
definitely want to make sure you
determine what your goals are so you can
measure them accordingly then you want
to choose in this case a relevant list
of keywords you could do it for your
brand meaning you could choose your own
brand keywords you could choose keywords
related to what your brand is trying to
offer whether that be a service or
product and
once you choose a relevant list of
keywords you can finalize those keywords
and then bid on them so
once you start bidding on them then what
you're going to do is align those
keywords with a headline so it's all
done within the framework of any
platform you're advertising on really
the key here that i want to really
emphasize is when you establish a
campaign or set up a campaign you need
to establish what the goal is because
when you actually choose your keywords
and write your ads and launch the
campaign and start paying google or bing
or whomever
it is you're advertising with you want
to be able to measure those goals so
that's really the important part here
because
regardless of where you advertise you're
going to be able to monitor campaign
results and so with google you can even
import conversions into the campaign so
for example if i go to google ads for
example if i go to tools okay you can
see i'm running campaigns what am i
trying to accomplish with these
campaigns well in this case i'm trying
to get donations people click on
donations so i can go to tools click
conversions and then i can see what
conversions are added to my account and
that way i can measure my campaigns
against these conversions okay if i
don't see a conversion error i can
certainly create one or import it from
in this case google analytics so that's
the important thing you want to be able
to measure your campaigns
with your conversions and then just as
important you want to be able to
optimize your campaign because if it's
not performing if you're running a
campaign you're running up cost and
you're not getting conversions you're
probably not going to be continuing to
run those campaigns so you want to
optimize your campaign and re-target
potential customers so retargeting is
always a good option retargeting is
targeting someone who that went to your
website and basically
acted in a certain way meaning they went
to a certain page or abandon the card or
actually purchased or downloaded
something okay you define what action
you want that audience to take in order
to retarget to them okay so the whole
point is you can configure your
retargeting campaign based on certain
behavior on your website and the whole
point there retargeting is you're
pulling people back to your website so
in addition to optimizing you know
search campaigns you can one of the
benefits of search engine marketing is
you can run retargeting campaigns so
here's an example of an ad okay so here
you can see
it's a good ad in the sense that
it's using everything available to it so
for example here i could see three
headlines so google in this example
allows you to add in three headlines so
here you can see simply learn official
site get certified get ahead then you
can see simplylearn.com
so they're taking advantage of three
headlines and then here you can see two
description lines and so each
description line you can have up to 90
characters and so you want to be able to
take advantage of what google gives you
the more information you can add the
better well here you can see some other
types of ads here you can see a banner
ad for slack okay here you can see
betterment.com running an ad okay so
this looks like an ad that is on youtube
so because you could see
after a few seconds you can skip the ad
okay so here's a video at here's an
image ad here's a text ad so depending
on what platform you advertise on you
have an option on what type of asset you
want to use you know the one thing i
like about facebook is they offer up a
multitude of options in terms of assets
so you can run a single image ad you can
run a carousel meaning you get a
multiple images you can run a video you
can run a combination video image you
could obviously run text okay with a
thumbnail so you have a lot of options
in terms of the type of ad you can run
so before we move into our next channel
let me just show you an example of you
know how an ad actually looks on a
particular website so here you can see
i'm on buzzfeednews.com
okay here you can see
uh volkswagen golf is running an
advertisement in spanish on this
particular site so
they're either using google or some
other platform and having that platform
if it's google post their ad on this
particular site so here you can see it's
a banner app and if we're in google ads
and you're setting up a text ad let me
just run through you with the text that
it looks like remember you want to
always take advantage of what's offered
to you because especially text ads you
have very few characters and with very
few characters it's hard to get your
message across so with google you have
your final url which is where people are
going to go to after they click on your
ad but you have one not one not two but
three headlines that you can take
advantage of so we're talking about help
and child hunger help today you know you
can always add in visit our website for
more info i mean you want to take
advantage of what's available to you now
again here you can see in this example
i'm only allotted 30 characters and so
if you go over then your ads not going
to get approved so you really have to be
cognizant
of the character counts and getting your
point across because writing text ads is
not the easiest thing to do when you're
limited to characters now with google
you have what they call display path so
after the domain you can add in a couple
of keywords in there and then you have
description line one and description
line two so again take advantage of
what's available if you're not sure what
copy to write grab some from the website
and paste it in there you want your ads
to be healthy and to have as much
information as possible and then the one
thing i will say about google ads is
they also have extensions so extensions
are exactly that they're extensions to
your text ad so here you can see i have
four extensions these are actually site
links so google ads offers up something
called ad extensions so it could be call
outs site links can be location
extensions app extensions they have a
number of different extensions that they
can append to your ad so take advantage
of that as well remember the whole point
of ads is to make a compelling case for
your product or service so that somebody
can click on the ad and go to your
website and then perform the action you
want them to perform now if you have any
more questions about google ads feel
free to check out our in-depth video
about google ads it covers everything a
to z on google ads you know we also have
videos on our simply learn youtube
playlist for facebook uh twitter social
media marketing so if you're curious to
know a little bit more about search
engine marketing you know check out any
one of these videos that we have listed
on our youtube channel okay so let's
move over to affiliate marketing now and
so with affiliate marketing
really it's interesting and unique and
that affiliate marketing involves paying
out commissions and who are you paying
commissions to while you're paying
commissions to website owners or
publishers or people who have websites
with lots of content or people who have
websites that attract a lot of users and
so the whole point is you want to be
able to find those websites to advertise
your product or service okay these
people who are selling your product or
service on your behalf are going to get
commissioned or incentivized based on
whatever action you put out there so
it could be registrations just getting
your affiliates to help you with
getting people registered or signing up
for your email or you know for a lot of
you conversions you're trying to sell a
product so you want help in selling that
product or it could be subscriptions
okay signing up to something okay so
you determine what it is you want to
incentivize your affiliates for you also
determine how much you're going to
incentivize them and that's the great
thing about affiliate marketing it's
it's no different than having a sales
team um to support you what are the
steps for affiliate marketing well you
need to find a platform there are lots
of different affiliate platforms out
there you know commission junction or
cj.com comes to mind because these
platforms are going to help you find
these affiliates or partners okay so
they're the broker and all this and
so once you set up your platform you're
going to establish rules guidelines post
images and banners and assets for those
affiliates to use on their websites and
more importantly again you're going to
establish the commission so the
commission doesn't have to be the same
for all affiliates it could simply be
you know your top affiliates get a
higher commission as opposed to just
some other affiliates who get a starting
commission you establish everything on
the platform the affiliate platform that
you choose now affiliates apply to
advertise on your behalf so they're
going to say hey i'm interested in
selling your product or service so
you're going to use that platform if
it's commission junction to approve or
disapprove the re affiliates request to
advertise on your behalf and really what
you want to try and do is leverage the
platform as best as you can a lot of
these affiliates are out to make money
and some of them are really good you
need to be able to choose the affiliate
that is going to represent your brand
product or service the best so it's
simple customer clicks on an ad or link
okay on that affiliate website and they
go to your website and they perform an
action so that could be a purchase a
registration a subscription a download
an email sign up you determine that and
the great thing is these affiliate
networks the cj's commission junctions
of the world will record everything
they're tracking not only traffic from
the affiliate website to your website
but they're also tracking the
conversions the transaction is validated
and credited to the affiliate by the
broker and then the affiliate has paid
his or her commission so that's how it
works so the more the affiliate sells or
converts on your behalf the more they're
going to make and that's the beauty of
the affiliate network so here's an
example of affiliate marketing okay here
you can see
uh an advertisement here okay so you can
see profit from our experience earning
up to 12 advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce list leader so somebody
clicks on that link joins and then this
person is going to get a commission
based on somebody joining for free again
i mentioned commission junction there
are also some other affiliate marketing
tools out there
uh
amazon associates a win trade doubler
max bounty i mean there's a there's
there's a lot out there
cj.com is the one i've used in the past
but you know give some of these other
platforms a chance okay it doesn't hurt
to even be on multiple platforms you
have nothing to lose okay when you're on
a platform basically the platform again
is acting as the middle person they're
introducing you to affiliates and so
every time you actually pay an affiliate
a commission they're going to get their
cut of it so they're going to get a
small percentage as well so just keep
that in mind but you know give it a try
try one or two of these affiliates if
you find you're getting quality
affiliates that are selling your product
or service great if you don't then you
know feel free to change you know
affiliate networks it's that simple but
the key here is
find the affiliates you think are going
to best represent your brand product or
service because those affiliates are
likely going to be the ones to convert
for you and if you're small business
starting out and you need some help
affiliate marketing is the way to go
okay let's move over to native
advertising okay so native advertising
so negative advertisements means that
your ad is showing up next to content
that basically
naturally fits so these are advertisers
that are featured on a platform
alongside the content okay that isn't
paid for okay so for example here you
can see a paid post okay this is by
spotify okay this paid post okay was on
buzzfeed this particular post was
probably on a news article related to
music because they're talking about your
bands that probably won't exist without
led zeppelin okay so for spotify
you're using native advertising allows
them to put their ad next to content
related to their ad here you can see
another buzzfeed article okay 11 great
amazon deals that will be music to your
ears if you're an audiophile here you
can see
an advertisement next to the article so
you can see the ad about led zeppelin
and here you can see the actual article
is about music so the whole point about
native advertising is making sure
there's a connection between the ad and
the article so spotify is advertising
okay their product and service on an
article on buzzfeed which happens to be
about music so a good example we used
buzzfeed just a second ago so if we go
to buzzfeed here you can see i'm on tv
and movies and here you can see got an
ad here if we scroll down
uh keep scrolling down we can see
another ad here for hbo and so this ad
makes sense because
it's placed on tvs and movies so people
who go and read the content are going to
see an ad related to that content so
that's generally what native advertising
is you need to be able to be able to
place the ad on the right pages okay so
you're going to need an ad network for
that so we talked about paid search
advertising we talked about google ads
so google ads has the ability to place
your ad natively on particular pages
that are relevant to that ad so that's
really what native advertising is all
about making sure that your ad is placed
next to content that's naturally
relevant so if you need more information
about affiliate marketing feel free to
visit simply learns youtube channel we
have a nice uh in-depth video about
affiliate marketing to get more
information about the platforms how it
works and all the tips and best
practices about how to run a successful
affiliate marketing campaign so let's
turn our attention to email marketing
now so email marketing very traditional
form of digital marketing it's been
around the longest it's kind of the
grandfather of all digital marketing
channels so email marketing really is
used to personalize emails in order to
convert that recipient or that
perspective user into a customer and so
like all the other digital marketing
channels we want to follow some type of
flow or process or methodology and the
first step in email marketing is you
have to identify your target audience
okay when you identify your target
audience you're gonna create a segment
okay so in other words you don't want to
send one email to everyone because not
everyone is going to be interested in
that email so in order to get somebody
interested you need to be able to send
an email tailored to that audience okay
so that audience can respond and react
accordingly so once you target that
audience and create segments email
segments you're going to create the
campaign and set up an appropriate call
to action one note here is when you
create the campaign and set up that
appropriate call to action that call to
action is going to be aligned with your
goal so what is the goal of the email
campaign is it simply to get people to
click on something and purchase or is it
simply to get people to click on
something and sign up or watch something
or submit some information or download
or whatever the case you need to
establish that up front just like you
would with a search engine marketing
campaign or any other type of campaign
you want to run
so
there are lots of tools out there just
like with affiliate marketing you want
to choose an appropriate email marketing
tool there are plenty to be had each
work in a very similar nature
some offer different pricing models
meaning you know you can send an email
to x recipients for flat fee or you pay
a small amount per email address each
one is slightly different in terms of
how they price but in terms of the
features they all work in a very similar
fashion and we're going to show you an
example of one here shortly so
when you choose that email marketing
tool you're gonna test your emails
before you send them out and then when
you test your emails you're gonna use
that email marketing tool to actually
send the campaign after it's been tested
okay so you want to send the campaign
you can immediately send them out or you
can schedule them now a best practice
with an email is when you actually send
one out you're sending an email out to
your target audience you want to create
probably two emails per segment audience
why because you want to add an
attractive subject line and copy to the
email but if you send two emails to the
same target audience then you want to
test the subject lines you want to be
able to see what subject lines going to
entice somebody to open the email okay
that's the beauty of email marketing is
you can do that okay so you can set up
your a design based on your target
audience but it's always the subject
line that people see first so you want
to write an attractive subject line and
copy that's going to entice somebody to
open the email so why not send two
emails to each target audience that way
you can see what email subject line
works best so that's the whole idea
about performing a b test to test out
different ideas it doesn't necessarily
have to be a subject line it can be the
same subject line two emails but the
difference being the body of the email
it's totally up to you but the idea here
is to always split out your emails per
target audience and just like any other
channel whether it be affiliate or
search engine marketing organic search
you want to analyze performance and in
the case of emails it's always about
open rates how many people are opening
then how many people are clicking and
then how many people are actually
responding are they converting or
downloading or whatever it is you want
them to do you need to be able to
monitor the behavior because for example
if your open rates don't work or they're
low then you know something's wrong with
your subject line so you want to be able
to make an adjustment so here's an
example of an email from airbnb it's a
simple email okay they're just simply
trying to get somebody to click on that
call to action to take the survey okay
that's really all it's about here with
this particular email so who's their
target audience well their target
audience could be somebody who's already
stayed at
a airbnb property or it could be
somebody who used the app probably
airbnb has already targeted this
audience and they're sending this survey
to a particular audience so that they
can get the best results okay so that's
a good example of a targeted email with
a good call to action that's getting
somebody to take the survey so they're
probably measuring how many people
opened it how many people clicked on the
cta the call to action and then how many
people actually filled out the survey so
you need to follow each step and track
each step accordingly okay so again some
popular tools used in email marketing
let's take a look at mailchimp here uh
but i will mention like marketo is a
good marketing automation tool now owned
by adobe marketo allows you to send
those drip campaigns so if somebody
doesn't purchase right away you can send
up follow-up emails like say one day out
or seven days out or 14 days out so
hubspot works in a very similar fashion
you want to be able to methodically plan
out your emails that's the point i'm
trying to make here so let's take a look
at mailchimp so if we go over into
mailchimp a very easy interface okay
here if we go under audience we can
actually see who our audience is and we
can break out our audience into
different groups you can have a simple
test list you can have people who
purchase people who subscribe to
something okay so you can break out your
audience into different groups okay when
it comes to campaigns you can see
campaigns that are already been built or
you can create your own campaign okay so
in the case of mailchimp we can actually
see
what campaigns have been dropped or sent
out already and then we can see
the opens the clicks and then the
conversions so mailchimp has some nice
reporting so you want to be able to
measure
the reports or how well the campaign
performed so here we could see
specifically how many people open
clicked how many people bounced or email
addresses bounced and how many people
unsubscribed from the list and here we
can see
you know the top links that have been
clicked okay the subscribers with the
most opens did anybody perform any
social media activity okay what
locations open the email okay so you can
actually see a lot of good information
here right in mailchimp and you want to
be able to react to the emails you send
out so if an email is not performing
okay you want to learn from that so you
don't make the same mistake again great
thing i like about mailchimp too they
have a lot of nice templates to use so
if you're trying to create a template
here you got some templates that you can
leverage so that's mailchimp kind of in
a nutshell mailchimp you could pay
upfront buy credits and with those
credits you could send out emails to a
number of people okay so that's how
mailchimp works they do have a free
trial so you can set up an account using
the free trial now if you need any more
information about mailchimp or email
marketing in general take a look at the
email marketing webinar we have set up
on our simply learn youtube account now
let's finish up with online pr press
releases so we talked about seo and
social and search and affiliate and
email marketing and and content native
advertising let's talk about online pr
here because with online pr
it really does involve
working with digital publications or
blogs or other content related websites
for example
content related websites could be
newspaper digital newspaper sites like
the new york times okay the whole point
of
online pr is you want to try and get
some publicity on those on those
websites publicity means awareness for
the brand it means traffic to the
website and eventually some loyalty
future customers and conversions
channels that can be used to maximize
your online pr efforts for example you
can connect with reporters on social
media to develop a relationship so you
can just follow some reporters see if
they're covering specific uh industries
or verticals and if they are similar to
what you're offering then it's probably
a good idea to reach out to them you can
use engaging user reviews to help
humanize your brand or you can respond
to comments that help generate
productive conversations so those are
all certain things you can do
to generate awareness and buzz for your
brand so really the one thing i want to
point out about online pr is basically
you can also hire a pr firm and they can
do some of the heavy lifting for you
or like i said you can reach out to
different reporters or different
influencers even to help push your
product or brand now if you're trying to
go at it alone on the online pr what you
could do if you don't reach out to
reporters or influencers or you're
active in trying to build your brand
through a conversation you can always
use a third party service like pr.com so
pr.com allows you to
you know basically create your own
profile you know submit content to your
own profile or even submit press
releases if you submit press releases
then other news agencies are going to
pick up on those press releases so it's
a good way to get your press releases
out there likes of yahoo and google
might pick up those press releases and
give you some you know much needed
visibility you can also use other tools
like you know pr newswire for example so
it works in a very similar way
again it's a press release distribution
network so you can go ahead and sign up
for an account get that press release
out there and they do the distribution
for you or you can also use aggregation
sites so there are lots of different
aggregate sites out there and so what
aggregate websites do
is they help disseminate and distribute
your content so here you can see
some of the new aggregator websites of
2019 you got feedly
panda
tech mimi
metacritic e science news the morning
news so you have a lot of options
available to get your content out there
okay so what these sites do is basically
pick up articles that fit their website
fit their theme fit their target
audience so you do have options in the
form of third-party tools as well okay
so if you don't hire a pr firm which
could be expensive you can certainly go
at it alone by signing up for any one of
these particular products or services
carl has a website on cake recipes
unfortunately his website on google is
not ranking well
moreover when searching for cake recipes
keyword his website ranks way below than
his competitors
this can be due to various reasons but
one that sticks out is seo to solve this
issue i have a few important tracking
factors that carl needs to know and
apply if he wants his website to rank
well
before we get started with the ranking
factors let me first explain what seo is
seo is the practice of getting traffic
from organic search results on a search
engine like google bing etc depending
upon the keywords search engines rank
websites based on what content they
consider most relevant to users
without further ado let me tell you the
top 5 ranking factors which can help
carl to rank his website
first is content quality then it's page
speed of a web page after that its
website structure
next is ssl certificates
and finally it's backlinks which is the
most important ranking factor let's have
a look at good content quality
a good content quality is an essential
factor that helps a website to rank on
google
google ranks content that completely
answers a user's query
in our case cake recipes
also longer content rank higher on
search engine results
apart from longer content you can also
optimize your content with few
techniques such as you can start with a
comprehensive introduction
this article on the best vanilla cake
i've ever had is a good example of
having a comprehensive introduction
ensure to write content relevant to the
chosen keyword
for example if your keyword is cake
recipes ensure to write a content on how
to bake a cake rather than focusing on
cake decorating ideas
always create a click-worthy title and
include lsi keywords in your content
in seo lsi stands for latent semantic
indexing they are used to drive content
traffic and create more visibility on
serves an easy way to look for lsi
keywords is on google serve some of the
lsi keywords for cake recipes are easy
cake recipes vanilla cake recipes
chocolate cake recipes and a lot more as
shown on the screen
ensure your heading and subheadings
consist of keywords for example all the
heading and subheading for this article
have the keyword cake
build a comprehensive internal linking
structure of web pages it helps in
spreading link equity across the site
it is important to create a simple
internal website link structure
in the below example a bot crawls on web
page 2 by following internal link of the
webpage1 next add suitable images with
descriptive alt text here using relevant
images can help search engines
understand what your content is about
and this method helps in site ranking
for example for carl's website on cake
recipes he should use suitable images
like wedding cakes birthday cakes etc
incorporate call out boxes as it will
highlight the important information and
increase the dwell time for example if
carl wants to sell his cake he should
place call out box with contact details
immediately after the cake recipes
ensure your webpage is completely
crawlable for bots as it will enhance
website ranking here as you see this
website is high up on the google serp
because every web page in it is
crawlable by bots
next opt for mobile friendly designs it
will result in good user experience
for a mobile friendly design always
prefer short and crisp sentences for
easy reading
a poor example and a good example of
mobile friendly designs are shown here
and most importantly update the content
regularly by doing this search engine
rearranges your site's ranking
for example the sally's baking addiction
cake recipe blog ranks at number one on
google the reason it updates content
regularly next we have page speed
page speed defines how fast the content
of a web page is displayed on the screen
it is important to ensure that a page
speed isn't slow otherwise it will
result in high bounce rate paid speed
can be optimized through
improving your server response time
this can be done by fixing major issues
like slow database queries slow routing
or a lack of adequate memory
use a simple website design and reduce
the image size that is larger than 150
bytes
next use a content distribution network
as it distributes the load of delivery
content at multiple geographical
locations
you can also optimize your code minify
files if your website has numerous css
and javascript file you can minify and
combine
them google says slow page speed results
in high bounce rate as you can see here
next comes optimizing title tags and url
a title tag summarizes the website's
content and url is a web address
title tags are displayed on serps it is
a clickable headline for a given result
title tags are displayed on serps it is
a clickable headline for a given result
for example
chocolate cake recipe cake recipe carl
cake.com is a title tag of a website
where chocolate cake recipe is the
primary keyword cake recipe is a
secondary keyword and callcake.com is
the brand name
backlinko recommends writing a relevant
keyword in the title tag is important as
it gives an overview of what your
content is about
now talking about urls always refer a
well-structured short and simple url
according to backlinko analysis short
urls tend to rank better than long urls
moving on to our fourth ranking factor
let's talk about ssl certificate
websites using https server have a
higher chance of boost in rankings https
is used for secure communication over a
computer network
as you can see here google confirmed
https as one of the writing factors
there are two ways to improve site
security you can protect your domain by
enabling dns sec protocol or use hsts to
add an extra layer of security over
https whereas hsts protects from
hijacking
the next ranking factor is website
architecture
the famous digital marketer neil patel
says the better your site structure the
better your chance of ranking higher in
the search engines
also backlinko confirms that an
optimized website architecture helps
bots to find and index all of the web
page
a good site structure results and good
use experience
some of the ways to optimize your site
structure are creating a logical
hierarchy structure which means a good
site architecture not only makes content
easier to find but also helps to gain
traffic
[Music]
include site maps so that the bots can
easily access and index the content
code your site navigation in css or html
because these two languages are easy to
quote and understand
build a comprehensive structure of
internal linking as it improves indexing
of a website and helps in spreading link
juice
coming to our last ranking factor that
is backlinks
backlinks is an online navigation of
hyperlinks from other websites to your
own website
in this way we can drive referral
traffic and increase the website's
authority
in seo the more backlinks in a web page
receives the better it will rank in
google
backlinks enhances search engine
rankings brand awareness and referral
traffic
backlinks can be gained through
influencer marketing
engaging with audiences on multiple
social media platforms like telegram
linkedin etc
participating in high pr q a sites like
quora and post answers to the questions
related to your business
congratulations you have learnt
important seo ranking factors within 10
minutes
today we're going to talk about why you
would want to rank using seo and seo is
search engine optimization also known as
organic search you also may as hear us
say organic listings where we're going
to talk a little bit about why you'd
want to rank your website in organic
search okay what is search engine
optimization then we're going to follow
that up with how does google rank
websites so
why does it rank one website over
another and how do we get our website to
rank number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of seo or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're gonna finish that off
with the do's and don'ts of seo so let's
get right to it and talk about why seo
so we're gonna use a basic example and
let's just say you have a blog you're a
food blogger you're passionate about
food and your niche is ice cream and
let's just say you have a lot of ice
cream recipes you want to get traffic to
your blog you want people to read your
blog and you're curious why am i not
ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging along longer than
you when they have more content and more
blog posts and more pages for google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason the other reason is improper
usage of keywords and we're going to
talk a little bit or it's actually a lot
more about you know keyword usage in
your content so
what kind of keywords do you want to
rank for that's really what we're
talking about when we talk about usage
of keywords what keywords do you want to
rank for and how do we work those
keywords into the content another reason
is port link building practices and
really that means our other blog posts
or other websites linking to you also
are you linking to other pages on your
website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say wordpress
for example and your blog post isn't
loading fast enough well if you look at
it this way think about it if you're
google would you really want to rank a
website or blog post in this example
number one on google rankings if that
particular page loaded very slow no you
wouldn't because when somebody clicked
on that link in organic search and went
to your website they're going to have a
bad experience because the page is going
to load slow so google doesn't want
their users to have a bad experience you
don't want your users to have a bad
experience and so that's why web page
load time is a critical factor for
ranking so we need to make sure that our
web pages load fast and then your user
experience is not good enough so
google again based on my example about
the web page load time google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know google doesn't want any spam
content google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the webpage they
want people who are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a blog with a hundred recipes you want
google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on google organic search so
let's move on to what is seo so sticking
with our ice cream blog theme really seo
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for seo because that's exactly
how seo works it's exactly all those
points i just made mention about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in seo and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our pages
google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called the meta
description and then again the content
needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed's
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when i say response
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
etc on google search and then link
building remember i mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page seo
how does google rank websites and
basically google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your web pages they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to
basically rank the those pages that
they've indexed from number one to
infinity depending on how many pages are
relevant to that search query so really
it's about crawling indexing and ranking
so crawling is simply a process done by
which google has bots and what these
bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how do they find
these pages well they basically follow
links you might have heard the term
spydering but that's what they call
search engine spidering so basically
what google's doing is they're building
a web so to speak all the links that
they're following and so when they can
follow all these links on your website
they're going to be able to crawl them
and when they crawl them basically
they're going to take that content and
store it on their servers so it's
available in their index so based on
this method google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found then you're not going to show up
for relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to google search and if
i type in the keyword simply learn okay
i could see i have one million ten
thousand results okay and that's how
many results are showing up for simply
learn okay now they may not all be
simply learned pages but nonetheless
simply learned is ranked number one here
organically and there are 1 million 10
000 pages related to the keyword simply
learn now when it comes to organic
search we don't want to get it confused
with paid search so anytime you see paid
search you're going to see
something that says add next to it okay
so we could see that there are paid ads
here but when it comes to organic search
those are generally below paid ads and
so that's where google counts the 1
million 10 000 results and so that's the
whole idea behind crawling and indexing
google is able to crawl simply learn's
website and based on all the pages that
they gather they're going to make those
pages available in organic search so if
you type in a keyword and your web page
is not available for indexing then
you're never going to show up for that
keyword so that's why it's important to
make sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search google search
the most relevant websites that are in
google's index are going appear in the
search results so in the example i gave
was simply learn well simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learn so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is seo and why
seo we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned pages because that's who they
are simply learn however
simply learn also needs to make sure
that you know for their pages the page
load time is fast meaning these pages
load very fast for the end user and
google also takes into account other
factors like how long someone is staying
on a website or are they bouncing
meaning are they going to one page that
they land on and then leaving the
website okay and so the user experience
is very very important there are other
factors also like language and location
and so for example location if you do a
search say in india the results are
going to be a little bit different than
say the results in the united states why
because google is indexing as many web
pages as they can find so if somebody's
doing a search in india
their results may be a little bit
different than the results show up in
the us because google has different bots
and these bots are crawling different
pages at different times and so google's
index is updating continuously but it's
not real time syncing so if you do a
search in india you may not see exactly
the same thing because both search
engines the google and india and the
google in the us are may not be exactly
synced up so an example would be you
know if you're looking for cafe so if
you search a cafe and say san francisco
you're going to see different results
now if you do a search for cafes in
mumbai you're going to see different
results there's going to be local search
here at the top there may be some paid
search but again you may see
different results because one location
but two google search engines in india
and united states google.com aren't
exactly synced up exactly at the same
exact time you do that search so
location is important language is
important and relevancy is important
along with user experience so all those
are important factors in how google
ranks websites okay so we're going to
talk about the types of seo now so if we
want to rank for a particular keyword on
google we're going to have to apply
search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization on-page seo and off-page
seo so first we're going to talk about
on-page seo so on-page seo is nothing
more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do
is understand what keywords we want to
rank for in order to understand what
keywords we want to rank for we need to
do keyword research and if you do
anything in seo keyword research is the
most important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for seo and
why do i say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page seo you can
change the title tag the meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool i would
recommend is google keyword planner and
why do i choose google keyword planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so google is going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if i want to use google's
keyword planner and i want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then i'm going to
type that keyword into google's keyword
planner and what google's going to do is
they're going to give me some trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see
that
there are trends that that appear for
both desktop and mobile so mobile is
important because people start their
search process a lot of times on their
mobile device so we want to be able to
get data from mobile as well as desktop
and so we could see a trend here that
for each particular month over the last
12 months we can see how much volume
this particular keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist gets per
month and so on average on average over
the past 12 months i could see how to
become a digital marketing specialist is
averages 30 searches a month and this is
on google.com and so google gives us the
volume what they also give us is the
competition and so here i can see google
says for that particular keyword the
competition is medium and so in the
google's keyword planner what they also
do is give me other relevant keywords
that i might think about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword so how to become a
digital marketing specialist they're
going to also offer up other types of
keywords that are relevant so just
digital marketing specialist social
media marketing specialist so for those
keywords i can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist i
can see the average volume is 1 000 per
month on average of the last 12 months i
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what i would recommend as a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keywords in a spreadsheet and when you
put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data i'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from google planner google's
keyword planner and i have competition
from google's keyword planner and so if
i go into a spreadsheet and i put all
that information in here i'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that google's
keyword planner if we go back just gives
us low medium and high and if i want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe
i want to be able to
get exactly the competition number for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist what i can do is go
into google and i can type in that
keyword so if i type in the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
i can see there's 76 million results so
i could see 76 million results 76.1
actually and for the keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
now that's a whole lot of results for
this particular keyword especially when
the volume is only 30 uh per month on
average and so what i want to do is get
a more clear picture of the competition
and so what you could actually do is
type in the syntax all in title and then
colon and then your keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and when i do that i get a different
result here i can see only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136
with that particular keyword that we
want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see when you type in a
keyword or search query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top of every search result and so now i
can see i typed in how to become a
digital marketing specialist with the
all in title syntax and now i can see
every listing every one of these
136 results have that particular keyword
in it so i could see every one of them
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and why is that important
because now that tells me i only need to
climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from google's
keyword planner but you want to get your
competition from google search and again
that's simply typing in the syntax
hall in title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page seo so
again you want to
create content for
say a keyword like digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
google will truncate the title tag so if
i go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword then chances are it's going
to be relevant they're going to see it
and they're going to click through to
your website and that's the whole idea
behind ranking we want to get clicks so
that's how the title tag appears so when
you optimize it you're going to update
the title tag and this is how it shows
up it's going to show up at the top of
your listing okay and it's going to be
bigger and bolder than anything else
google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize is the meta description
and the meta description is simply just
a brief description up to a hundred and
fifty five i would say about 155 to 60
160 characters but probably no more than
that and so the meta description is
nothing more than a summary of the web
page itself so if i go back to my google
search results i see my title tag and i
see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where i can see my meta description
so in this particular keyword query how
to become a digital marketing specialist
i see the meta description an ultimate
guide on how to build a career in
digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist note that it's a well-written
meta description within 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialists so we're trying to
rank for how to become a digital
marketing specialist and here you can
see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description in the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave the
meta description blank then you're
leaving it to google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
seo we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal you're setting up your
brand and you need to make sure it
reaches the right audience and provide
the best results there's really only one
place to turn to it's one of the largest
online advertising platforms really in
the world and that's on google and so
today we're going to talk about how to
advertise on google and let's get right
to it and talk about google ads and
its effect with advertising
so we're going to start out with what
are google ads well google ads used to
be called google adwords and it's been
around a good while almost 20 years now
so really google has grown at a really
rapid pace it's become one of google's
main sources of revenue uh you could say
probably in the 90 percentile of its
revenue comes from google ads and when
we say google ads we mean people who pay
for advertising on google.com so google
ads really what it does is it provides
services that fall under the category of
ppc which stands for pay-per-click you
may also may hear google ads or ppc
referred to as cost per click or cpc or
sponsored search really what it comes
down to it's a model so when you
advertise on google.com and somebody
clicks on your ad basically you're
paying google for the click okay so it's
just really a business model where an
advertiser pays google to have their
advertisement on google.com but they
only pay google when they get the click
so that's really in a nutshell how it
works for advertisers if i want to
advertise my business i can go to google
ads and say google place my ad on
google.com and then my ad does get shown
on google.com somebody clicks on it it's
just as simple as i pay google a fee so
google ads is just an online advertising
platform developed by google with which
advertisers can pay to display ads they
can offer up their services there's
video involved there's obviously
mobile's involved so you got all the
necessary devices and platforms
available in google's ecosystem so for
example if i go to google search even if
i type in you know what is google ads
here i could see a total of 1.8 billion
results for what are google ads as my
search query so in search you got a lot
of different things going on here you
have organic results you have videos
that are being pulled from youtube you
got a knowledge graph here you got
feature snippets you got an organic
listing but really at the top this is
what we're going to focus on today we're
going to talk about sponsored search so
you can see here for this particular
keyword query that i typed in what are
google ads really to sponsor search or
pay-per-click ads appeared now if i
happen to click on any one of these two
and go to that particular advertisements
website they're going to pay google a
specific cost per click so that's how it
looks on google.com it really depends on
your query and what ads show up but the
great thing about your google ads is
they make it known for the user who's
doing the search query what the ad is so
here i can easily pick out what's an ad
a sponsored search or pay-per-click ad
and what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an advertiser
advertising on google.com i'm going to
be able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organic search here or even down here
doesn't have that little ad box next to
the listing so you know if it doesn't
have a little ad box you know it's a
paid search at now why do we want to
advertise on google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so
what i mean by that is you know search
is really a great place to advertise
because you're meeting the consumer
halfway meaning somebody's typing
something in and your ad is there to
help them find what they're looking for
so google ads advertises your product or
service to the relevant audience to
ensure the users perform the action
required of them so it's really a great
way to get quality audience to your
website because if somebody types in
something and you happen to offer what
they're looking for basically your ad is
going to show up somebody clicks on it
you pay google for the click and you get
quality traffic in return so the other
great benefit to being on google ads is
increases brand awareness so it's a
great way to get your product and brand
out there google has a vast network uh
also known as the display network but
even on google.com the search network
itself the search engine itself millions
of people use it every day in fact here
in the united states it's been said or
studied that you know people over the
age of 18 use search at least once a day
at least once a day here in the united
states so you can figure that's millions
and millions of people so it's a great
way to get your brand in front of a
large captive audience okay so top of
mind awareness refers to a brand of
product being the first one that comes
to a customer's mind when thinking about
a particular industry or category so it
really does provide top of mind
awareness another benefit to being on
google ads is retargeting so when we say
the word retargeting in marketing that
means you know showing our ad to
somebody who's already been to our
website so we can use google's display
network or we can run remarketing lists
for search as right on google.com to
ensure that we're targeting those folks
who have already been to our website and
have not performed a function that we
want them to perform such as converting
or buying something or downloading
something or subscribing to a newsletter
or visiting a certain page okay so if
somebody doesn't do what we want them to
do it's okay maybe they're ready to
commit to our product or service and
that's why google offers up retargeting
so it allows us to reach that audience a
second time so they're gonna be familiar
with their product they're gonna be
familiar their website because they've
been there and so we can offer up a very
unique specific ad to that audience so
that's a really good benefit to being on
google ads so some other benefits here
increased intelligence so you know we
can certainly get data about who is
coming to our audience so we can look at
what device what you know browser etc so
we can really gain some information
about who's coming to the website we
could certainly measure our performance
so with google we're paying cost per
click and so based on that model you
know we can certainly measure
what keywords what ads are generating
traffic to the website and how much
we're paying for that okay and if that
traffic turns out to be a lead we can
measure that against that specific
keyword or ad or campaign so we can
certainly measure our performance all
the way down the keyboard level and can
we can measure up against how many
conversions or what we're paying for
those conversions so google ads is a
very highly quantitative approach to
advertising because there's lots of
numbers involved and you're constantly
collecting information about your
advertising on google.com and its
network and another benefit really is
high flexibility so google ads has a
number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads dynamic
responsive ads video ads display ads so
google ads has very flexible options in
terms of advertising and we're going to
talk about some of those as we move
along here today so another big benefit
here and this is what i always suggest
is if you're not ranking organically
then you might want to consider google
ads because as we shown here in our
example if i go back to our example a
couple minutes ago you know if you want
to
bid on the keyword what are google ads
why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business maybe you're
in the digital marketing industry and
you want to help folks who need help and
advertising on google ads but what if
you want to be found for that
organically well if you're not found for
it organically then you can bid on it so
it definitely is a good option if you're
not ranking for a particular keyword
organically so it serves as almost an
option i always say that you know search
is like a fruit bowl okay you have
apples and oranges in that fruit bowl
well the orange is organic search and
the apple is paid search they're
different approaches but they share the
same fruit bowl the same real estate so
you can really really help yourself by
using google ads to complement what
you're doing organically so if you're
not ranked organically for keyword you
can certainly use google ads if you are
ranked for specific keywords and it's a
highly competitive industry then you can
use google ads to help you leverage the
amount of clicks you get from that ad so
it's okay to be organically listed and
have a paid search listing at the same
time so if we go back to our example
here we could see wordstream.com has a
paid ad and here we can see just two
spots below organically they're showing
up with an organic listing so you could
certainly be in both positions to try
and maximize your clicks so it's
definitely a good strategy to run with
google ads on top of everything we
mentioned in terms of measurement
flexibility google ads does offer up a
really good incentive to advertise and
let's not lose focus that again search
is really the only medium in which
you're meeting somebody halfway based on
what they're looking for and when i say
halfway meaning your ad is going to
appear for somebody who's looking for
something whether that be food a cafe a
plumber a doctor
or directions search is there to serve
that that person needs there's no other
advertisement platform or another
channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be tv or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps or also known as organic
search but the great thing is google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift focus now and talk about the
various formats in google ads on google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on google search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so jbl headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about google ads with with this text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also going to contain what we call
ad extensions so here you can see
shop by category in-ear headphones
on-ear headphones those are all site
link extensions meaning they're going to
link to something on your website and so
the purpose of the extension is to help
get the click so the reason why you're
running google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad i'll help you get
that click yes you're gonna pay google
for the click but that's the whole
purpose is to generate the click from
search because remember search is there
to respond to somebody's need or query
and so if you get the click on your ad
chances are it's going to be a highly
relevant visitor to your website so
google offers up a lot of opportunity
for you to write a lot of information in
your text ad on google for google.com so
google also has other formats and so
they also have responsive display ads so
when we say responsive we mean google
can serve up a specific image from your
website based on what somebody's looking
for based on the page that they went to
so these ads are responsive they adjust
their size appearance and format
depending on the space available so
responsive can also be text text and or
image and so the whole point of response
is if you have a large website let's
just say with a lot of different
products and categories like amazon well
it's hard to write static ads for
thousands of particular categories and
products so why not let google do the
heavy lifting why not let google serve
up the images and ads based on what
somebody looked at on your website and
so that's the whole idea behind
responsive ads is it allows google to
you know show the particular ad that's
most relevant to that user so it's a
really a great option when you're
advertising on google you have image ads
as well so image ads are as we mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay you can see just
an image app but the great thing about
image ads is you have a lot of different
size options so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160
by 600 all these are pixel sizes so you
have a lot of different size variations
when you run image ads okay so you don't
have to run a small image ad let's just
say in comparison to facebook where you
have a thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on facebook first
says google you have multiple multiple
sizes that you can choose from in terms
of running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if you're going to
advertise on google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so google
owns youtube so you can run
advertisements video advertisements on
youtube so they could be standalone or
they can be inserted into other
streaming video content as say pre-roll
meaning people are going to look at your
ad before actually watching the actual
video they went to youtube for so you
have a lot of different options with
video advertisements on youtube so the
other ad format you have on google are
shopping ads and shopping ads are really
a great way to get your product in front
of the right user so somebody's looking
for shoes or running shoes it's an
opportunity for you to run shopping ads
so you could put that particular shoe
with a description with the price with
your brand name in front of that user
and so with a cost per click model if a
user clicks on your shopping ad then
chances are they're probably going to
convert because they could see the
product they could see the price they
could see the product name they could
see the brand and so it's an opportunity
for you to really drive high quality
traffic to your site with the
opportunity to convert somebody at a
very high rate so shopping ads are
really good because it prevents unwanted
clicks if somebody clicks on that ad
they're definitely interested so let's
take a look on search to see how that
looks so if i go to google search and i
just type in running shoes so my search
results are going to list not only some
paid ads but a lot of different options
on shopping ads so here i could
certainly scroll around and see all the
different brand names i could see the
price point if i hover over it i can
actually see you know some other
information about it like reviews
return policy so if i actually click on
this ad chances are i'm going to buy it
otherwise why would i click on the ad as
an end user and so that's the great
thing about shopping ads it gives you
the advertiser an opportunity to really
get your products in front of people who
are looking for your product or service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily
have to be running shoes it could be
anything that you have to offer a user
so running shopping ads on google is a
good strategy if you have products okay
so you can showcase these these shopping
ads on google search by certainly
really giving google access to your
product inventory connecting in some
reviews connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up google shopping ads within google
search and the great thing about
shopping ads is it also pairs under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if i'm on google search you know i can
go to shopping or i can go to images and
i'll see those same image ads show up
here at the top and i will certainly see
those under shopping as well so shopping
ads allow you to really showcase your
products on google search to those
looking for that particular product so
it's really a great option with google
you also have call ads so when we say
call ads really call only ads are great
for mobile so when you run
advertisements on google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number they click on your number they're
actually going to call your business and
google can track that they can track how
many people click on your number and
even turn that into a conversion for you
so if you have a phone number associated
with your business it's wise to go ahead
and set up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the app because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to where is
google showing your ads i showed you an
example of google search so we looked at
text ads we looked at shopping ads on
google search network so google search
network really allows you to advertise
on google search so with google search
if i go back to google search and i go
to all i typed in running shoes okay
here i can see shopping ads here i can
see a couple of text ads so you have the
opportunity if you're running only text
ads to show at the top and if you're not
at the top then google will place you at
the bottom so really depends on the
keyword that somebody's querying in
google search so it really depends on
how many people are advertising and so
what google does if i didn't have any
shopping ads here google will list a
maximum of four text ads at the top and
at the bottom any other ads that weren't
shown at the top will get placed at the
bottom so ideally if you're running text
ads on google you want to make sure
you're always at the top and i would say
between positions one and three you
always want to make sure you're at the
top okay so you can certainly measure
that remember google had has measured
performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
going to advertise on google with a text
ads you want to make sure you're always
at the top so let's have a look at the
different types of search networks that
google ads is affiliated with so
the first is google search okay so let's
focus on google search and so basically
when we say google search or search
sites we really mean google.com or all
google search engines for that matter so
if you want to advertise to a mass
audience you want to probably start with
google.com because again millions of
people use it on a daily basis and so if
you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a google search so
if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query they're
going to see results now depending on
the device as well so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and
they could see organic search results so
for example this is what an ad would
look like so let me show you what that
looks like on google search so if we go
for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above
some featured snippets and the organic
search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again i've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if i scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we could
see simply learn here in the second
position why because again i can see the
logo add here okay so i can see simply
learn using three headlines i can see
simply learn using there are two
description lines here and i could see
simply learn using some other extensions
with the ad now all of this is geared
towards getting the click so when you're
on google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the
click okay so that's the whole idea
behind being on google search if you're
on google search you have the
opportunity to be at the very top of the
search result or in the top three above
local listings and above organic results
now if i change my search query and
typed in coffee in san francisco
my search results are gonna be
completely different i'm gonna see local
listings here okay so this is tied to
google my business not google ads okay
so this is completely different so don't
don't mix this up with
running ads on google search so google
my business is tied to local listings or
google maps and again with desktop which
is what i'm showing you the search
result on you're going to see likely
google local listings above organic
results okay and if i go back to my
previous query of classes on digital
marketing i'm going to be able to see
paid search results above local and
organic listings so in other words if
you're running ads ads are going to
trump any other type of results on
google search if you can be in positions
one through three now in addition to
google.com google also has something
called google search partners so if you
set up an account and you set up a
campaign in google ads you have the
option to choose google search as your
network and then as an alternative or an
additional option you can advertise on
google search partners sites and so some
of their search partners can range so
basically these are sites that have
partnered up with google that's allowing
google to
show ads on their site so the sites can
range anywhere between youtube to amazon
to new york times let's take a look at
an example it could even be another
search engine so if i go to say ask.com
and type in classes on digital marketing
it's a completely different search
engine but i can see the same ad for
simply learn so i can see same i could
see a different headline here actually
but i can see the description and i can
see some site link extensions and so
notice the ad is still at the top in
this case it's in position one and i can
see multiple companies running
advertisements why because they could
see ad next to it and i could see those
over
over organic listings so
these are google search partner listings
so you can opt in to be on other partner
sites that google or other sites that
google has partnered up with so you have
options outside of google search and
that option is display network so
display network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of google
search and if you're going to advertise
on google's display network you have
more ad formats available to you
including image and including a video
for example your ad can be found on a
specific
website if you choose to advertise on
the new yorktimes.com or webmd or
marriott.com you could certainly do that
okay you just need to tell google hey
this is the site i want to advertise on
so some of the advantages of being on
the display network so if you don't want
to advertise on google search okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're gonna grab the attention of
potential customers because of the
format of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so you're basically reaching out
to a large number of people on google's
display network and giving them an
opportunity to see who you are as a
brand and giving them an opportunity to
see what your product is all about so
for me the display network is a good
opportunity to get your product and
service in front of a lot of people
because the way the display network
works is it's a millions of websites who
want to have advertising on their site
and so you can really pick and choose a
specific site where your audience is
going to be and get your ad in front of
that audience so you can really retarget
to potential customers so
retargeting as we said earlier is really
reaching out to people who have already
been to your website and didn't perform
a particular function that you wanted
them to perform meaning somebody came to
your website from paid search on
google.com and they went to page a and
then they left so you really wanted them
to go to page b add a product to a
shopping cart and check out and purchase
that product however if they didn't do
that you could certainly
run ads knowing that they've been to
page a and page b and you can offer up
that specific ad to that person who's
been to your website and so that's what
retargeting really is all about and you
can retarget on google's display network
so remarketing your product to people
who previously visited your your website
or even your app allows you to really
get your ad in front of a qualified
audience and so you could take advantage
of analytics so google's ads has all the
information you need so let's actually
take a look at some of these options in
google ads for the display network so if
i actually go to google ads and i
actually go to display campaigns i can
see i have a lot of different options
available to me so if i click on
keywords for example okay i can choose
keywords for my display campaign so what
google does if you choose keywords
basically what they're doing is they're
going to contextually place your ad
based on the keyword okay so that's an
option for you if you're not sure what
websites to be on with the display
network you can certainly just add
keywords and based on those keywords
google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the splake network
you can say hey google i only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and so based on that
google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the display
network you can also choose topics so if
there's a specific topic that you want
your ad to be associated with you can
certainly do that so google has a number
of different topics at their disposal so
here if i just choose a particular ad
group now i have specific topics that i
can choose from arts and entertainment
food and drink to news to pets and
animals and so under each one of these
topics i can get really specific so if i
go under science i can see subcategories
under the topic science i can see
chemistry and physics and scientific
institutions and equipment so i can
really pick and choose specific topics
where i want my ads to be shown as i
mentioned already you can pick and
choose specific placements okay so if
you have a specific website that you
want your ad to be shown on you can
certainly let google know okay you can
also advertise on gmail you can also
advertise on youtube so you can really
pick and choose where you want your ads
to be shown so you have all these
different options available to you to me
one of the best options for advertising
on the display network because when you
tell google you have a specific audience
you want to target and that audience
could be somebody who went to a specific
page or somebody who went to your
website and didn't convert you can
associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
retarget them with an ad so the display
campaign is very powerful with google
because you have all these different
options available to you so with google
ads you can also determine how well
you're reaching your goals which
websites you're running your ads on
which ads are bringing in clicks and
which site gives you maximum value for
the minimum cost so you can see all that
in google ads so when i actually pick
and choose how i want to target i can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or demographics for example if
i go back to demographics i have all
this data that google's collected on my
advertising so i can see for example by
age range based on my campaign how many
clicks how many impressions impressions
are how many times my ads been seen
click-through rate meaning the rate at
which people see my ad and are clicking
on my ad how much i'm paying per click
cpc is cost per click total cost and
conversions how many conversions am i
getting so i could see all this data
available to me in google ads so it's a
very powerful platform for measuring
performance okay let's talk about how
you can create a google ad okay so
first thing you want to do is you want
to set up your campaign and you want to
align and go with that campaign just
like we talked with ads related to
facebook you always want to align a goal
with your campaign just like we talked
about there we want to do the same thing
here on google so we have a number of
different options at our disposal so
when you run a campaign why are you
running the campaign so if you're in
just to drive traffic or you're trying
to generate brand awareness okay great
you can still set up that campaign
you're just going to choose the display
network okay the display network allows
you to get your ad out there on millions
of websites so that people can actually
see what your brand product or service
is all about now if you're into direct
response meaning you're in it for sales
and leads then you probably want to
choose potentially google search
partners as a network okay not display
but google search and the partner sites
okay on google search so by choosing
google search as your network it's
director response so somebody's typing
in a keyword query and you're responding
so that's the whole idea behind google
search is we want to meet somebody
halfway we want to be able to offer up
the product or service they're looking
for so if sales and leads are
what your campaign goal is all about
then you want to go search network with
the option to choose google search
partners okay again if you're into you
know driving brand awareness or product
and brand consideration then maybe you
should choose the display network the
bottom line is you need to figure out
what the goal is of the campaign that's
the very most important very first step
and most important step is to figure out
what the goal is of the campaign and
once you've decided that then it's on to
setting up the campaign and in google
you're always going to have at least one
ad group and what makes up an ad group
keywords and ads so ideally when you set
up a campaign on google search network
you're going to choose keywords and
those keywords should be tightly knitted
or tightly themed or in other words be
all relevant to one another in an ad
group so that's what an ad group is
keywords that are relevant to one
another okay in that ad group you're
also going to have an ad so when you
choose your keywords you're going to
write an ad for those keywords so step 3
is after you set up the ad group and
choose your keywords you're going to
create an ad so let's take a look at how
that looks in google ads so if i go to
google ads i can see i already have an
account set up i have a couple campaigns
so let's just say i have this campaign
set up here i'm just gonna call it
industrial campaign okay and if i choose
industrial campaign okay i'm going to
then be asked to set up an ad group now
if i set up an ad group already in that
ad group should be keywords and ads okay
so remember when you set up an ad group
you want to choose your keywords first
paying keywords should be all related to
one another so for example i could see
an ad group here called fig concentrate
well if i click on this ad group and i
look at the keywords they should all be
related to fig concentrate so here we go
we can see a few key words in this ad
group in fact i have 10 of them all
related to fig concentrate so it's very
very important from a quality score
perspective if you remember when we're
talking about quality score quality
score is based on landing page
experience expected click through
and the add relevancy to the keyword so
if you can choose a ad group and have
all your keywords related to one another
like i do here with fig concentrate then
it's easier to write an ad okay so here
i have 10 keywords all related to fake
concentrate so now if i go to ads and
extensions in the google ads platform we
can see here i already have a couple of
ads going okay so
ideally if i wanted to i can run more
than just two ads as a best practice as
a best practice you want to have at
least two ads why because these two ads
are going to be served up against each
other and ideally the whole idea of
running more than one ad is what google
can do is start serving up the ad that
is performing better in terms of
click-through rate or in terms of
conversions okay so it doesn't hurt to
even add one or two more ads so here i'm
gonna go ahead and add one more ad here
okay so if i click on that plus button i
have a bunch of options here i'm going
to go ahead and choose text ad because
i'm running this campaign on the search
network and my goal is to get sales not
lead sales so i want sales i want
somebody to click on my ad go to my
website and purchase some fake
concentrate so that's my goal and so if
i'm on the search network i can only
have text ads so i'm going to choose
text at and once i choose text ad then i
have the option now to go through
and create a new ad okay so what google
actually does is they populate the ad
from previous ads and so this gives me
an opportunity to tweak one of the ads i
already have in place so here you can
see i have a final url and that's the
url that the traffic is going to go to
when they click on your ad okay so if
somebody clicks on the ad that's the
page they're going to go to call that
the final url now i have an option to
create up to three headlines so here i
could see headline one up to 30
characters i have my brand name headline
two i have something related to the
keyword i'm bidding on so what am i
talking about fake concentrate okay
again up to 30 characters now that
includes spaces so if you happen to go
over 30 characters your ads not going to
get approved so here you can see 32 over
30. i'm two characters over
i just get rid of that the add is okay
so you got to be careful to stay within
the boundaries of the character limits
including spaces so here i got headline
two is fig concentrate now i'm gonna
write headline three this is new so this
is recently implemented by google and i
highly recommend that all the fields
available to you you use because the
more information you can put in an ad
the better it is for not only your ad
but for the end user because if
somebody's searching and looking for
fake concentrate and you provide them as
with as much information as possible
then the chances of them clicking on
your ad are going to be greater and
that's what we want if we're going to
advertise we want to advertise so that
people can see our ad and click on our
ad that's the whole point isn't it to
get people to click on our ad because
they're looking for something that we're
offering in this example fit concentrate
so here i have headline three i'm gonna
go ahead and put something in a headline
three maybe a promotion let's just say
i'm offering up twenty percent so i can
say up to twenty percent off through
april and may now you see i'm running
into character count so i'm just going
to go ahead and keep it at april so up
to 20 off through april now i can create
another ad and maybe change the headline
to say up to 20 off through may so you
want to take advantage of all three
headlines now notice when i added the
headline here i can see a preview of it
on mobile and i can see a preview of it
on desktop now underneath that i have
what they call the display path so what
google does is they take your domain in
this case valleyfig.com and you can
basically customize that domain with
what they call a path so you have path
one path two and the whole point of this
is for you to
customize it based on the keywords you
were bidding on so if i'm bidding on
fake concentrate i'm going to put fake
concentrate in here now remember when
somebody actually clicks on my ad
they're not going to go to valleyfig.com
fig concentrate they're going to go to
the url up here under final url so you
want to make sure you put a path in here
ideally what i would do is put in
something related to the keyword i'm
bidding on in this case fig concentrate
now i have an opportunity to add a new
description a second description this is
new and i have up to 90 characters so i
can go ahead and add some content so
remember with description 2 i have up to
90 characters so i'm just gonna go ahead
and borrow some copy from the website if
i'm not actually sure what to write and
so here you can see thick concentrate is
a natural product containing no
preservatives or additives so that's my
second description so now i can go ahead
and
save and create extensions so i'm just
going to go ahead and push the button
save and create extensions and when i do
that i'm going to be prompted to go
ahead and create some ad extensions and
so ad extensions allow me to add in
links site links underneath the ad just
like you see here so when you've added
your site link extensions and other
extensions you save it you'll be able to
see your new ad here here we can see the
ad we created okay notice it's got the
three headlines notice it's got the two
descriptions and
if i want to edit i can just click edit
add and go ahead and edit it if i don't
want to edit it then i don't have to i
can always go back so you can always
edit it ad after it's been created okay
if not no big deal notice when you
actually create your ad in some cases
google is going to review it to make
sure it fits within google's guidelines
and policies uh but once it's approved
you'll see it under
you'll see approved under the status
column and that's pretty much how you
would go ahead and create a text app
okay so when it does get approved it's
going to be in the rotation with the
other two ads and so what google's going
to do is serve up each ad equally and
then eventually the ad that is
performing best will get served up more
and that way you're putting your best ad
always in front of the user who's
looking for the product and service
you're offering so now let's talk about
the metrics so associated with these
keywords these ads these ad groups and
campaigns so there are a lot of metrics
in google ads a lot of metrics and we're
not even going to cover most of these
metrics we're just going to cover what i
deem the most common the most important
metrics to get you going so if you find
yourself advertising whether that be on
google search network or google's
display network you're going to have
some common metrics and here are the
metrics that we're going to focus on
today so you have impressions cost
clicks average cpc
conversions cost per conversion ctr or
click the array and quality score so
let's go through these metrics here and
talk about what they are so impressions
really it's the number of times your ads
been shown on that particular network
whether it's google search or display
and so an impression is just how many
times somebody actually seen your ad
okay whether they actually physically
seen it or not if your ad is showing up
on that network then an impression is
gonna get counted so here if we're
looking at ads we can see we have over a
period of time certain amount of
impressions okay so that's how many
times this particular ad has been shown
so this particular ad here the first one
at the top has been shown
557 times over this period of time which
is year to date okay so that's an
impression how many times your ads been
shown so if we talk about cost cost
refers to the amount of money we've
spent so any time your ad gets clicked
you're going to pay google x amount so
if i go back to google ads i can see
what my total cost is and not only can i
see what my total cost is i can see what
my average cost per click is and so
there's a lot of factors that go into
what you actually pay and some of these
factors are who else is advertising
where you're advertising what network
you're advertising on what time of day
what particular keyword and so there's a
lot of factors and so here i can see on
average year to date i've spent 1.80 per
click on this particular ad for a total
of 32.33
so i can really see how much i've
actually spent and so clicks is just
refers to how many times somebody
clicked on your ad so if your ads been
shown you need an impression and when
somebody sees your ad they're going to
click on your ad so the whole idea is to
get the click remember you want to be in
positions one through three so i want to
make sure that my average position is
between one and three and so if you're
looking in google ads at metrics and you
don't see average position well you can
always add that as a column so if i
click on columns here and then i go to
competitive metrics and i click on
average position and i'm going to move
average position all the way to the top
here so if i click uh move average
position all the way at the top i'm
gonna be able to see what my average
position is over that particular period
of time so here i can see i'm in
positions one through three and that's
where you wanna be you wanna be in
positions one through three so if you're
in positions one through three that
means you're at the top if you're on
google search or that means you're in a
problem position on the display network
so if your ad is shown meaning this gets
an impression then likely somebody's
going to click on that ad and somebody
clicks on that ad it's going to generate
a click which in turn is going to
generate cost and so ideally what you
want to do is you want to measure the
rate at which people click on your ad
based on how many times it was shown so
here i can see 28 clicks over
3549 impressions that's a 0.79
click-through rate so ideally the higher
the click-through rate the better the at
and the higher the clicker rate the
chances are you're going to get more
traffic to your site so we want to be
able to measure clicks and we want to be
able to measure click through rate and
we also want to measure cost per click
which is really the total cost divided
by the number of clicks so if i go back
to google ads here i can see you know
17.57
over 28 clicks that averages out to
about 63 cents per click so that's how i
get cost per click now your cost per
click is going to vary a little bit okay
so it's going to vary based on keyword
it's going to be based on where you're
advertising what position etc so there's
a lot of factors involved with cost per
click but that's how you would actually
calculate it but google ads actually
does the calculation for you for
collector rate and cost per click but in
case you want to know you can always
divide clicks into cost okay so
conversions probably one of the most
important metrics you're going to use in
google ads because you're paying google
and if you're paying google for
advertising you want to make sure you
get in return on your investment so
conversions are added when a user clicks
on your ad and performs an action that
you've defined such as purchasing
something downloading something viewing
something signing up for a newsletter
etc so you want to make sure that if
you're in google ads that you're
measuring conversions and so you simply
want to go to tools so if you go to
tools and then click on conversions you
want to make sure that you're running
conversions ideally what you want to do
is you want to run conversions from
google analytics but you can certainly
set up conversions within google ads as
well notice i also have call from ads as
set up as a conversion so you have an
opportunity in google ads to add a
number a different conversions and the
more conversions you add really the
better off you are because you want to
measure up all your campaigns against
conversions if i go back to campaigns i
want to be able to see what campaigns
are driving conversions and if i can
measure that and i have a campaign
that's really driving conversions that
i'm going to continue to advertise on
google okay so here over this particular
period of time i can see one campaign
has driven nine conversions at 128.67
cost per conversion and so how do i get
cost per conversion well i get my total
cost divided by the number of
conversions and then i could see my
conversion rate the rate at which people
convert so really if i have 241 clicks
and nine conversions that's 9 divided by
241 that's 3.77
conversion rate so i can measure
conversion rate cost per conversion and
conversion just by setting up
conversions in google ads and so ideally
if you're going to pay google for
advertising you want to be able to
measure return on investment via
conversions so again see cost per
conversion is just really the the total
cost divided by the number of
conversions and then click the rate
again just as a reminder the total
clicks divided by the total number of
impressions and then one other metric
we're going to talk about here today is
quality scores so quality score is
really google's way of measuring how
well
your keywords are are compared to
the ad associated with it the expected
click-through rate and the landing page
so quality score is the backbone of
google ads so if i go back to google ads
and i click on keywords quality scores
something you want to measure and if you
don't have it in your columns you could
certainly just click on columns and add
it and so here i can see my quality
score and quantity score is a
measurement between 1 and 10. and so if
you have a good quality score google is
going to score you higher because your
keyword is relevant to your ad it's
relevant to the landing page and you
have a good expected click-through rate
if you don't have a good quality score
google's going to let you know why you
don't have a good quality score so again
your three categories that make up
quality score are landing page
experience which means really google
looking at the landing page you're
sending people to and they're seeing if
the page loads well fast does it have
ads does that have good content is it
good landing page will the end user have
a good experience they also look at the
ad relevance okay is the ad relevant to
the keyword and they'll also look at the
expected click-through rate okay so
based on other advertisers and their
click-through rate are you achieving the
same click-through rate and so those
three factors make up quality score
quality score is a metric assigned to
keywords so if you don't have a good
quality score you need to fix it because
the repercussion is you're going to have
to pay more so having a good quality
score likely means you're going to pay
less per click so you want to make sure
that if you bid on a keyword that the
keyword goes to a relevant landing page
the ad itself is relevant and you're
getting a good click-through rate so
quality score is the backbone of google
ads and how it works so you want to make
sure you have a good quality score so
optimizing your ads so what if you don't
have a good quality score what if you're
not getting conversions well there's
things you can do so remember we want to
make sure that we're adding extensions
whether that be call site link review
app add extensions to your ads because
it's going to increase the click-through
rate so you can also really
hone your ad copy if you're selling
products and you're running a promotion
maybe you want to add in a little sense
of urgency to help people you know
realize hey if this this promotion's
ending maybe i want to click on the ad
and take action okay with google ads you
can always run a b testing on ads and so
what you could do is run two ads in one
ad group and see what ad is performing
best in terms of click-through rate or
conversion rate and whatever ad is
running better you can always run that
ad and then continue more testing so
that way you're always putting your best
forward in terms of advertising and the
ad copy whether that be text or display
you always want to use call to action
you want to get people to click on your
ad when somebody clicks on your ad it's
going to improve click through rate
click to rate improves quality score so
as i mentioned several times already you
want to make sure your ads are placed at
the top between positions one and three
on google search so you can measure ad
position in google ads and if you're not
rank between one and three you want to
increase your bid okay you can also
optimize for local search so local is an
ad extension that you can add to your ad
you can also advertise at a time when
your audience is online or you can
advertise on during business hours only
so you can adjust when you advertise on
google ensure some of your ads you know
capitalize on some particular events
that are related to your industry so you
can capitalize on that okay you can
certainly ask google to accelerate your
ads okay or you can do standard delivery
so google can spread out your clicks and
show your ads throughout the day google
search is all about keywords so you want
to be able to pick and choose the right
keywords first you can also add negative
keywords so
if you're bidding on a specific industry
let's just say you have software and you
want somebody to sign up for your
particular piece of software uh but you
don't offer a free trial then maybe you
want to add free as a negative keyword
so if you don't offer anything for free
free should be a negative keyword so if
somebody actually does type in looking
for free software then your ads not
going to show up so that's the whole
idea behind negative keywords okay you
can use dynamic keyword insertion into
your ads meaning you can ask google hey
i want to dynamically insert a keyword
into my ad that somebody uses to make
your ad more relevant so relevancy
increases click-through rate and
improves quality score so as you can see
there's a lot of things you can do
here's some more things you can use
branded keywords you can use particular
match types in google so let's talk
about match types for a second so you
have different match types if i go back
to google ads here i could see my
keywords that i'm bidding on so by
default if you actually bid on a keyword
it's going to be broad match and so if
i've been on the keyword medical
computer if somebody typed in something
related to medical and included the
keyword medical but not computer then my
ad may show up however i can make an
exact match so somebody can type in
exactly only medical computers so if i
click edit and i can change the match
type for that particular keyword to
exact then that means that somebody that
types in only medical computer my ad is
going to show up i can basically do
phrase match so somebody types in
looking for
something that's going to
help me with medical computers okay
that's a long tail phrase work keyword
query but the keyword medical computer
is in that order so my ad is going to
show up okay so with phrase match your
ad is going to show when somebody types
in that keyword you're bidding on in
that order you also have broad match
modifiers so if you have a plus sign in
front of the keyword then that means
that somebody actually has to use that
keyword in the query in order for your
ad to show up okay so you could change
the match type of any keyword so if you
use an exacto phrase then chances are
you're going to have lower volume of
queries but probably higher relevancy if
you use a broad match then your ad could
show up for any combination of search
queries so you really want to be careful
on the match type that you choose so
keep an eye on quality score remember
google has quality score between one and
ten the higher quality score the better
you are so really if you have a quality
score i would say anything below four
you probably want to pause the keyword
okay so you can measure quality score at
the keyword level so if i go back to
google ads and i have keywords that are
say three chances are i'm going to have
to pay more for the click and it might
not be worth it so i may want to end up
pausing that keyword and try other
keywords that are more relevant that i
can send traffic to a more relevant
landing page or i can have an ad that's
more relevant to that keyword in order
to help with the quality score okay you
can ensure that your landing pages are
mobile friendly so that's another thing
you want to keep in mind that most
people start their search on mobile so
you certainly want to make sure that
your landing pages are optimized because
if somebody starts to search on mobile
likes your product or service chances
are they're coming back via desktop or
even going into the store most searches
start on mobile so you want to make sure
those pages are optimized and there's
plenty more things you could do to
optimize your ads you want to make sure
you group and organize your keywords
into relevant ad groups why because you
can write relevant ads for those
keywords so if i go back to google ads i
want to make sure if i go to ad groups
that the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to one another so what's my
ad group name well if it's medical pc if
i click on medical pc i want to make
sure the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to medical pc i want to
structure my campaigns and ad groups to
target more ads effectively so you want
to be able to you know organize your
campaigns and ad groups and the rule of
thumb here is you should organize your
campaigns and ad groups based on the
site architecture of your site so the
way your website is laid out in the
navigation is how you should likely
structure your campaigns and ad groups
focus on your budget okay so you want to
put more budget to campaigns that are
converting okay you can use automatic
bidding for ads to maximize results so
meaning that google has what they call
artificial intelligence so google can do
a lot of the bidding and a lot of the
managing for you that's really a great
benefit to running your ads on google so
their machines are learning behavior
from your keywords that you're bidding
on and so ideally when they learn what's
converting they're going to bid more and
try and help you get the conversion for
the keywords that have historically
converted and so ideally you can use
some of the automated bidding features
that google ads has to offer in order to
improve performance imagine it's the
year 2004.
this is phil
phil's looking to release a book and set
up a blog
he's sure that he'd be successful but
he's only worried about one thing he
doesn't know how to ensure that his book
reaches the right target audience who
could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads billboards
radio direct mail direct sales and the
television all of these options were
pretty expensive their effectiveness
couldn't be accurately determined and
they didn't let him advertise his
content to the appropriate audience
phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved
now let's have a look at the same
scenario in the present day alongside
traditional forms of advertising phil
would have access to digital marketing
the form of marketing that's a lot more
lucrative inexpensive and configurable
marketing that would enable marketers to
advertise their audience digitally using
channels like search engines websites
social media platforms emails etc among
these types social media marketing cop
feels eye social media marketing would
give phil the opportunity to take
advantage of social media platforms to
advertisers content to a highly targeted
audience it would help more people learn
about his book increase the interaction
with his audience it's relatively
inexpensive unless he goes into
advertising and will help him get
marketplace insights that might help in
understanding his audience preferences
better
phil started by taking up a
certification to learn about social
media marketing
since he was already familiar with the
concept of social media marketing his
next step was to learn about the
different types of content he could post
on social media
some of the most common forms of content
that phil could post would be images
text posts polls and videos
but over time phil began to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content phil needed to advertise
his content
for that you would need to use the
advertising options provided by the
social media platforms like facebook
instagram youtube linkedin and twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text they also have a call to action
that encourages user interaction
phil could use images from his book
advertise websites that sell his book
and more then there are text and post
ads
these ads could advertise posts or
excerpts from phil's blog or his book
further garnering interest from an
interesting audience
he could also use video ads phil could
use video ads that feature favorable
reviews and customer testimonials to
advertise his books
phil could also use lead ads through
which he could collect information from
users who are interested in a weekly
newsletter or regular updates from his
blog
but that wasn't the only thing phil
could do with social media platforms he
could create a brand for himself and
drive audience interest to it engage
with them create an identity engage with
content finding content that works for
him
social media platforms also allowed him
the opportunity to target audiences
based on demographics like their age
location gender and much more
and in time phil began to see an
increase in the number of viewers coming
to his social media page and by
extension his blog
he also saw an increase in the number of
people who bought his book
greatly increasing his audience here are
some things he learned one to set goals
that were quantitative smart and follow
a constant deadline two to understand
his audience by engaging and connecting
with them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
four
using tools like buzz sumo ifttt buffer
and more for lead generation creating
email lists setting buyer personas and
more
five to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos what we
live in now it's highly digital place
but that wasn't always the case until
four years ago so if we rewind letting
people know about your products was a
little harder then so even if you go
back say five or ten years promoting
your products wasn't as easy as it is
today i mean people had to resort to
you know good old-fashioned newspapers
putting in an ad or those big thick
books called the yellow pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton i mean those were the ways to get
your product and message out there a lot
of advertising in those yellow pages
then you have billboards you know
driving down the highway you see that
billboard on the side of the road you
wonder who are those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then facts
facts ads uncommonly known way to
advertise by the way who has faxes now
but people did advertise vfx just a few
decades ago so these were all the ways
in which people had to get their product
and service out there it seems like so
archaic looking at it now but back then
that was legitimate that was the way to
do it and then one thing made our lives
a lot easier so if you're a marketer
you're thinking yourself man i'm glad
i'm a marketer in today's day and age
because it's social media marketing
social media marketing has made
everyone's lives better from the company
that's selling the product or service to
the marketer promoting the product and
service to the end user who wants to see
that product or service and engage with
that product or service so social media
is a good source of getting your product
and service out there and it just makes
everybody's lives a heck of a lot easier
so we're going to answer that million
dollar question and what's that million
dollar question it's how can you rise
above the rest and so today's session is
going to be how to start with social
media marketing so you can rise above
the rest leveraging this great platform
that we all take advantage of today so
let's start by asking the question what
is social media marketing social media
marketing involves increasing website
traffic
it centers around engagement it offers
you the ability to
increase your brand awareness and it has
other marketing goals you know so you
can create various forms of content for
different social media platforms so
that's really in a nutshell with social
media marketing so again if we want to
increase our traffic or we want to
increase our engagement like likes or
comments then look no further than
social media marketing if we want to
engage with our users our customers our
potential and prospective customers we
can really put a personalized experience
in place using social media marketing we
want to create different forms of
content like videos and blogs and
infographics and other types of graphics
with the potential to actually go viral
by viral is spreading like wildfire one
user sending it to another as rapidly as
can be and before you know it you get
you know millions of views and millions
of likes i mean that's the power of
social media marketing so why do we want
to do social media marketing and i think
we just answered some of those questions
but let's dig a little bit deeper we
mentioned in our definition of social
media marketing that we have the
opportunity to
really build our brand awareness and
that is no more truthful than with
social media marketing more so than any
other digital marketing channel social
media marketing allows us to really put
our brand in a good light in a good
position in front of the right eyeballs
so it allows us to really improve our
brand by pushing out the appropriate
content in front of the appropriate
people social media is a great channel
for that we can look to conversion rates
so if we are pushing a product and
service in front of the right eyeballs
and we are building up a funnel of
prospective customers who then turn into
customers who then turn into loyal
customers who then turn into lifetime
customers we can see at every step in
the process that our conversion rates
may increase we can certainly leverage
social media marketing for seo for
search engine rankings it's about
off-page seo it's about posting content
on social media platforms to build up
some link juice okay so there is some
inherent benefits to working seo and
social media side by side it's cost
effective well if you're posting content
on twitter or facebook it doesn't cost
you anything it just takes a little bit
of time and creativity now if you want
to go ahead and do some advertising on
these platforms yes it's going to cost
you but you'd be surprised not going to
be as costly as say other search
platforms like say google or bing where
you're actually paying for keywords and
paying per click for those keywords so
social media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by your target audience okay
your target audience goes from seeing
your brand for the first time to
getting to know your brand a little bit
more to maybe buying a product or
service from your brand then returning
to buy another product and service and
then continuing to buy that product or
service i mean that's increasing the top
funnel traffic and not just the traffic
but the conversions so at every step in
the process social media allows you to
build that funnel depending on where
somebody is whether they're seeing your
brand for the first time or actually
returning to purchase the product or
service again so that's the inherent
benefit these are the inherent benefits
of social media marketing
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation and sharing
of online content to help generate
audience interest in a brand's product
or services this means providing
information that the audience considers
valuable and relevant in a consistent
manner so that it drives some sort of
profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing there's
options like blogs
videos
infographics
case studies white papers and ebooks
so why is content marketing so important
firstly it helps build awareness trust
and loyalty in your brand
the more your brand provides accurate
and well-researched content the more
people learn about and trust your brand
the more the audience trusts in you the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase traffic to your site
and get more conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics like search engine optimization
social media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign it could be increased
conversions website sign ups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content
but what exactly are buyer personas
now these are research-based profiles
that represent your target customer
buyer personas help you describe your
brand's ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you
you also need to set up a content
management system like hubspot
squarespace wix and wordpress they'll
help you with increased collaboration
greater support run a b test and much
more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content that would
work the best for you
and finally you can publish and manage
your content now let's talk about
content marketing tips
number one remarket your content
content marketing is one of the many
ways you can spread your content to a
buyer audience you can define the
audience you want to market to and then
tag visitors who come to your site and
using google's display network you can
strategically position your ads in front
of people on google or its partner
websites who previously interacted with
your website and advertised to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience here's an
example of a banner advertisement i
would be shown if i was shopping for a
macbook pro on amazon and changed my
mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head until eventually i go and finish
that purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content this is why
you need to focus on google's featured
snippet this position also known as
position 0 enhances and draws user
attention on the search engine's result
page
through the featured snippet you can
drive a large amount of traffic to your
website while cementing your position as
an expert in your industry
you can have different forms of snippets
like definition boxes where a snippet of
text gives researchers direct and
concise definitions and descriptions
you could have tables where data is
taken from the page and displayed in a
table you could have ordered lists where
items are presented in specific order
and you can also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand
if you're looking to grow a following
for your content try not to copy how
already established and successful
corporate blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about it
tend to follow solo influencers they
advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what these popular
and influential blogs are doing and
incorporate into your brand's website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
neil patel
see how he himself is the brand and if
you've gone through his content you know
it's pretty great as well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four
ensure that your content matches your
brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards and make sure your tone and
quality remain consistent
you need to ask your audience questions
about how you can develop and refine
your brand's voice
by answering these questions you can
provide your audience with a more
cohesive and helpful experience
your tone of your brand can vary on the
basis of what type of content you're
planning to post and what the goal you
want to achieve from the campaign
next up we have number five
back up your arguments for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original source makes it extremely
credible this data can help the audience
grow trust in your brand to persuade
them that your content is valid and
valuable this will also help your brand
grow as an industry expert
at number six
we have use specific keywords
now make sure you use specific keywords
in your content this takes care of the
seo aspect behind your content
this will also help your content have a
greater chance of being found indexed
and ranked
it could also help your content rank for
niche topics within your industry moving
on to tip number seven
evaluate the success of your content
with data
earlier we talked about why it's so
important that you back up your content
with data
now let's talk about how data can help
you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about how well your content is doing the
age demographics of the people enjoying
it who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much more with this
data you can make sure that your time
and money are being used in the best
possible way
some of the most popular tools in the
market are buzzsumo evernote hubspot
trello and wordpress
these will help you find topics and
influencers within your industry you can
capture organize and share notes
collaborate with team members create
sales funnels and much more
now we've reached midway right now so
i've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
all right so let's get back to our list
tip number eight is to be consistent
with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted with the help of
a content calendar will show your
audience that you're committed to
providing them helpful and informative
content
this will also establish your brand as
an authority and thought leader within
your niche it will help your audience
depend on you for quality content and
give them a reason to return tip number
nine is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content will coerce
your audience to take a particular
action quickly
it can help you create valuable content
and fix pain points faced by your
audience build a strong relationship
with them and earn their trust
it also leads to increased engagement
and a positive brand experience
it provides users with real value and
solutions leading them to take action
here we have an example from trello
where we see a pop-up with a call to
action asking interested users to input
their email ids to sign media today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 percent of them felt content
marketing was really important to their
digital marketing campaigns and more
than 25 percent of their budgets are
used for visual advertising content like
images infographics
videos and other forms of rich media
will help you enhance the message of
your brand and reach a wider audience
here's an example of advertising by
coca-cola
although there's not a lot of text in
the ads you can immediately recognize
the unmistakable branding and the
message they're trying to send moving on
to tip number 11
create trending and evergreen content
creating content that's evergreen and
trending with your own unique angle
statistics and research will be a huge
advantage since you'll have to update it
every now and then
you'll get a great deal out of the work
without having to do a lot of work
here's an example of one such evergreen
article
people are never going to stop wanting
to learn how to do seo so with a little
tweaking every few months to reflect new
changes that google may have done you'll
have an article that you can get
considerable mileage out of
next up tip number 12 is to understand
content that works for you
you need to analyze what content works
on different social media platforms
for example you all know youtube is the
best place for video content instagram
and pinterest for visual content twitter
for smaller snappy content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content across the internet
tip number 13 is to understand your
target audience
now like i mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign isn't going to bear
fruit without targeting a specific
audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find this out by asking
questions like who you're engaging with
online their age location language etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand using tools to research what
social channels your audience is using
and so on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now abs testing will help you understand
what your audience likes or doesn't what
content works for you and much more
you can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags call to actions content
formats image types content length and
much more it can also help you make
better decisions in the future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people sharing similar
content
one of the best ways to build your
audience is to get people or influencers
who already share content within your
niche to share your content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience they would be a lot
more likely to enjoy your content
content marketing strategy
so buckle up and let's get right to it
and we're gonna get right into some of
the best practices some tips some
methodologies some things you should be
doing with content marketing so right
out of the gate let's start talking
about
knowing your audience okay so content is
all about
writing for a particular audience so
it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect demographics
of your target audience based on
who's coming to your website so you can
get that data in google analytics under
audience email subscribers i mean who is
subscribing to your emails who do you
already have in your email database and
you can look at social media i mean you
look at facebook you can look at the
people who are already connected to you
okay these are just some three three of
many examples you could be doing to
gather data on your audience okay you
have to know who your audience is before
you start writing you know for a
successful content marketing strategy
you really just need to know your
audience and basically you're going to
segment them based on their interests so
that content is going to be catered to
that audience okay so if it's science
that likes a specific you know product
uh that you offer or feature
that's part of that product that you
offer then that's the segment you're
gonna be writing about so you need to
collect your data on your audience ahead
of time and then you're gonna segment
that audience okay so you're not gonna
write content for everyone because the
shoe doesn't necessarily fit for
everyone okay the shoe has to fit for
specific foot and in this case we're
talking about an audience we need to be
able to segment our audience out and you
could certainly segment them out by age
by gender by education level by income
by interest i mean these are just some
of the examples again it could be new
returning or new re users versus
returning users it could be users who
have purchased from you in the past
versus users who haven't purchased from
you in the past it could certainly be an
age range or it could be even going
further on interest level or combination
thereof okay so for example you can get
that demographic information using
google analytics just got to go into
analytics under audience under
demographics you're going to see age and
br it's age is broken out by age range
and you're gonna see gender so you're
gonna see a breakdown of gender and use
that to your advantage so if you're
going to
you know write some content and you know
99 of your traffic is female the age of
18 to 24 then you know that content's
been catered accordingly so you could
certainly go to facebook page insights
and get some really good demographic
data there because facebook is all about
demographics okay so
you could see exactly
you know how many fans you have broken
out by men versus women and then you can
see again same thing as google analytics
you could see an age range breakout you
could use twitter analytics i mean
twitter has share some really good
insights into education level so
you know if you're dealing with
you know highly sophisticated people who
have master's degrees or even higher or
let's just say even on linkedin you know
that majority of the people you're
trying to target are c-level meaning
ceos
or cfos or cmos you know chief marketing
officers or chief executive officers
then you're going to cater your message
a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high range managers or even vps so use
your audience information you collect on
these various platforms to your
advantage okay so let's jump into number
two we want to create high quality
content now i know this sounds like a
given but
and i say but heavily there's not a lot
of high quality content out there on the
internet so separate yourself first and
foremost always always always create
high quality content it's gonna result
in a lot of things that are gonna
benefit you you know one you're gonna
come across as you know somebody who
knows what they're talking about and
that's gonna help increase your brand
awareness okay when you increase your
brand awareness people know about you so
it's likely going to increase traffic to
your website or if you're on social
media you know if you produce good high
quality content people are gonna share
that content okay so
from an seo perspective it can improve
website ranking meaning if you have good
quality content you know and it's really
focused in on a specific topic or a
certain set of core words keywords then
you're gonna rank improves website dwell
time meaning hey you get good content
people are gonna hang around to see what
else you have to offer okay so it's no
secret that you know good content you
usually leads to you know quality
engagement and then
certainly last but not least you can
gain a lot of leads here meaning hey
somebody likes what you have to say
whether that's a video or blog post or
or infographic you know people are going
to become more interested more engaged
spend more time and that's all going to
funnel through to somebody taking that
next step in the funnel and
becoming more interested in your service
or even purchasing one of your products
so creating high quality content
involves brainstorming topics and terms
you know you got to do the upfront work
due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics use a keyword
research tool to gather results so if
you have a topic you know one of the
benefits of quality content is rankings
go to google's keyword planner
understand how much quality
and and understand how much competition
each keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in google's keyword planner or
any really any keyword planning tool you
always want to create original content
okay so you don't want to plagiarize or
take somebody else's content and then
you want to support that content with
compelling headlines so if you have a
piece of content you got to get
somebody's attention
write a nice headline that's going to
grab their attention okay so give
valuable content to your readers and add
resources from well-known sites so if
you you do borrow say
a data point from another source then
you know cite that source you also want
to create engaging and thought-provoking
content get somebody to think i mean
people are gonna rage your content
because they not they don't know the
subject matter their interests in the
subject matter and they want to be able
to spend the time taking something away
from that content follow a logical
structure and use relevant images i
can't stress this one enough you know
just throw things on a web page you know
put some structure to it maybe you have
to break it out if you feel like you
have too much content there's no harm in
breaking it into part one versus part
two get people uh tease them a bit get
them to come back and read part two okay
use different content forms in case
somebody's interested maybe you want to
capture some data you know prefer short
paragraphs to make the content readable
remember if you're talking to c-level
folks you know maybe you don't have to
dummy down the content so to speak but
if you're dealing with you know folks or
people that are right out of high school
or still in high school then adjust your
content in format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done i mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check in to see how much
that data points changed so these are
all
you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content there's some other
things that you should be aware of you
know grammatical mistakes
you know you need to avoid those there's
no reason for grammatical mistakes
today's technology doesn't allow for it
and
hey listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for it because if
you have a grammatical mistake you just
lost a lot of credibility you know don't
be afraid to add a clear call to action
at the end of your content if somebody's
interested in reading it they're
probably going to be interested in
taking the next step whatever that next
step is okay so creating content that
fulfills viewers requirements meaning
somebody's searching for something and
your content shows up in the search
results then they're actively looking
for you what are you offering them is it
fulfilling their requirements you know
don't be afraid to use examples
throughout your content in fact work in
or integrate some case studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know so break up that content
with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then give more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content i was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information you don't withhold it have
them come back and read a secondary blog
post or secondary piece that supports
the original now we want to move from
high quality content to running a b test
baby test so important why because with
a b split testing you can increase your
conversion rates okay so four elements
to test and your content marketing
strategy so if you have content say a
blog and you're testing that blog you
know test out the images test out the
forms do you have a long form or short
form you know test out the content
length you can have a variation that is
a lot shorter than the original does
that increase or decrease bounce rates
play around with call to actions your
call to actions do matter you know do
you want to use a softer call to action
a softer tone or do you want to use
something very direct and strong you
know test call to actions to see what's
going to get people to move closer
through the closer to purchasing and
through that funnel so a b testing to me
is something that should be naturally
done with google optimize it's free so
with images you know you could test a
lot of different variations of images
anything from people
to
you know outlandish imagery to just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low
you know don't write something very long
write something that you think is going
to stick with that time on page but on
your a b test create something maybe a
little longer if it's engaging enough
maybe somebody's going to stay a little
bit longer on the page so you know
create a variation it's going to play
with that length okay so use analytics
to your advantage to figure out
as a baseline what amount of content is
getting people to stay on the page then
see if you can push the envelope one way
or the other okay improving the page
with sign up forms really what you want
to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to facebook or google so
if they're creating an account they can
create an account via google or facebook
or
you know don't put too many forms on the
page and then on those ctas as i
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color i mean i
test color all the time believe it or
not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the middle east or
the far east asia you know color schemes
and what you say
matters and it changes versus say you
know europe or the west okay so keep
that in mind when you're making changes
on color or tone or placement and things
of that nature so you want to conduct a
competitor analysis so we're talking
about creating high quality content
testing that content you know
brainstorming some topics you know
looking at your audience you're doing
all this work you might as well take the
next step and figure out what it is your
competitors are doing so you can opt for
competitive analysis by
identifying your competitors top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so
really what we're trying to do here is
improve our conversion rates so what are
your competitors doing what are their
baselines we can maybe up that annie i
mean that data is also available in
google analytics so you can look at
benchmarking reports in google analytics
to get some form or fashion you can also
go to facebook and look at your
competitors facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include facebook as well or maybe even
linkedin so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag and the meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you could certainly leverage an
seo platform like search uh sem rush or
moz or something like that that's going
to allow you to get some good insight on
competitor information so keep in mind
there are seo platforms that will give
you information on your competitors and
that's what these seo platforms are good
for so number five moving on choose a
suitable content format so
now we've done all this homework we know
what we want to say we know who we want
to say it to we're ready to do some
testing but we need to find a format
because it's not always about a web page
per se meaning content on a web page
there's not always about a blog post
with content in that blog post okay we
need to decide the type of content
that's going to fit what we're trying to
say so again you can go the traditional
route with just posting a blog post
there's nothing wrong with that because
with a blog post you can incorporate
video and imagery you could also go a
more harder route when i say harder more
i say official route with an e-book or
case study something that a user is
going to be able to take away with maybe
download
something more official um something
more in-depth something with a harder
stamp on it so that that shows
individuals that you've taken the time
you've done this homework you've done
this research you've done some really
in-depth analysis and now the proper
format for that is not a blog post it's
an e-book now if you're into talking
like i am then you can certainly do a
podcast and podcasts are always popular
depending on the topic so you got to be
aware of the topic now videos are always
always a good option you got the likes
of video
and video and youtube and some other you
know video platforms out there that
allow you the ability to get found very
quickly especially with the likes of
youtube you know people use youtube
before they go on to purchasing a
product so think about that so if you're
trying to get somebody if you're trying
to sway an audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal
you know customer to taking the next
step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time and so
videos kind of help convey that now if
you're trying to convey a lot of
different points then an infographic
might be your best option instead of
having to write out all those points try
using an infographic to convey those
points visually now again with blog
posts it should have valuable content
that can be shared by your website
visitors on social so that's the key
make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer in-depth content so
and it shouldn't be published frequently
so maybe if this is something you're
doing annually then ebook could be the
format with a case study what you should
have a customer story that succeeded and
and you solving that customer's problem
so the case study is always there for
you know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in a more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture
hey everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience
and then videos are highly engaging
they're also shareable on blog posts and
pretty much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a content management system
that's going to work for you so you want
to be able to choose something where you
can plan appropriately produce
manage publish and measure results all
in one place there are plenty of content
management systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are wordpress hubspot
binder i mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know wordpress
is the way to go if you're into building
out landing pages that you want to you
know share you know hotspot could be the
way to go okay there are lots of
available options out there so moving on
number seven target your audience using
emails okay so what are we talking about
well we all know what emails are emails
help us to communicate directly with our
target audience and convert them to
leads so email is a good way to follow
up with your audience so if you've done
a podcast follow up with an email you
know maybe get them to you know fill out
a survey via email based on that podcast
or if you create a podcast about some
data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email okay there's
lots of ways that all these formats can
complement themselves via email okay you
could certainly take a blog post and
package it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series a blog post you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly
you know you can collect emails and send
out those emails with you know certain
information or what you should be doing
is targeting and segmenting your emails
just like you are your content so if
you're producing content for a certain
audience then make sure that particular
audience gets that same email now some
of the email content that you could
share with your target audience or
newsletters okay seasonal emails
promotional emails automated messaging
and what we mean by automated messaging
hey if somebody just purchased from you
send them a thank you email maybe follow
up a couple days later with another
email with a survey or what you could do
is if you know who your loyal customers
are you target them with a promotional
email so there's lots of ways to slice
and dice content via email okay just
make sure you know your target audience
is there's lots of things you can do in
email again you can complement lots of
different formats within email as i
mentioned before with a podcast or a
blog post so keep all that in mind email
is a good way to communicate with your
audience okay the last point we want to
make here is use native ads okay so we
talk about native ads it's one of the
smartest ways to connect your audience
with your brand so for example this is a
native ad on buzzfeed okay it's about 15
bands that probably wouldn't exist
without led zeppelin okay so for you
folks out there that don't know who led
zeppelin is a rock group from the 70s
late 60s 70s okay disbanded in 80 81 82
early 80s okay but you know people grew
up like myself listening to led zeppelin
okay so you can see the headline here 15
bands that probably won't exist with the
outlet zeppelin you know i'm interested
in who those bands might be even if you
don't know who led zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay
who is this led zeppelin group and what
are these 15 bands the key here is not
necessarily the headline or led zeppelin
per se but it's a native ad and it's
sitting next to
content talking about music okay so
according to forbes online audiences are
25 more likely to look at a native ad
than at a banner and so that native ad
in this case we're talking about music
needs to be sitting or accompanied
alongside content talking about in this
case music you know would help if it was
rock music just music in general might
get enough
to get peak people's interest okay so if
you're going to create content you know
align that content with something that's
you know naturally going to fit and
that's why we call them native ads
because they're native to the content
that they're associated with so finally
after all that's said and done when all
you've done is create good content
follow up vmails targeting your audience
and associating that content with you
know content natively then you can
always measure your content performance
so
my favorite part of it all you going to
analytics going on facebook insights you
know you want to go in and check out how
that content is performing and you want
to do that because you want to be able
to see what's performing what's not
performing the key here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key so measuring the right metrics can
help you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video
you're not necessarily going to look at
page views you're going to look at video
views so you know some of these basic
metrics of users and sessions and pages
bounce rate you know dwell time that's
all great but you just need to make sure
that
you're aligning the right metric with
the right asset so for example if you
have a case study or ebook you want to
make sure that
you're measuring how many downloads the
ebook or the
case study received again with the video
you want to measure video views now if
you're packaging up emails and sending
them out to your target audience you
want to make sure you look at open rates
and click rates okay so a lot of things
you can be looking at so make sure you
choose the right metrics because there's
hundreds and hundreds of metrics to
choose from so just be aware all the
different metrics that are available you
know if you're in it for search okay how
much traffic getting from search where
are you ranking so there are a lot of
things you need to think about so think
about the content that you're producing
and think about how you want to be able
to measure that content so let's go back
over our checklist here
so what you could do is create an
editorial calendar in fact i would
highly suggest you create an editorial
calendar in order to keep track of all
the content you've done over a period of
time are you making your content worth
reading that means are you
checking the results of that content
what we just went over measuring the
content is it worth reading have a
column set up in that editorial calendar
you know performing or not performing if
it's not performing don't do it again
okay curate your content okay you always
want to you know make sure you're
reusing or using or adding to the
content that you've created guest post
on influential blogger websites you want
to add statistics numbers and quotes to
your content make it engaging make it
look like you've done your homework you
could share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
slideshare now you can share it on all
social media platforms i'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast then you know you can recite
that podcast in the form of a blog okay
so get some testimonials that support
some of your content again create a
podcast you can send out an email with a
survey or trying to solicit some
testimonials or if you post something on
facebook you know leverage the feedback
you get from facebook in the form of a
testimonial okay and then you want to
promote your blog post for maximum
success and a lot of that means seo so
make sure you do your due diligence and
get the right keywords in that blog post
okay so you can create personas for
different user audiences okay so
remember it's all about tone okay so if
you're going to create a blog post make
sure your tone is aligned with that
right audience whether that be young
middle aged or older
are you choosing the right type of
content okay you'll know based on the
results okay you want to add h1 and h2
tags on your web pages why because when
we're talking about content we're
talking about organizing the content and
h1 and h2s help you organize the content
appropriately customize the metadata
metadata is title tag and meta tag
descriptions and even all tags okay all
of that is for search so you want your
content to show up in search whether
that's video infographic or blog post
all of it can be shown in search results
so make sure you write a good title and
make sure you write a good meta
description because that's what people
are going to see when they search okay
so you want to create a detailed summary
and title and again that goes along with
the title tag meta description and then
you want to make it easy for the
audience to ask questions and comment on
your blog so don't be afraid like i'm
going to do right now in this video is
if i'm missing anything from this
checklist feel free to comment hey i've
written my fair share content but i
could be talking to an audience that is
just as qualified as i am and they may
have some tips so feel free to comment
underneath this video now don't be
afraid to ask just like i just did
people are always willing to provide
constructive feedback so don't be afraid
to ask for it and make it easy so to me
every blog post needs to have some form
of a comment box because blog posts are
out there to solicit engagement now
let's recap everything we talked about
because we'd certainly covered a lot and
there's a lot to cover when it comes to
content marketing so one know your
audience again you can lean on google
analytics you know demographic data
whether it be age or gender you could do
the same with facebook and twitter and
linkedin you know every platform has
some data you could take away great high
quality content when i mean high quality
content
brainstorm some topics has it already
been written to death about or is this
unique you know don't write something
your competitors are writing okay don't
copy what your competitors have written
organize your content support it with
good imagery all of these are tips to
creating high quality content okay when
you create that content think about
running to maybe test you know run some
variations
and switch out the image switch out the
call to action see what's going to get
people to react and engage with the
content conduct competitor analysis so
lean on the facebooks of the world to
see what your competitors are posting
see what's engaging for them okay you
can also lean on these seo platforms
like sem rush and moz all you got to do
is plug in a domain and they're going to
give you some information about
where a particular competitor ranks for
keyword or how many backlinks and what
websites are linking to them so all
that's available in these seo platforms
okay so you want to choose a suitable
content format we listed a few from
ebooks to case studies to podcasts to
infographics to blog posts to videos
it's up to you what you think is best
for your audience just keep in mind you
need to be able to measure it and so
that's the important thing if it doesn't
work the first time out then you might
want to consider changing out the
content format choose a content
management system you know plenty out
there wordpress is a good one if you're
going to be a blogger okay blogging
allows you to
you know post optimize that blog post
you know you could have the ability to
share that blog post across social
platforms and you can also have that
blog post show up in search engine
results so you can't do any of that
without a good content management system
so you want to target your audience
using emails okay so email is a good way
to again further communicate with that
particular segmented audience and again
you could use it to send out promotional
emails to loyal followers or
you can use systematic emails to send an
email a thank you email somebody
purchases and then another follow-up
email and again you can repurpose some
of the content you've done in another
format in the form of an email so
you know if you created a video you know
put that video in the form of an email
and send it out to your audience to make
sure they're not missing out on that
video you just created so lots of ways
to use email take advantage of email
it's your ally here okay use native ads
okay don't be afraid to put that content
and pair it with some other content on
another website it's been proven people
are going to engage in an ad that they
see based on the content they're
currently reading because the ad if it's
native it's going to be similar in
nature to the content they're currently
engaged in and then measure your content
performance i can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging google analytics
okay with google analytics or facebook
insights or twitter or linkedin or any
other platform you're running on they're
going to have data on what you've posted
so take advantage of it
align your kpis so if it's an e-book or
case study don't measure just traffic
measure how many people are actually
downloading them okay if it's a video
how many people like the video how many
people are commenting how many people
are sharing the video how many people
subscribing to your playlist based on
that video content okay so these are all
things you can measure okay so every
platform from wordpress to youtube to
reddit has some form of analytics
associated with it today we're going to
talk about how to get traffic to your
website so thank you for joining and
let's get started so
let's imagine you're setting up your own
website okay you're clicking away you're
developing using some good tools you're
developing you're designing you're doing
some qa
you're testing you're sharing with
friends in an alpha version and then
finally
your website is all set up
congratulations well when you hit enter
and your website is finally published
what's going to happen well a few days
later you're checking your website and
you're looking at analytics and you
notice your traffic's very low okay well
you're scratching your head because
you've done all this work with your
website but you're not getting any
traffic so the reason is
you
spent all your time developing designing
the website to make it look good but you
didn't do anything
or any planning or any strategy around
bringing users to your website so the
two go hand in hand you just can't build
a website without
thinking about how to drive users to the
website and so before i tell you how to
bring traffic to your website let me
tell you why this is so important okay
why do we want to bring users to our
website i mean it has to be on equal
ground as web development and design is
somebody who goes to your site and then
does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when those
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view in certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be
you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as sales people
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or
you can increase brand awareness or
you can earn revenue through sponsored
posts and advertisements so if you have
for example a lot of content on your
website you can turn that in to
revenue by hosting ads on your website
so when somebody clicks on that ad
you're gonna earn a percentage of that
click okay what that click is worth so
having a website means
a lot of good things for you but first
you got to get the traffic there and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
tell you how to drive traffic to your
website so there's lots of different
ways in which you can bring traffic to
your website well the first is paid
advertising so paying to advertise your
products services with ads is one of the
easiest ways to drive traffic to your
website so some of the options available
are
search ads social media ads or display
ads so search ads are ads that are
displayed in the search engine results
so when a user types in a keyword query
you want your ad to show up based on
that keyword query okay so an example is
digital marketing course somebody types
in digital marketing course and simply
learn is the first app that shows up how
do we know it's an ad because you can
see the word ad next to the domain so
when somebody clicks on that link simply
learn is going to pay google so that's
how search advertising works okay the
next is social so social media marketing
involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness and lots
of different strategies but you're
instead of doing this on search you're
doing it on a social media platform okay
so
for example
you can advertise on any particular
platform and the way you advertise could
be with an image it could be with a
video so in this case you could see
cobreo
is doing a sponsored ad here how to
succeed with google ads and then another
form of advertising is display so
display means creating ads that are
placed on specific websites so with
display
unlike search you have a choice in the
ad format with search you only have text
ads but with display you have text edge
image ads rich media ads video ads so
you have lots of different options in
which you can advertise on other
websites so the idea here is to get your
ad in front of the right audience when
they could see your display banner your
banner ad
then it's going to be more visual
more appealing generate some brand
interest and hopefully you can get
somebody to click on that ad and over to
your website so
that's paid advertising again through
search through social through display
but you can also promote your site on
social media so once your content has
gone live you could take advantage of
different social media platforms i mean
it really depends on what you're trying
to promote because what you're trying to
promote needs to align with the
appropriate social media platform so
facebook is best suited for industries
like food and beverages and news and
media and if you're selling a product so
you fall into one of those categories
and facebook could be the right platform
for you if you're involved in again
beauty or food and beverage or
e-commerce then you can also leverage
instagram which is part of facebook's
ecosystem so if you advertise on
facebook you can also advertise on
instagram and or instagram so it doesn't
have to be and facebook and instagram it
could be facebook or instagram you also
have linkedin as a platform linkedin is
great for b2b so
if you're trying to promote industry
news or or tips and best practices or
job postings then linkedin is the place
for you it's a b2b platform it's great
for
targeting specific industries targeting
specific job levels or job descriptions
okay so linkedin is great if you're into
b2b focusing on the business side of it
so you also have youtube now youtube is
part of google's ecosystem youtube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so youtube's a great way to promote your
site
by getting your product out there in the
form of a video and then you have
twitter twitter to me encompasses a lot
of different industries beauty and
fitness news and media entertainment
okay you have limited number of
characters but
a lot of people are active on twitter
and it's a great way to generate some
awareness and get some clicks over to
your website so these are just some of
the most popular social media platforms
of course there are plenty more out
there the third way in which you can
drive traffic to your site is guest post
blogging so
most of you already know what blogging's
all about well if you're blogging for
your own site you can jump on somebody
else's site and blog on their behalf so
having the opportunity to guest post on
another website can be very helpful
because one that other blog could have
lots of traffic and have a a well-known
brand so if you're blogging on another
blog it's going to build your brand
awareness and potentially increase
traffic to your blog or website so it
exposes to you to targeted traffic so if
you're going to guest blog guest blog on
a site that's very relevant to your
business or industry that way you're
targeting the right audience okay you
can expand your personal network so
getting yourself out there getting your
brand out there in front of a different
audience and then obviously for service
because it generates a backlink so serps
search engine ranking pages means that
hey if you want to rank organically
you're going to have to generate some
backlinks so guest blogging is a way to
generate some backlinks to your site and
an effect that's going to help you get
your pages ranked higher because google
is going to recognize the relationship
from one blog to your blog and build up
your relevancy so some other benefits
here to guest blogging is you can grow
your social media following because you
can then promote that on social media
that you're guest blogging okay again
you can improve your online authority
okay because when you're guest blogging
and you have recognition on that guest
blog if it's a popular blog then it's
going to help your domain and page
authority for seo and then the end
result is going to improve your backlink
score so a lot of benefits to guest
blogging to me at the end of the day
it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that in the form of a blog and the
results of that is going to mean more
brand awareness for you and turning that
track so you can also interview industry
thought leaders so that's another way an
interesting way to generate traffic to
your site so reaching out to thought
leaders for interviews okay could
generate some credibility for you and
the other person so it's reciprocal so
it means that you're active in the
industry that you're in and it allows
you to engage with other
leaders in the industry and the indirect
net result of that could be increased
traffic because if you do the interview
and you record it or if it's via video
then you can obviously post it on other
platforms and that could in turn drive
traffic to your website obviously just
like guest blogging it's going to
increase your reach so getting yourself
out there nobody knows who your brand is
and they know who the thought leaders
are and they see you interviewing the
thought leaders then that's going to put
you in front of these people and so it's
going to increase your reach another way
to drive traffic to your website is just
to make sure your website's responsive
and what do we mean by responsive well
we mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
enlarges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure that your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so is content arranged
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website via mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
content's all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so they should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness on mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to
you know treat these people as loyal
customers okay maybe give them a
promotion
to use specifically just for them that
they can use on your website or talk
directly to them because you know that
they're followers they're repeat
customers they purchase for you multiple
times so talk to them differently as
well you know who these people are and
that's what building a brand is all
about it's about identifying your brand
with other people okay and identify
people who identify with your brand and
messaging and talking to them as if
they're part of your own community your
own family so you can use user generated
content that provides future marketing
strategies so the feedback you get from
your own community could be in turn used
to promote or used in future marketing
strategies i.e advertising i.e
post on social it can also provide pr
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to
you know put out press releases based on
the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately
give them the what they deserve the
respect and loyalty that they deserve as
well because they're communicating and
they're following you as a brand so the
next thing you could do to drive traffic
is be active in the comment section so
engage in relevant and thought-provoking
conversations on other blogs and sites
it doesn't necessarily have to be
another blog per se could be other sites
like reddit or cora or media sites that
have a lot of content that are broken
out by industry that allow you to engage
in conversation allow you to either
upvote or share or respond okay so be
active because when you're active people
are going to see that hey
you're a leader in the industry you know
what you're talking about you have some
some brand equity you have some thought
and some knowledge on the specific topic
and subject so it just puts you in a
better light when you can respond and be
active on these different platforms okay
let's turn our attention to
search engine optimization
also known as seo or organic search so
in order to drive traffic to your site
you're going to have to implement an seo
strategy why do you want to implement an
seo strategy because it can help you
improve your overall search ability and
visibility on search engines and
obviously that comes with advantages one
of those advantages is obviously more
traffic to the site search is still king
in terms of volumes of people using
search on a daily basis so you have a
great opportunity to be found it also
builds trust and credibility because
still a majority of the people who do a
search click on an organic search
listing and so if you're found
organically
and you're ranked number one then
chances are somebody's going to click on
your listing and it provides increased
engagement and traffic and so what that
means is more traffic more engagement an
engagement is something you define it
could be again a download of a document
or the clicking on the play button of a
video or or submitting a form or signing
up for a newsletter or calling these are
all forms of engagement so the the
amount of traffic you drive from organic
search to your website is only going to
improve engagement okay so you can also
provide and improve user experience and
what do we mean by that well if you're
getting lots of traffic from organic
search you have a really good
opportunity to do a b testing and when
you do a b testing you can improve user
experience meaning you're showing one
variation against the other from people
coming from organic search and so this
is helpful
and that you know if you're running an a
b test the variation has a chance to
improve or outperform the original and
if it outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps target quality traffic so seo to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so if somebody's looking for
a pair of red women's nike shoes the
2019 model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in new women's red nike
shoes size whatever at the year 2019
model then of course they're going to
probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of
product you're selling so again you have
a chance to really be visible for what
people are looking for and so that's the
beauty of search engine optimization you
have a really good opportunity here to
meet people halfway
to drive quality traffic to get them to
enjoy a good user experience all the
while generating engagement and along
with seo we want to be able to build
backlinks so
seo is a two-pronged approach meaning
you have two strategies in one on page
and off page and so
off page involves backlinking so
backlinks are just links that direct
users from
other websites to your own website so
with that inherently it's going to drive
traffic qualified traffic to your
website because if somebody's on a
relevant website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so
back linking because it's an off-page
strategy why is it an off-page seo
strategy because if google crawls that
other site that has a link to you
then that's going to give you credit
because google say hey this site's
getting some links from some relevant
sites we must think they're relevant and
therefore
we're going to trust this site so
by google
trusting your site it's going to improve
your organic ranking and with the
organic rankings being approved meaning
it's going to mean faster indexing so
what does that mean so you want to be
indexed by the search engines and so the
quicker google can find your pages even
if it's on somebody else's site then
that means they're going to follow that
link go to that page on your site and
take that page back to their servers to
be indexed okay so the quicker you can
get index the quicker you get found and
then it helps with referral traffic so
again we noticed that our efforts are on
seo organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts i mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
seo and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so
you want to do internal linking and that
just means connecting one page on your
site to another and why is that
beneficial because it can help direct
visitors to other pages they wouldn't
normally otherwise find via your
navigation so if you're active on a blog
don't be afraid to include multiple
internal links you want to move people
through your site you want the flow of
traffic to go from one page to another
to another and so when you do internal
linking just like with backlinks it's
going to improve the indexing of your
website google is going to follow those
links and index those pages and google
does give credits from an seo
perspective from an internal linking
perspective so if one page is linked to
another and that page has really good
relevance in the eyes of google then the
other page is probably going to benefit
from that the other reason you want to
do internal linking again you want to
move people from your one page of your
site to the other and when you do that
it's going to reduce bounce rates so
bounce rate is simply the rate at which
people land on a page and then leave so
if i have a hundred people land on my
home page and only one person went to
another page and the other 99 left the
site then that's a 99 bounce rate so by
putting internal links in place you're
helping people move from one page to the
other and thus
reducing the bounce rate and that's what
you want you want to keep people on your
site you want to be greedy it also
drives traffic to older posts so again
when we say older posts we're really
referring to blog posts so if you have a
relevant blog post and you're writing a
new blog post then link the two together
if it's relevant link it i don't you
know regardless of how old it is you
know you want to show google that these
older blog posts just because they were
written a year ago doesn't mean they're
outdated and old-fashioned okay or
useless you want to keep them alive by
linking to them so to me that's a good
strategy for internal linking link to
older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves
pagerank so what we mean by pagerank is
simply just a rank that google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and when we buy link juice again just
like backlinking it builds relevancy so
just keep all these inherent benefits in
mind to internal linking the end result
is keeping the flow of traffic on your
site and all these other benefits will
fall into place okay so another way in
which you can really hone in on traffic
to your website is long tail keywords
and long tail keywords to me are more
than just one or two keyword phrases
okay so they're usually three or longer
keywords in a phrase okay so long tail
keywords really nowadays account for
most web searches people
really take the time to even pose
questions as a search query say likely
somebody it's unlikely somebody's going
to go into search and just type in the
word shoes they might type in red shoes
but that's unlikely what they're
probably going to type in is you know
red nike running shoes 2019 or some
variation of that okay that's a long
tail keyword and some of the advantages
of using long tail keywords to be found
for are less competition so if you're
using broad keywords like red shoes then
who doesn't want to be found for red
shoes well you don't necessarily you
don't want to be found for red shoes
because it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
red shoes it could be running shoes it
could be work shoes it could be you know
boots it could be
slippers okay it's too bright so long
tail keywords help narrow it in and the
more narrow and focused the keyword is
the less competition it's gonna have and
when something's not competitive in the
form of a keyword then that means your
chances of ranking for that keyword are
gonna be greater and the chance of you
ranking faster are gonna be greater and
then of course if somebody's looking for
exactly what you have to offer then you
have a higher chance to convert that
person so if you have exactly those 2019
red nike women's running shoes and
somebody does a search for that and
that's a long tail keyword and they
click on your organic listing if you
have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like i just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for seo so remember seo is a two
pronged approach on page and off page we
talked about off page with internal
linking and backlinks on page is all
about
making sure those keywords you choose
are integrated in with the page you want
to be found for and so if you're using a
long tail keyword it's just easy to work
that keyword in so it enables easier
on-page optimization okay let's switch
away from seo to email marketing so
let's focus on email marketing as a form
or method of driving traffic to your
website so email marketing has been
around a long time in terms of digital
marketing why because it provides an
effective way to convert leads into
sales why because you can send
personalized emails to a target audience
so when you send an email to somebody on
a regular basis you know who that person
is so what are you doing in the email
you're writing a specific message to
that person well email marketing is the
same thing except you're just sending an
email to a larger group of people and
when you send an email to a larger group
of people you're still going to
personalize the message right you're not
going to send a generic email to 1 000
people okay nobody's going to do that so
make sure your email's targeted if it's
targeted it can be cost effective
why because sending large amounts of
emails or let's just say an email to a
large amount of people or a large group
of people is going to be cost effective
it's not cost per click you know it's
not cost per open okay so email usually
depending on the the
email provider you're using really is a
flat fee so it just really depends on
how many emails you're sending or how
how many people you're sending the email
to as well so but email generally tends
to be more cost effective than other
forms of marketing so look at the email
content provider you're using and just
get a sense of what they charge but if
you look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marketing is also time
saving okay meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely a majority of the
people
on day one or the day you send the email
are going to be able to view it open it
click on some of the links and convert
so
that's normally what happens in email
majority of the people open it on day
one and it kind of tails off from there
so think about it as real time so when
you send that email and if you have a
thousand people on your email recipient
list break it up send the first 500
first with a different subject line and
then you can see the data come in and if
you don't see the good results from the
subject line or the body of the email or
you know the page you're going to then
make adjustments before you send the
other email to the next 500. so that's a
great thing about emails you can break
up the email into two groups the first
group and then the second group with
different subject lines and you can
probably send them a little bit of time
apart that way you can learn from the
first email because with email
you are generally going to get results
right away okay within the first 24
hours so that's a great thing about
email okay so the other thing about
email it's less intrusive so normally
people who are going to get the email
are the ones who sign up for the email
so they're almost expecting your email
so when they get your email
again as long as you're not sending an
email on a daily basis normally most
companies send it monthly or bi-weekly
it's not going to be as intrusive okay
and then it also helps build credibility
increased visibility and brand awareness
meaning you're going to build your brand
in that email you're going to put
content in that email that's going to
show off your credibility meaning you
could put some testimonials in the email
you could put some good affiliations you
can put a good article to an industry
article you just wrote so email is going
to inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you could track it
right from that email so one thing i
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like google
analytics if you use google analytics
you're going to be able to track when
you send the email who clicks on it and
who converts so you want to be able to
measure an roi for these emails and you
can and that's the beauty of email
marketing okay let's move away from
email marketing to webinars so webinars
great method for effective social media
promotion it's a great way to bring
traffic to your website so why do we
recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group
what do we mean by contact with your
target group well you're going to host a
webinar and you're going to invite this
targeted group of people who are
interested in your product or service so
if you have a facebook community you
could do a facebook live event or you
could do a youtube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
on another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouncing
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target group so you're going
to be able to create a webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software i mean i'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
uh create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money and webinars
again allow you to talk to your targeted
group your community maybe prospective
clients it helps build credibility and
in effect drive traffic to your website
and when somebody does attend a webinar
they're likely going to be highly
engaged because you're inviting them
they're going to opt into the webinar
and the great thing about webinars is
even if they don't attend the webinar
the day you have it it's going to be
recorded so they can always go back and
watch it so whoever watches the webinar
is going to be engaged because it's
going to be a topic they're interested
in and then users are likely to become
prospective customers so
having a webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to
sign up and watch the webinar and if you
do they're going to be engaged and then
take the next step oh i like what this
guy this person has to say they seem to
be credible i like their personality i
like their brand i like their product
i'm gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
youtube or vmail okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embedded in a
facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
in sales or or roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get built
trust it's going to increase engagement
and that's the beauty of video unlike
text or imagery
videos really do engage with the
audience and so the more video you could
do the better off you are because again
you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves roi so always think
video there's plenty of video software
out there that you can leverage and the
great thing about video 2 is hey most
people are using mobile phones these
days smartphones and so video works just
as well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging regardless of what
device somebody uses and then of course
if they're watching the video on
facebook or youtube then chances are
they're going to
share that particular video which is
going to bode well for your brand and
traffic okay so video if somebody likes
a video it's very easy to share video
especially from a mobile phone so
youtube just makes it so easy to share
or like or subscribe to a channel it
just it becomes that much easier things
can go viral and chances of them going
viral with video are going to be greater
okay so other ways to drive traffic to
your website is submit your content to
content aggregators so what's a content
aggregator well a content aggregator is
like reddit that provides a great
platform for you to post your content so
that's what a content aggregator is
really a site like reddit or medium or
quora where you could post content to a
large number of people okay so with
reddit people are either going to upvote
it or downvote it so the more upvotes
you get or thumbs up or likes or people
who encourage that content the more of a
chance it has to be found and so first
thing out of the gate if you do provide
content to a content aggregator like
reddit make sure it's good quality
content that's interesting and that
should be a case the case across the
board whether it's a social post or blog
post make sure the content's unique
professional and interesting and then if
you do say put something on medium or
you do put something on quora and it is
professional and interesting and
thought-provoking then people are going
to react to it and then that again could
lead to traffic but even if it doesn't
lead to traffic it helps build brand
awareness so if you have content just
like videos leverage it put the content
out there and when you put content out
there it's only gonna especially if it's
good content put it's gonna put you in a
good light so don't be afraid to share
your content on the likes of reddit or
medium or core or some of these other
content aggregator websites because good
things are only going to happen and
again referral traffic seo brand
awareness conversions so all these are
inherent benefits of just sharing your
content okay and then finally we want to
learn from analytics okay so what do we
mean learning from analytics so there
are plenty of analytics platforms out
there one of the most popular is google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with google analytics so i have to do is
just go to google analytics via search
sign up add the analytics code to your
website and while uh they're doing all
the heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming your website and not only
they're going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it google analytics is hey you could
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that i sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from youtube based on that
video i posted or they coming from
reddit based on the content i just
posted there or they coming from organic
search it so google analytics can help
us understand how much traffic we're
getting from organic search so to help
us measure our seo efforts and then with
google analytics you could segment so we
could segment by mobile we can segment
by desktop returning user new user by
campaign by page by language by city by
region i mean there's so many ways in
which to segment your audience and
segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to see so
if you want to look at you know females
between the ages of 18 to 24 who come
from mobile via organic search that's a
segment and you can look at that
information in analytics if that's your
target audience then you can see how
they're performing okay so anal there
are a lot of benefits to google
analytics definitely want to take
advantage of
segmenting in google analytics you could
look at your competition so there's a
benchmarking report the great thing
about google analytics you can also look
at content and how your content is
performing when somebody lands on your
website are they what page are they
spending time on what page are they
engaging on the most okay what pages
have the highest bounce rate or the
lowest time on page so you can really
determine what pages work best and then
of course the end result in analyzing
all this data is you want to be able to
fine-tune your website so take advantage
of the data that google analytics or any
other analytics platform is giving you
by learning once you learn what's going
on with your website you can make
adjustments to your website to improve
user experience okay so we went over a
lot of different ways to drive traffic
okay you can incorporate all this to
your website immediately welcome today
we're going to talk about email
marketing tutorial so buckle up and
let's get started with email marketing
tutorial and so let's start out asking
the question why email marketing so
linda is the owner of an e-commerce
company and basically she isn't able to
take her leads the leads she's
collecting per day per month and convert
them into customers okay so customers
sign up but they don't buy her product
so she's left scratching her head
wondering what to do so how she gonna
solve the problem of converting the lead
she gets into paying customers well look
no further than email market so you can
boost your sales funnel with the help of
email marketing so email marketing leads
to
email campaigns that lead to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing email markings also in a it's
a very good way to generate a high
return on investment so
linda thinks this is too good to be true
you're telling me is a very efficient
way to generate a return on my
investment how expensive is email
marketing well email marketing is
neither expensive or time consuming
that's the beauty of email marketing and
so linda is now
very interested we've piqued her
interest she wants
us to explain
email marketing to her in detail and
that's exactly what we're going to do
we're going to talk about email
marketing in detail so for everyone out
there listening
what's in it for you
why are you going to invest your time
and listening to
simply learn and me talk about email
marketing because we're going to talk
about everything there is about email
marketing in today's webinar so what is
it for those that aren't really familiar
with the intricacies of email marketing
we're going to talk about how to set up
email marketing we're going to discuss
all the benefits of email marketing
we're going to get into a b testing
we're going to get into the automation
of emails the types of emails how to
engage new users and we're going to give
you a demo so there's a lot going on in
this webinar like i said buckle up and
let's get started and talk about
what is email marketing so as i
mentioned to linda it's an efficient way
to convert leads into sales why because
we can send personalized emails to a
specific audience a targeted audience if
somebody's interested in our product we
can reach out to them via email it can
also be used to re-market pre-qualified
leads so anybody who's pre-qualified we
can go ahead and communicate with them
as well so email marketing is very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when i say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so let's talk about each
one of these parts of the funnel or
customer life cycle if you will so let's
start with awareness at the very top so
email marketing allows customers to
recognize their problems after which you
can educate them on how your brand can
solve them okay just like any other
marketing channel somebody's looking for
something in need of something and we
can come to the rescue in this case
we're going to come to the rescue with
email and we can go ahead and educate
them on what their need is and how we
can collaborate with them help them
educate them solve their problems with
our product okay so that's what email's
going to do we're going to communicate
with them via email and we're going to
bring awareness to the problem by
solving the problem that's what email is
good for okay good for generating
awareness for our brand for example we
can share a newsletter with our
customers so we're running a cosmetics
company we can basically educate them on
the five important skin care products
that everyone should have okay so we can
get them to click on the call to action
to learn more so if somebody's having
some skin care issues or
not sure what products to buy you know
an email can cover that okay the next
step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so customers focused on
searching for relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely looking
they're a little further in the process
they're educated they know what they're
looking for so we can really hit them
with the right email we can send a
relevant email to promote our product
okay discover that perfect moisturizer
for your skin that perfect skin
moisturizer smooths hydrates and
contains spf 20. so we got the perfect
product for that person who's further
along the funnel and really is ready to
purchase that product so we can hit that
person up with the perfect messaging
talk about purchase the next step in the
life cycle well purchase well with
purchase we can send an email that
encourages that customer purchase our
product by offering them something okay
by giving an offer for example we can
give a discount discounts always tend to
work so that moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying well they can move from
consideration to purchasing because
we're going to offer them a discount
they can't refuse okay so you know it
could beat for a specific date okay it
could be you know something that's going
to get them excited to buy the product
20 off of moisturizers pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other products they were
considering buying so getting somebody
that extra incentive to purchase the
product goes a long way via email okay
we want to take that next step in the
life cycle and nurture our relationship
with customers to ensure they're loyal
okay they've already purchased how do we
get them purchased again that's
retention we want to retain our
customers we want to get them back to
buy the same product or similar products
or completely different products in our
inventory so what do we do we're going
to send an email we're going to send an
email to active customers okay we're
going to give them an offer just for
them exclusively just for them in this
example we're gonna give them a combo
pack a facial kit at just 39 and get a
sunscreen worth ten dollars for free
so you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations on offers key is
the offer is exclusively just for those
who you want to target and retain as
customers because if you just get
somebody to purchase once it's not going
to work those people have already taken
the that step in the relationship where
they trust your product they purchase
your product now you want to go ahead
and treat that customer special by
giving them an exclusive offer and then
what we want to do is advocacy last step
in that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer into brand
advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite non-profit could be educating
poor children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to
get them to speak on our behalf and say
look guys this is a really good company
you know they're offering me products
exclusively they've offered me discounts
in the past they have good products they
have a lot of different products and on
top of all that
they help they help the environment they
help the needy okay they care and so we
can go ahead and provide a call to
action for these customers that are
loyal to our brand and have them share
the email with their friends to spread
the word on you know what we're trying
to accomplish for our non-profit or if
anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount for every
friend that they get to buy a product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
you know just sharing with friends it
can be that extra incentive of giving
them a discount if they do share with
friends and their friends buy okay so
this is the customer life cycle and
examples of different emails that you
can use at every step along the way in
the life cycle so let's take a look at
an example if we go back to our email
marketing platform mailchimp in this
example we're going to take a look at
some reports so most email marketing
platforms have reporting functionality
built in and so in this case what we
want to do is we want to be able to take
a look at the open rate click-through
rates of the emails that have been sent
out previously so here we could see our
april email coupon versus tools promo
okay so we've had basically you know
opens and clicks so 14
open rate 1.4 click-through rate okay so
the march email that went out did a
little bit better 19 open two and a half
percent on the click-through rate so
here we could see how many people
actually were sent how many open it and
how many clicks so this is a mailchimp
makes it very easy for us to measure you
know open and click rates and then we
can measure by revenue as well based on
the campaign so
that's
measuring the response rate so it's all
built in so most email marketing
platforms have open rate and click rate
already built into the functionality so
you can measure those two metrics
against any email so let's talk about
the benefits of email marketing so what
are some of the benefits well we've
already mentioned to linda
that it's cost effective it's time
saving real time marketing less
intrusive builds credibility increases
visibility and brand awareness and it's
an easy way to track roi these are all
the benefits for email marketing we're
gonna go talk about some of these now so
basically when we talk about
cost-effective you know some email
marketing platforms charge based on the
number of users who you send the email
to time saving well you saw how quick it
took me to set up that email campaign
the key is figuring out who you want to
send it to when we talk about real-time
marketing you know we're sending this
email out basically in real time trying
to meet our customers needs at the right
time it's less intrusive because we can
customize the emails okay we can as you
saw i can put first name in there to
make it more personal so when
something's more personal it's less
intrusive especially if it's a segment
that already knows your brand okay
builds credibility hey we gain
credibility when we offer exclusive
offers to repeat customers or you know
try and build advocacy by working with
non-profits okay it increases visibility
and brand awareness why because you know
we could send our email out to a large
group of people and that's a good way to
generate brand awareness and as you saw
we can easily measure you know not only
open rates click rates but roi so how
many people from that email went on and
purchased so we can measure that it's
very easy to measure email it comes to
completing your profile on mailchimp
you're going to need an audience to send
these emails to and so when you click on
audience here if you don't have an
audience already imported into mailchimp
you're going to be asked to import so
you can see i already have one contact
that contacts me because i added my
email address on that test email so
mailchimp smart enough to say okay we
don't have this email address and our
contact list so we're going to add them
so here we could see we can manage our
audience so we can add subscribers we
can import contacts we can have sign up
forms and we can manage our contacts so
if we import our contacts if i click on
import here i'm going to be asked to
import either from a csv or copy and
paste or i can just go ahead and
integrate it so if i choose for example
any one of these then it's going to pull
in the context i have there and so it's
up to you how you import your contacts
now the whole point of contacts is you
want to probably or really not probably
it's a best practice to actually create
different lists so that you can use
different audience lists with different
emails and so here you can see i have
one email address i can again import
contacts or i can add them individually
so i can add subscribers here okay
that's another option that's the slower
option my recommendation be import them
but when you import make sure you you're
importing lists that have some
commonality so you can manage those
lists so if you have one list that are
say you know clients who have never
purchased then you want to create a list
for them if you have clients who have
purchased separate those out okay so
that's the way i would go about it now
if you're trying to build a list
mailchimp has what they call signup
forms so you have different forms that
you can embed and or have as a pop-up
and when people add their email address
to that form then it's automatically
going to get added to your mailchimp
account so that's a great feature in
mailchimp that allows you to
you know build out your audience just by
using one of their forms so again we
have a subscriber pop-up you've probably
seen some of these on some of the
websites you've gone to
so you can customize it and if you want
somebody to subscribe to your newsletter
for example all they need to do is enter
in their email address and click
subscribe okay that's the the pop-up
version now again you have the
opportunity to
you know use other forms as well so you
got a form builder here or an embedded
form okay or you can integrate the form
okay so if i click form integrations
here i can use wufoo or squarespace i
can integrate with them if i go back to
signup forms if i choose form builder
here i have a signup form and then i can
customize that form with different boxes
okay or fields okay so whatever field i
want somebody to add information to i
can have that in there and then this
form could be you know on your website
so that's a great feature about
mailchimp is it helps you build an
audience so i can add this form to my
website and anybody who fills out that
form this is going to be added to
my subscriber list that i can use for
future emails to take that a step
further i can even go from building a
form to building a landing page so here
you can see if i click on audience i can
go ahead at the bottom right here i have
an option to create a landing page so if
i click on that just like everything
else in mailchimp it's fairly easy to
use i'm just going to name it test click
begin here i can choose my audience
again i can what audience do i want to
add these emails to i click begin and
i'm going to accept and here now i have
all these different templates that i can
use as a landing page so if you want to
use these landing pages to collect
emails and those emails are going to be
added to your audience then you have a
nice selection here at your disposal
okay so here i'm just gonna choose one
you know grow my list okay this is a
landing page so i can customize it just
like i do with my email template i can
add my logo okay i can start adding
different fields here like an image i
can drop an image here okay i can go
ahead and
you know drop in my social shares okay i
can drop in a box text box okay and then
i can start customizing it with some
text some imagery you know some other
information again this is a landing page
that i can then add to my website and so
anytime somebody goes to the landing
page and fills out their email address
and hits subscribe it's going to be
added to that audience list and then i
can turn around and send an email using
one of mailchimp's templates to that
audience so mailchimp really does a
great job of allowing you to grow your
list within your own website via a
landing page a form submission or or
forum or pop-up so there are lots of
different options available to us so i'm
going to click save and close here and
now this landing page is available to me
so i can customize the url i can edit
the audience that these emails go to i
can add a page title and again i can
edit the design so i can really make
this an integrated part of my website by
designing it so it fits the feel and
look of my website i can add a specific
url and i can add a nice page title to
it so mailchimp again does a great job
of just making it so easy for you to
build out a landing page for you to use
on your website to collect email
addresses so if you're doing a
pay-per-click campaign on facebook or
google you can actually drive traffic to
these landing pages and get people to
fill out a form submission and when they
fill out the form submission that email
address is going to get added to your
audience that's an option or you can
just add it as part of your website and
people who go there from say organic
search can find that page and add their
email address organically so that's a
great thing about the audience feature
in mailchimp and that not only can you
select an email template but you have
options to grow your audience okay again
importing contacts you can simply just
add contacts you can add you know a form
submission via pop-up or regular form
fields to your website or you can add a
landing page so it's important to note
that in mailchimp if you go to the
content studio that's where you're going
to find all the files that you've added
to all your templates or landing pages
that you used before so if i click on
content studio here here you can see the
files i've added to my templates if you
have products you can add your products
here okay so if you have an e-commerce
store you can certainly add your
products and then those products can be
used on your landing page or your email
templates you have something called a
giphy you can insert these into any of
your emails make it fun exciting
engaging here you have instagram so what
you can do is you can integrate you know
any one of your instagram accounts if
you have multiple accounts or if you
have one instagram account you can
integrate that one instagram account in
with your mailchimp account and when you
do that it's going to pull in all the
images that you've had on instagram and
then you have an opportunity here just
to add a logo okay so you can use any of
your instagram images within your emails
use one of these cool giffies again you
can import your products that you can
use for your email templates or just
keep tabs on all the files that you've
added before just by clicking on my
files now when you get to the point of
building different audience lists and
sending down emails you're gonna have
the option to look at reporting to see
how those emails perform for those
specific audiences now again an audience
is a set it's like a segment you know
these are set of individuals who are
going to receive a specific email so in
this example you can see i have
different audiences and if we look at
say any one of these audience or even
just go to all audiences we'll be able
to see
how we fared on some of our emails okay
so for example if i sent out an email
here in april and this is april of 2019
i could see how many total subscribers
i've had now along with the number of
subscribers you have you have what we
call open rate and click-through rate
now we explain a lot of the reporting
and the specific email metrics and
another recording that we did last week
so if you're interested in learning more
about some of the metrics then check out
the video that we have on youtube email
marketing tutorial uh we recorded this
last week go into details about all the
different metrics you
uh can learn about with email marketing
so take a look at this video email
marketing tutorial it'll be a nice
precursor to the mailchimp tutorial so
to give you some insights as to what
metrics to really pay attention to with
email marketing but in mailchimp we know
we can look at the total number of
subscribers we know that we have how
many opens and we know what the open
rate is and again the total number of
clicks and what the click-through rate
is okay so with mailchimp very easily
you just hover over it you get the raw
number and then the percentage so open
rate is how many people actually open
that email based on the total number of
people that the email was sent to so
here we could see
in this particular email last year in
april you know we've had 14 14 1.1
percent to be exact and that is thirteen
thousand three hundred seventy seven
divided by ninety seven thousand four
sixty nine so that's how many people
open the email so thirteen thousand out
of ninety seven is about fourteen
percent now when somebody opens it we
hope they're going to click on it and so
here we got a
1.4 percent click-through rate again
that's the total number of clicks based
on the total number of subscribers or
people that were sent the email and so
mailchimp just gives you a nice overview
of how many subscribers were in this
particular audience list and then the
open rating click rate so we can really
dive in here and we can actually see how
that particular email performs so if we
just pick one email here we can just
click view report we have other options
here we can print we can download we can
share it the whole campaign or just view
the email if we want to view what the
email look like we can select that so we
just want to view the report so we're
going to click view report and now we
can get into some nice detailed
information about the actual report
itself so again here you can see total
number of recipients
and this came from the audience list
called newsletter okay was delivered
last year september 26 2018 again i have
the option to view it download it print
it or share it so let's take a look and
view the email to see what it looked
like okay so this is what the email look
like we have our own template here and
here you can see it takes into account
some of the best practices involved with
email marketing you know we have some
nice content imagery some call to action
here some other links okay we have our
social icons okay so that's what the
email looked like okay so we'll go back
and we're going to click view report now
we want to view the report again here's
what it look here's when it was sent
okay the open rate for this was 21
click-through rate was 4
so for us the list average this list
here newsletter the average was for the
open rate 16.8 so we're above the
average on this email for the
click-through rate the list average is
2.7 so we're above the average so
we've done a good job on this email at
least generating more opens more clicks
and mailchimp even takes that a step
further they'll even show you what the
industry average is for your particular
industry and in this case we're
education and training so we did better
than the industry average for both the
open rate and for the click-through rate
so we could see some other specifics we
could see the raw numbers of opens
clicks how many people bounced meaning
the email address wasn't valid anymore
and so mailchimp does a good job of any
email that actually bounces it'll be
scrubbed and removed from your list and
then here you can see 347 unsubscribe so
the the thing about you know mailchimp
is we want to be careful we don't have
too many unsubscribes and also people
abusing or reporting abuse meaning you
don't want to send out an email multiple
multiple times a week where it gets the
point where it's spammy and so you want
to avoid a high number of unsubscribes
and a high number of abuse reports and
so here you can see
most emails are open within a 24 24-hour
period and then it kind of just tails
off so here we can see opens and clicks
based on the time of day so within 24
hour period okay so this is how most
emails operate within that first 24
hours you're going to get a lot of opens
a lot of clicks and then it's going to
tail off from there great thing is
mailchimp provides me more detailed
information about what was clicked so i
could see here the top links that were
clicked and let me just point one thing
out here
whether you use mailchimp or you use any
other platform whether that be vertical
response or any other type of email
marketing platform you want to use utm
tracking with your links so that google
analytics can pick up the actual
campaign so here you can see we have utm
tracking appended to our links and let
me just go in to detail on that for just
a minute so mailchimp again gives us
nice data on open and click-through
rates but when we send out an email and
people actually do click on one of these
links they're going to go to our website
and from there google analytics is going
to take over on the tracking so this is
as far as mailchimp goes so we want to
be able to bridge the gap between
mailchimp reporting and google analytics
meaning when they came from the
email when and went to the site did they
convert meaning did they download
something did they purchase something
and so we want to be able to bridge the
gap and utm tracking which is simply
appending the original url with some
tracking parameters named utm
it allows us to bridge that gap so all
you need to do when you set up a
mailchimp campaign is just go to url
builder in google then you're going to
click on campaign url builder and we're
going to go ahead and set up an email
campaign so for example
if we go back here this was the original
url so if i just copy this original url
here and paste that as part of my
website url what's my campaign source
i'm going to put mailchimp with my
medium i'm gonna put email so mailchimp
is the source of where the traffic came
from the medium the means in which they
arrived at our website was via email and
then the campaign name we're just gonna
put maybe whatever it is summer promo so
with the url builder you have five
parameters for utm tracking you don't
have to use all five okay so here we
need to put in the url and we need to
put in the source but the other four
parameters medium name term and content
are optional so you don't have to put
anything there but the more parameters
you put in the more specific it is for
you to track the behavior of that email
campaign so here i can see mailchimp
email summer promo and then for the
content i can use that to differentiate
my subject lines so when you send out an
email we mention this in the email
marketing tutorial you always want to
send out multiple subject lines meaning
one list gets one subject line another
list gets this a second subject line
because you want to be able to measure
open rates based on subject lines so i
can use the campaign content parameter
for different subject lines and notice
the url builder once i enter in my
parameters it's going to append the
original url with a new url appended
with utm tracking so if i copy that i
can simply just paste that in my browser
just to see if it works and here you can
see it works the page loaded the
original url with utm tracking and so
that's exactly what you want to do
because when you're looking at your
reports in mailchimp it's going to show
me the top links that were clicked now
if i go in analytics i want to be able
to see how that campaign or how that
link actually performed so let's take a
look at that real quick so if i go to my
google analytics account and i go to
acquisition campaigns all campaigns what
am i looking for well if i click on
source and medium source and medium are
to the parameters for utm tracking i'm
going to look for mailchimp so here i
could see um original url mailchimp and
then the date stamp and then the
medium's email so if i go back here i
can see for example any one of these
mailchimp emails that went out and then
i can see how many people actually came
from the email what the balance rate was
meaning if they arrived on the side did
they leave after arriving or did they
actually go to another page and then i
could see other engagement data like how
many pages they looked at did they how
much time did they spend more
importantly did they convert so that's
the whole idea behind using utm tracking
because with utm tracking you can can
bridge the gap from open rate click
through rate to behavior on the website
all the way through to the conversion
and that's what we want to measure we
want to measure did somebody go from the
email open it click on one of the links
go to the website engage on the website
and convert and so that's the whole idea
behind utm tracking because mailchimp
and any other email marketing platform
is only going to give you at most your
open rates and your click-through rates
okay so here we could see the top links
clicked i see 4 000
recipients clicked on this email they
went to the site and now i need
analytics to kind of tell me the rest
and here i can see what subscribers had
the most opens and if i integrated
social i can see some social performance
and so that goes back to our original
setup so if you integrate your twitter
account or your facebook account you'll
be able to
integrate that email in with your
twitter and then from there i'll be able
to see you know tweets or or how many
likes for example and to top it off i
can see how many people from around the
world clicked on the email so that's
reporting in a nutshell on mailchimp
reports are fairly easy to look at you
know all sorts of other information like
links specifically links
you can look at social so if i click on
the social tab here if i integrated my
social i can look at social reporting
likewise for e-commerce and notice
analytics 360 i can integrate google
analytics in with mailchimp if i want to
so i have all sorts of options on my
reporting so that's it for mailchimp i
mean it's fairly easy to navigate you
have all the campaigns that you've sent
out so if you just click on campaigns
i'll be able to see all the campaigns
i've set up and all the campaigns that
have been sent and obviously the ones
that have been sent i can start looking
at reports i can pick and choose
templates okay i can pick and choose my
audience and manage my audience okay i
can see what the growth is from audience
again i have different options to grow
my audience okay i can certainly add
form submissions landing pages
sign up forms i can import more contacts
and i can manage them through different
lists content studio is where all your
files are going to be located from the
files you've uploaded to e-commerce
products to githi's to instagram to my
logo and then you have reports and the
reports are there for you to measure the
performance of your email campaigns once
they've been sent so you can look at
them from reports or just from the main
campaigns view that's pretty much it so
if you're ready to go at it again click
that create button click that template
choose that audience you can go ahead
and send yourself that test email when
you're ready go ahead and send that
email off to your audience it's that
simple in mailchimp and today we're
going to talk about affiliate marketing
so
let's jump right into it and take a look
inside an office environment right now
we have chuck here chuck's doing a
little bit of pacing john walks in the
office hey man what's with all the
pacing everything all right chuck
responded hey i'm just worried that i
might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product i mean i've done
seo i've done paid search i've done
email i've done social man nothing's
working i gotta come up with something
new asap well john responds hey don't
worry i think i've got your solution for
you man hang tight relax take a load off
here's my solution affiliate marketing
first off before you ask the question
what's affiliate marketing let's talk
about why we need affiliate marketing so
let's dig into affiliate marketing so
john's just taking over now and he's
gonna let chuck know everything there is
to know about affiliate marketing so the
first question john answers for chuck
what is affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if i'm selling a
product basically somebody else sells
that product for me i'm gonna pay that
person a commission for selling my
product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these merchants are doing or other
entities they're advertising your
product so they're advertising your
product with a referral so they're
passing on their own customers to you so
that they can buy your product and again
the exchange is you give that website or
other entity a commission that's more or
less what affiliate marketing is so
john's gonna have us take a look at each
of these components of affiliate
marketing in detail take it away john so
john says first we have the merchant aka
the brand the seller the creator the
founder the owner the inspiration the
innovator hey this is the person who
came up with this brilliant idea this
brilliant idea has to get out there
we're the merchant we're trying to get
this brilliant idea out to the masses so
this is the component of affiliate
marketing that creates the product the
merchant could be anyone okay so it
could be startups to large multinational
companies international companies
non-profits for-profits individuals
independent contractors freelancers a
group of people who have a passion for
something okay it could be anybody
there's no limit the affiliate aka the
publisher so the affiliate is basically
that third-party website or entity which
promotes the merchant's products and
tries to convince potential customers of
the merchant's product's value so this
affiliates going to represent the
merchant on their behalf and try and get
their clients to basically purchase that
particular merchant's product so the
affiliate could be incentivized based on
you know registrations email sign up
sales and subscriptions so it doesn't
always come down to
you know sales you know if i'm just
trying to get you know build my email
list then hey i can incentivize that
affiliate to push email signups if i've
got this big you know offline you know
promotion that i'm doing at this
particular mall and i want to get people
there well i can get an affiliate and
incentivize that affiliate to drive and
help me drive registrations for this
event so it doesn't always have to be
sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that merchant who has
this brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially drive registrations sales
signups etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
affiliates it allows merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your prospective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate network merchants can
use tools for tracking and reporting and
processing payments for affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant an
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in the affiliate
network to see and track how
sales are going and when sales happen
okay or commissions happen you want to
be able to use that affiliate network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
john so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
affiliate would not get any commission
so we need customers so john what is the
process of affiliate marketing well john
says let's have a look at the process so
it's affiliate marketing time so we're
going to use a tool or platform like
commission junction commission junction
is a popular you know platform that
affiliate network platform that brings
merchants and affiliates together so the
merchants can use those affiliates to
advertise their product so let's take a
look at uh commission junction as a good
digital marketing tool for affiliate
marketing so we're going to use
commission junction as an example here
remember in affiliate marketing it's an
ecosystem between
publishers
and merchants so remember merchants are
selling products publishers are selling
those merchant products on their site
and so commission junction is the
middleman so to speak okay so commission
junction just known as cj now is the
middle person they're introducing the
publisher and the merchant and so let's
go ahead and log in here so when you log
in like any other digital marketing tool
any other platform you're gonna have
your own settings and whatnot so really
the whole idea behind any affiliate
marketing tool is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell the product
somebody who has a targeted audience
it's similar to yours okay so
we go into cj.com we're going to log in
and here you can see a publisher's link
so we're going to click on the
publishers link and remember when you
sign up publishers you have to have
program terms and so if we click on
publishers program terms we're going to
be able to see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program turns we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher
so as a best practice if you have
publishers who are actually performing
well who are selling your products maybe
you want to offer them a little bit more
on the commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program charms as you
want there's no limit here you want to
be able to align and reward program
terms again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publisher is performing well
sweeten the deal offer them a better
program terms and so you can align
publishers with different program terms
and so that's the whole the idea behind
program terms is you want to be able to
align publishers with that so when you
sign up a publisher they're going to get
a line with a program term meaning what
are they going to get paid for selling
your product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports
in
cg.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here we can't or
these publishers can't make any money if
they don't generate clicks so that's why
you have an epc model or metric so to
speak so you can measure earnings per
click cj does it over seven day period
and over a three month period so you
could sort based on seven day or three
month to see who's earning the most per
click in terms of publishers now you can
select under publishers groups now you
can group your publishers okay so if you
have say a group of publishers in a
specific region like the united states
or india or if you're just focused on
the united states and say you have
publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so as you
get more publishers for your network
you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again i'm gonna repeat it is
you want to get
publishers you want to start building
your base of publishers because the more
publishers you have the more chance you
are to sell your product remember if
nobody clicks on your product then
nobody's going to buy your product so if
you have publishers who are promoting
your product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense as a business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers now when
you're in cj and you're starting out
okay you want to start recruiting your
publishers so you click on recruit and
based on your settings based on what
you're selling cj is going to try and
put you in front of
some good publishers and so here we
could see if we click on recruit we're
going to get a list of publishers and
this search results list of publishers
that we can recruit into our network are
all listed here and you can actually see
what's interesting you can see the name
of the publisher and you can see the url
and then you could actually see
if they're a good performer or not so
you could actually see their history as
a publisher just by looking at their
network earnings and then also looking
at their seven day
earnings per click or three month
earnings per click and so if a publisher
has a very high earnings per click epc
then they're probably a good publisher
somebody you're probably going to be
interested in so if i see a publisher
with you know three month earnings per
click of 105
then that means hey if that's my
publisher i'm paying 105 or 106 over
seven days you know they're generating
some clicks for me and they're
generating sales you can't deliver
commission if they don't sell and so to
me i want to be able to look at the
seven three month earnings per click for
these publishers and so i can just click
on any one of these publishers here and
get some more insight about that
publisher right here in cj so
here i can see the particular url the
company some other urls that they have
associated with them in cj i could see
the category that they're in again i can
see the seven three month epc here you
can see description okay you can see
some other promotional methods that
they'd use when promoting products and
you get some program performance from
this particular publisher just by
pulling down the pull down menu here i'm
going to look at this year and see what
their performance is and why i'm waiting
for that to load i could see hey they're
also in other countries as well so i can
get
a good snapshot of
a particular publisher by recruiting
publishers seeing what their performance
is over a period of time and potentially
you know recruiting that publisher would
be part of my network because if they're
part of my network then hey if they're
selling products if i'm selling products
and i want my product on their site and
they're doing a good job of selling
other products then i want them to be
you know part of my ecosystem part of my
network now remember
cj's doing the introducing here they're
introducing you to recruits so
you want to be able to again take a look
at the site does do any of the sites
that a particular publisher has
interest you you know again we can just
click on it go to the specific site take
a good look hey virgin atlantic okay do
we want them selling our product maybe
maybe not um so you want to take a look
at the website make sure it's not spammy
make sure it aligns with your business
goals it makes your aligns with your
product your target audience remember a
lot of things you want to make sure the
website aligns with because they're
representing your brand okay very
important here very important and so
that's what you want to be able to do
and you could do all that just by
looking at the publisher detail in cj
and then again take a look at earnings
per click if they're selling products
for other merchants and they're doing a
good job maybe you want them selling
your product as well okay so you can
also
you know sort by country you can also do
network earnings and you can really
filter here so if we want you know
choose high network earners in a
particular country a particular state
you know we could definitely filter in
on a particular
type of publisher okay so you want to be
able to hone in on somebody to align
with your geography or you know
definitely you want to align with
somebody who's a high network owner now
when you get all your publishers set up
you're going to need to provide them
with some good promotional materials
some good banners um you know it could
be text links some messaging okay so
you're the one who's going to provide
the publishers with you know the
information they need now
as a best practice remember you can get
on the phone with these publishers have
monthly calls or quarterly calls see
what they need you know reach out to
them via email or reach out to them via
the cj platform figure out hey you know
how's your banners working for you do
you need new banners so you want to be
able to constantly you know push new
content out and so
if i click on links here
and manage i'll be able to see
everything that i have available for my
publishers to use okay and then you can
actually look at
banners that have actually produced for
you in terms of epc or
you know if it's a specific promotion
okay you could set that up here so
you're gonna be able to see it here you
can see all the banners you can see some
text links in here so all the you know
advertising that you want these
publishers to have is going to be
situated under links and so you can see
what the active ones are you can look at
archived you can look at again text
links content links or banners and as a
best practice if i click on a banner as
a best practice ideally what you want to
do is use utm tracking okay so you want
to have some type of tracking in place
however
cj does a lot of the tracking for you so
they're going to be able to tell you how
many times a banner's been clicked and
how many times a banner's been seen okay
they'll also tell you more importantly
not only was that banner click but did
it generate a sale and so here i can see
that i have three publishers using this
particular banner i can see over this
period of time 412 impressions meaning
412 people viewed the banner and i
received one click on it so you can get
some in-depth detail about your
different marketing materials and how
they're performing okay you can also see
what publishers are using them okay so
the key here is
you want to be able to communicate with
your publishers give them the
promotional material and that they need
to promote your product now you could
set up specifically you could set up a
unique banner for a publisher or you
could set up a banner for a group of
publishers that's where the group comes
in so you have some options here and
then as a best practice what i would try
and do as you can see here is come up
with different banner sizes so you can
see here we got a 728 by 90. okay you
got a 160 by 600 you get a 300 by 250
okay so you want to have different
banner sizes and you also want to mix in
some text um ads as well okay you want
to be able to give your publishers some
options in terms of what to use on their
websites so that's the whole idea
because a publisher may not have space
on the home page they may only have
enough space for
you know a text ad or a 300 by 250. so
you want to be able to mix it up and
then also mix up the messaging as well
so you can have the same 300 250 banner
but you can have different messaging
just like you see here 300 by 250 got
this messaging here and we got a
different set of messaging with the same
banner size so the more options you
present for yourself the more of an
opportunity you have for the publisher
to use that messaging that banner that
text ad on their website and then that
gives you a better opportunity to get
the click get the conversion that you
seek out so
that is links so you want to be able to
continue to
push out different banners and text ads
now cj also has a great feature in here
if you're selling
a lot of products you have a large
inventory of products you could actually
upload a product feed to cj so you can
see in this example we don't but
if you did let's just say you have a
hundred products that you want to sell
you can go ahead and upload that feed to
cj and then the publisher will be able
to use that entirety in its of the feed
or pick and choose different products to
use and sell so let's jump over to
reports in cj you have reports of this
is
really the bulk of where you want to be
spending your time because you want to
be able to
you know not only recruit those
publishers but after you recruit them
you want to be able to see the
performance how are things moving are
are publishers moving product are they
generating clicks are they selling your
products so go no further than reports
right here at the top navigation we're
going to click on performance reports
and so we want to be able to see
over a period of time you know are we
selling our product and here you can see
over the last 30 days you can see how
much commission was paid out remember cj
gets a fee they're the broker okay so
that's part of the program terms okay so
it's based on program terms who's
selling okay what program term are they
associated with cj gets their commission
okay so you can see the total commission
and then the sale amount okay so we
could see how many sales were generated
how many items were sold how many clicks
were generated how many impressions so i
can get a good sense here day by day
over who's selling who's not selling and
it's all broken down at the very end to
earnings per click so that's my
performance report so we want to be able
to see over a period of time you know
are we selling now i can go into detail
if i click on transaction here from the
pull down menu i can look at a specific
order i can choose a specific publisher
or website and i can get details about
that specific order publisher website
etc just be look by choosing transaction
so i can get really granular about the
data i see for a specific transaction
that's just by clicking reports
transaction now you can also click on
promo codes and if you're running any
promo codes for your publishers you'll
be able to see
how many conversions those promo codes
delivered and the set total sale amount
over the last 30 days so building a
network is all about recruiting the
right publishers
giving them the materials they need
measuring the performance of the
publishers and then communicating it's
just so key so cj has a nice message
center built in so you can actually you
know look at the messages you're getting
from your publishers and turn around and
communicate with them so
communicate seamlessly and efficiently
right in cj here so i just clicked on
mail and we can see the messages we have
so you can also click on email campaigns
and if you have any email campaigns that
you want to run you can look at them
right here in cj so cj offers up some
email campaigns then we can see how many
people we targeted know how many people
opened it and how many people joined in
this case joined our network so
here we have you know a breakdown of
each of the email campaigns that we've
run over a period of time and their
status and how many people were
targeting and opens deliveries etc so if
you want to run an email campaign right
in cj it's available to you as part of
the platform so if we move over from
mail to placements we have an
opportunity to place some promotional
material on a publisher's website and so
here we could see
a breakdown of different publishers who
basically will offer up some promotional
material that we can leverage okay so
here you got this particular promotional
placement it's a one month placement and
review page with your ad so we can
actually you know take advantage of what
publishers are offering up on their own
website so the whole idea here is if
it's in a prime position on their
website then we can take advantage of
that so then what we want to be able to
do is if we like what they're offering
up you can see hey
this particular publisher saying hey i
have a creative the placement is a home
page banner or full page review provide
an email with a copy of the ad that
you'd like to be displayed and we're
going to email this person here so if we
want to take advantage of a specific
promotional placement on a publisher's
website then we can do that just by
clicking on placements and we'll be able
to see who's offering up what notice
there's a fee involved so it just gives
you an opportunity to
reward a publisher that's performing
well for you and if they turn around and
offer you a better placement for a
little bit more money it might be worth
it so the whole idea is to take
advantage of placements because if your
product is in place properly then
nobody's going to see it if nobody sees
it then you know they're not going to
click on it and then you're not going to
get sales so that's the whole idea here
is take advantage of what publishers are
offering up in terms of promotional
opportunities so cj also has a
pay-per-call
click uh model as well pay model so
basically your pay per performance is
based on calls so
basically the whole point here is a cj
points out you want to promote more high
ticket and consultative products and
services you want to expand your reach
and you want to get more qualified sales
then you can offer up a pay per call and
the beauty here is cj tracks the calls
so
you will be able to see
the actual phone number and calls so
instead of offering up say you know
banner with a click you can offer up you
know promotional number and have cj
track the calls from the publisher and
that just opens up another opportunity
for you to give your publishers an
option to have people call if they call
then great you know it's another way for
somebody to get in touch and purchase
the product so the pay-per-call method
is available under cj as well so if we
want to get more insights about how our
program is performing we just click on
the insights cj's going to take us to
this overview this dashboard if you will
with some really good data based on a
time frame okay so we're comparing july
through
of july of 19 through july of 2018 we're
able to see revenue and commissions paid
out and how many clicks
average order value so there's kind of
an overview dashboard if you will about
how our overall program is performing
there are other similar tools and
resources to include
you know max bounty trade doubler amazon
associates there's plenty of networks
out there you want to find a network
where you're going to have affiliates
that are going to be passionate and
going to be relevant and have the
perspective audience that you need to
sell your product so do your due
diligence on the number of different
platforms out there so what's the
process of affiliate marketing so the
process is really setting up rules
guidelines specifications around
branding commissions etc for the
affiliates so that's really step two
step one is you gotta find that network
step two you gotta then establish the
process within that network within that
affiliate network and so
the merchant provides specifications
such as hey here's what type of creative
i want to use you know it could be a
banner it could be just a text ad it
could be a video and we want to be able
to specify the messaging in that ad we
want to specify the specific parameters
around the image what size image are we
going to use okay we want to specify the
landing page or the link we're going to
send people to and then most important
within that affiliate network the
merchant is going to set the commission
and so you can have
multiple incentives so remember you can
incentivize based on email signups or
registrations okay not just sales so you
could set the commission at say five
percent for email signups and 15 for
sales so you could specify what kind of
creative and text you want the affiliate
to use so this is really important
because if you're pushing a product like
a camera or some type of electronic
gadget you can also specify what
promotion you want that affiliate to use
you could specify the call to action
again you can specify the image
specifications the price point the
language in the ad so as the merchant
you're in total control over
what creative and text you want the
affiliate to use so john is going to
stay further john the commission that
each affiliate we receive is also
mentioned so let's look at the scenario
where an affiliate receives 15
commission for each product purchased
through a referral code so 15 commission
so the customer clicks on a referral
link from the affiliates website the
customer buys the product for let's just
say
27.97 well 15 of that is 4.20
so the affiliate will get a commission
of 4.20 so as the merchant you have to
be able to set that commission
appropriately you don't want to give 100
commission away you don't want to get 50
you want to set a commission that's
going to incentivize the affiliate so
that it's a win-win situation you're
getting a sale philly is getting the
commission the customer's happy with the
product and everybody comes away with an
ecosystem that works for all parties so
what is the process of affiliate
marketing well affiliates apply to
advertise on your behalf okay so that's
the third step here so first step choose
that network second step set up all the
guidelines third step really affiliates
are going to apply and say look merchant
i want to sell your product on my
website so john take it away john well
affiliates can contact you through the
affiliate network that's the whole point
of the network or through a page you
have set up on your website specifically
for affiliates so really there's two
ways for affiliates to reach out to you
through the network or directly through
your website either way we're trying to
get affiliates who are going to be
passionate about selling our product for
the commission we're offering so if you
look here at the bottom you may see a
link that says hey you know if you're
interested in our affiliate program
click on the affiliate program link and
from there you're going to be able to
see all the details about how to become
an affiliate so that's an example of
what you could do on your website if you
have an affiliate network so the last
step in all this is to select the
affiliates that are best suited for your
brand so when you set up that network
you set up all the guidelines you're
offering a great commission it's a
win-win scenario then you're gonna have
all these affiliates apply to sell your
product you're the one in control you're
the merchant you're representing the
brand you need to pick and choose the
affiliate that's best suited for your
brand this is probably the most
important step you want to get your
product out there on the website that is
best suited to position your product to
your prospective audience so john take
it away well you could select an
affiliate from the ones that have
applied for your affiliate program this
can be based on a number of factors one
how much traffic the affiliate website
gets you know we want to choose an
affiliate that gets a lot of traffic you
don't want to choose an affiliate that
gets very minimal traffic what's the
point you want to get your product out
there in front of people the second
criteria is how successful is his or her
previous affiliate campaigns were they
successful in selling other merchants
products do they have a good track
record were they good affiliates then
third criteria is the most important is
that affiliate okay with the commission
offered now you can always go back and
renegotiate a higher commission for
those that have been or proven to be
successful in the past at selling
products or you can renegotiate the
commission for affiliates who have
proven to sell your product so
for example if you have a hundred
affiliates selling your product and you
have 10 of those who have proven to be
really good affiliates for you then you
can go ahead and give them a raise so to
speak so instead of 15 commission you
can bump it up to 20 so you can create a
whole new commission agreement for quote
unquote best affiliates and likewise on
the flip side well you know an affiliate
is not selling your product then you
probably don't want him or her hanging
around you probably want to try and see
if you can incentivize them and if you
can't incentivize them then the
affiliate network is there to broker not
only the agreement but you know separate
the agreement as well so you could
certainly get rid of affiliates who
don't perform but you can incentivize
affiliates who do perform but really it
comes down to first do they have a good
track record you know do they get
traffic and are they okay with the
commission you're sending forth so
consumers click on the adder link which
sends the users to the merchant's
website so they're going to the
merchant's website from the affiliate
website to see it call to action will
direct you to a page where you can buy
for example in this case software so
we're buying software here and you can
see here from the software we could
choose what we want the full version
we're going to go for the full version
we're going to go through the checkout
here we're going to click on buy now
after we've entered in all of our
details so it's almost seamless from the
affiliates website to the merchant's
website or landing page all the way
through the checkout process and
remember the affiliate network is the
one tracking all this behavior so as the
person goes from the affiliates website
to the merchants to the merchant's
shopping cart the affiliate network is
tracking the entire behavior so after
the customer makes a purchase on that
merchant's website the affiliate network
records the details of his or her
transaction this is important because
the affiliate network records it they're
the ones that are going to calculate how
much commission gets paid out to the
affiliate so again if it's that 27.97
product 15 commission then the affiliate
network's gonna make sure that that
affiliate gets his or her commission of
four dollars and twenty cents okay so
the transaction is validated and
credited to the affiliate okay so this
is all recorded in the affiliate network
that you choose whether that be
commission junction cj or something else
okay the affiliate is then paid his or
her commission once they're paid it's
almost seamless nothing is stopped
nothing is halted nothing's paused that
affiliates is gonna keep on promoting
that merchant's product the more that
affiliates incentivize with commissions
i guarantee the more that
is going to want to push the merchant's
product because they know they're
getting sales by that particular
merchant's product by that merchant so
it's a win-win situation the merchant's
getting his or her product sold as a
result of these affiliates websites the
affiliate is getting commission via the
affiliate network thanks to the
merchant's product so it's a win
combination and it's a successful
combination so affiliate marketing to me
is equivalent to an ecosystem that
creates a win-win environment you the
merchants getting your product out there
hey the affiliate's getting an
opportunity to make some money so john
what do you have to say well the whole
process repeats itself it doesn't stop
so you as the merchant you got to keep
finding affiliates and on the affiliate
side hey you're going to offer up that
product to keep getting incentivized
with commissions so it's a constant
constant process that just continues to
recycle itself so that everybody
continues to win so some of the
advantages of being able to select an
affiliate that's relevant to your brand
are one you could choose an affiliate
best suited to represent your brand and
products okay that's important you want
to choose and a relevant affiliate two
you only need to pay a commission if a
conversion takes place okay that's the
great thing about it no conversion no
sale no commission now again you can
offer up other incentives like
registrations and emails so that way
you're getting something and the
affiliate's getting something in return
maybe a lower commission but they're
still getting something in return can
the affiliates audience are more likely
to be interested in your product if it's
relevant the affiliate's relevant to
your product then chances are the
audience gonna be interested in your
product on the affiliates website so the
system works on a semi automatic basis
the more commissions the affiliate gets
the more they push your product the more
sales you get you get sales affiliate
gets commissions everybody wins process
just keeps going in this session we'll
be covering some of the most important
marketing books for entrepreneurs
digital marketing is a field that will
probably never go out of style and
thanks to this there's always going to
be people searching for new innovations
and techniques to make the process
easier which means that alongside
courses tutorials and your own work
experience you will need a little more
to bring about true innovation
that's where marketing book comes in so
let's ask the most important question
probably on your mind why should i be
reading these books
the marketing books that we are going to
talk about here and the marketing books
in general are a collection of data and
experiences from goliaths within the
industry
these books provide a window to the time
period they were written in and help you
understand how marketing is still in
some ways extremely similar to how
things were back then albeit with more
technology nowadays
you will also soon see that the books
that we revere the most when it comes to
marketing are the ones that were written
in the period of the early 60s to 90s
and era where the lives we live now
would have been impossible to imagine
that's what makes these books so special
the time period and some of the methods
may have changed but the concepts and
rules covered in these books have stood
the test of time and are timeless
let's now start with number 12
contagious by jana berger
a new york times bestseller this book is
perfect for someone looking to
understand how to spread ideas increase
brand awareness
or even to grow their customer base
it goes on to explain why certain ideas
products and stories get shared and grow
in popularity
why only certain emails and videos get
forwarded and much more
contagious also goes into detail about
the six basic principles that contribute
to content becoming viral or contagious
from products initiatives youtube videos
and more
it also provides actionable and specific
techniques to spread information
designing messages and more
now let's talk about jana berger he is a
marketing professor at the wharton
school at the university of pennsylvania
he's an expert in concepts like word of
mouth how consumer behavior can be
influenced how stories ideas and
products catch on and much more
he's also been a keynote speaker in
several prominent events and consults
companies like google apple nike and
more
now let's have a look at number 11
hooked by neral
this book called a critical work in the
field of psychological marketing is one
that delves into how habit-forming
products can be built
years of analyzing startups have led nir
to understand the customers can be
influenced
this led to the creation of the hook
model
this book talks about how the hook model
which is a four step process can enable
companies to subtly encourage particular
customer behavior
it also provides practical insights into
how the hook can be used to create user
habits that will get them further hooked
onto your product the book also provides
steps to create such a product
finally the book also provides examples
as to how companies like iphone twitter
and pinterest hook their users
now
let's talk about nirail
starting off his career in the gaming
and advertising industry nir created
different techniques through which he
could motivate and manipulate users
he also helps create behaviors that can
benefit users while educating people to
build healthy habits
he is also an active angel investor in
companies like canva everbright kahoot
and more
now for number 10 we have the conversion
code by chris smith
this book recommended by digital
marketing guru neil patel is one that
focuses on helping users to increase
sales in this internet driven era
it guides users on tips to perform
online lead generation and inside sales
it also details the many ways companies
can engage with their consumers be bait
media mobile apps and blogs and how to
be effective at it
the book also focuses on leveraging the
strengths of social media apps and blogs
to capture more leads for less money
like i mentioned earlier the main focus
in this book is to convert more internet
leads into real-world prospects and
sales appointments
let's now talk about chris smith he's a
best-selling author and co-founder of a
blog called curator which is a social
media digital marketing and coaching
company
his work has been featured in a number
of major publications like adweek and
forbes he's also an in-demand keynote
speaker and is often on real estate
industry lists as one of the most
influential people within the industry
next up number nine
designing brand entity by alina wheeler
called a comprehensive pragmatic and
easy to understand resource for brand
builders by the global brand leader of
deloitte
this book mainly focuses on the
fundamentals processes and case studies
behind creating a brand
it covers more than 100 branding
subjects checklists tools and diagrams
the book also acts as a compendium for
tools that can make the branding process
a success and some of the best practices
that will get you some inspiration
the book also has 50 case studies
describing goals processes strategies
solutions and results
now
let's talk about the author alina
wheeler alina wheeler is a prominent
speaker who guides teams with everything
brand related from brand fundamentals
processes best practices and much more
she's also been coaching business
leaders and design consultancies
and has worked with more than 100
companies within the private and public
sector
now let's go to number eight gets crappy
by nick westgard
called a digital marketing bible by
publishers weekly this book helps
smaller companies with lesser resources
to develop powerhouse results
it also aims to help teams to think like
underdogs and to leverage the right
social networks and the appropriate
digital marketing tools
and to effectively reach people
it also focuses on integrating the
marketing strategy across touch points
for a unified brand experience both
online and off
now let's talk about the author nick
westgard
nick has helped brands grow from small
businesses fortune 500 companies to
president obama's jobs council
he is also a regular contributor to the
harvard business review u.s news and
world report entrepreneur
forbes
mashable and more he is also a member of
the boards of the university of iowa
school of journalism and mass
communication
the iowa city area chamber of commerce
and film scene
next we have number seven
how to win friends and influence people
in the digital age by dale carnegie
published in 1936
the book has been number eight on the
list of the top checkouts of all time by
new york public library
despite its age the many concepts are
still relevant and have been updated to
fit modern requirements
the book lays out powerful and timeless
principles of human communications that
have impacted millions
the essentials of engagement affirming
what's good connecting with core desires
and other concepts are elaborated on
the book also explains how to make a
lasting impression to merit and maintain
trust and how to lead change
now let's talk about dale carnegie
he's a writer and lecturer and the
developer of courses dealing with
self-improvement
salesmanship corporate training public
speaking interpersonal skills and much
more by the time of carnegie's death in
1955 his book had sold
5 million copies in 31 languages
and there had been 4 lakh 50 000
graduates of his dale carnegie institute
now for number six
positioning by al riese and jack trout
this book released in 2001 called one of
the most popular marketing books ever
released still keeps up with the current
marketing landscape
it details how brands can make their
product an industry leader it explains
strategies that can capture a large
market share and to build their
strategies around the competitors
weaknesses
the book also helps to analyze and
incorporate data from trends
now let's talk about algorithm and jack
trout
already is an author and marketing
professional credited with resurrecting
the idea of positioning in marketing
jack trout was a marketer who was one of
the founders and pioneers of marketing
warfare theory and positioning theory
next for number five epic content
marketing by joe polizzi
this book called one of fortune
magazine's top five business book
must reads explains how to attract
customers and lead them to your
businesses by creating relevant content
the book helps determine what your
brand's content niche is
and what you need to do to keep their
attention
the book can help discover and develop
your content marketing mission statement
and to set up a process to create and
curate content
it also explains how to leverage social
media and email channels to create and
grow your audience
now let's talk about joe polizzi he's an
author and an authority when it comes to
content marketing
he founded the content marketing
institute
and launched several events
one among them being content marketing
world
he also won the 2014 john caldwell
lifetime achievement award by the
content council
next up we have number four crushing it
by gary vaynerhook
a new york times bestseller this book
helps people build a personal brand and
how to achieve their goals
the book explains the many ways social
media platforms can be taken advantage
of by organizations to make a personal
brand for themselves
it provides tricks and tweaks to enhance
these strategies
it also provides tactical and
theoretical advice on how to become a
star on social media and podcast
services
it also details examples from real life
scenarios and how they were handled
let's talk about gary vaynerhook
he's an investor and advisor for several
startups across the world he's also an
expert on fortune 500 companies he also
runs vaynermedia a digital marketing
agency that helps companies like ge
pepsico hasbro the new york jets and
more
now for number three ogilvy on
advertising by davidor kelvey
this book written by david ogilwy who
was known as the most sought after
wizard in the industry by time magazine
was released in 1983.
this consists of concepts that remain
valid to this day
it covers a number of different facets
of advertising and covers the four
foundational principles of advertising
it also covers the author's experiences
working with many prominent brands of
the era
let's take a look at david ogilvy he was
a british advertising tycoon and the
founder of ogilway and mathur
he was called the father of advertising
he introduced the concept of branding to
advertising and focused on the
importance of the creative copy and
campaign themes
now for number two
the 22 immutable laws of marketing by
already and jack trout
this book covers 22 innovative rules
that help with understanding and
succeeding in an international
marketplace
the book provides insight into several
concepts that are still relevant today
it also details 22 superlative tools and
innovative techniques for the
international marketplace
and now for number one
scientific advertising by claude c
hopkins
this book released in 1923 has been
cited as the must-read book by several
advertising personalities like david
ogilvy gary halbert and jay abraham
it's credited with providing the
original description for split testing
and copen based customer tracking and
loyalty programs
it also details an advertising approach
that ensures reduced losses from
unsuccessful ads and gains from
profitable ads are multiplied
now
let's talk about the author claude c
hopkins
he was known as an advertising pioneer
and was known as leader in the creation
and development of modern day consumer
brand advertising and direct response
marketing
he was inducted into the advertising
hall of fame in 1957.
now let's get started with marketing
hacks
first you need to make personalized
messages
one of the most important things you
need to make sure of is that you
understand your audience
things like what they expect from your
brand what products they are interested
in what they like what they don't and so
on
then provide concise and understandable
content
this content should be of the form that
users feel like they have gained
something valuable each time they
interact with it you also need to make
sure you practice transparency and
respect your users privacy all of this
can be made possible with the help of
behavioral segmentation or dividing your
audience into groups based on actions
like cart abandonment repeat purchases
page views without conversation and so
on
here we have an example from the popular
food delivery application zomato
now for number two using data to drive
creatives
the combination of the write add images
and their corresponding copies are now
just as important as ad placement and
audience targeting
to do it right you need to use a data
driven approach to the process of
creative design you need to analyze the
metrics of the creatives you're using
currently identify what's going wrong
and make corrections or create new
designs to address the issues and
improve non-performing metrics in fact
in organizations like google and
facebook algorithms are being used to
determine what combination of ad copies
and creatives can bring the best
conversion rates and click-through rates
none of which would be possible without
a data-driven approach
next for number 3 we have to focus on
original research
you need to perform your own research on
latest technologies and trends with data
represented in a creative manner like
with the help of graphics
some of the biggest advantages of having
your own proprietary data enables you to
provide data in a unique angle and makes
it easy to share
moreover with this data being easily
shareable this improves the number of
bank links generated from high authority
websites it would also make you loads of
subscribers
let's now have a look at number four
you need to update your content the
content you have already published will
over a period of time see a decreasing
amount of traffic coming to it which is
why it needs to be updated regularly
with simple tweaks and updates to ensure
it doesn't decay and is refreshed in
google rankings
doing this is also significantly cheaper
than creating a piece of content from
scratch
updates also help increase organic
traffic and to introduce new customers
to your website or content
at number five we have perform guest
blogging
perform guest blogging by having people
with blogs or an audience within your
industry create content for you
first off you can take advantage of
their expertise and drive traffic to
your website moreover having them to do
this introduces their audience to your
brand this brings you new users you can
eventually turn into leads and then into
customers here's an example of a guest
blogger for the d-zone website
done properly this can ensure traffic
can be driven to your website
next up at number six you need to use
video
videos are now seen to be one of the
most successful forms of advertising so
why not capitalize on it videos like
tutorials testimonials and behind the
scenes footage can improve your
relationship with your audience and
increase the probability of them
investing in your product or services
they also help humanize your brand
adding doses of genuineness to
interactions with your audience on that
note might i suggest you check out our
video on digital marketing if you're
interested in learning about it i'll add
a link in the live chat
next up at number 7 you need to perform
live streams
live streams offer you a free form of
content that doesn't take too long to
create and give significant amounts of
authentic interactions with your
audience
moreover live streams give you a greater
number of impressions than the
traditional types of content that you
can post
next up for number 8 making explainer
videos
videos that make complex concepts easier
to understand can be of great help to
your brand or website
for starters your content gets a boost
from google thanks to its preference for
video content
this content also improves seo and
marketing opportunities for your website
you can take this one step further and
even create your own video series that
you can put up on youtube or other
learning platforms
now for number nine hosting or joining
podcasts
podcasts give you a platform to interact
with an audience that can return each
week
you could join an existing podcast
series or start your own each of these
methods help improve traffic to your
website and increase brand awareness
involving yourself in established
podcasts within the industry will draw
audience interest to your brand or
product
if the podcaster has a large audience
his or her trust in your brand will
become the audience's trust in your
brand thus bringing you a brand new
audience that can enjoy your content
next up number 10 focusing on local seo
prioritizing the google my business tool
will enable you to manage your brand's
online presence alongside maps and
search results
by focusing on local seo you are making
sure your brand is in front and center
when users search for related terms and
searches it also helps increase your
exposure to local audiences and can
increase the number of leads you can
gain
now for number 11 setting up automated
email campaigns
automating email campaigns can reduce
the amount of time you spent on the task
of manually sending email and increases
the number of emails that you can send
this helps you increase the conversion
rates it can also provide you with more
customization options stuff like a b
testing infographics time zones call to
action buttons and much more
next up number 12 we have test augmented
reality
augmented reality provides additional
personalization that enables greater
interactivity from the users
this by extension increases their
interest in your brand making them more
likely to convert
augmented reality can also give users
the opportunity to preview your product
or services giving them an opportunity
to try it before they can actually
purchase it
here we have an example of an ar
application through which users could be
a part of the launch of the smartphone
oneplus nord
for number 13 you have to use smart
bidding
with smart bidding google uses machine
learning to analyze your data so that it
can optimize your bits in real time with
this you enable google to learn from
past data to optimize your ad spend you
choose an appropriate bid strategy see
how it works out and keep optimizing
finding the right combination can help
you acquire leads and convert them into
customers
next up for number 14 you need to take
advantage of your user-generated content
with user-generated contents you get
constant updates from your customers and
this tells google that your content is
updated constantly thus helping with
improving your rankings comments and
reviews from users can also improve the
uniqueness of your content
and finally at number 15 we have
gamification
gamifying your content with loyalty
programs and competitions can greatly
improve your audience's engagement with
your brand gamification also encourages
your audience to perform a particular
action like liking sharing or commenting
on content
here's an example of a rewards program
that gives users credits called
star-speaking news as currency at a
number of different locations the more
products you buy from starbucks the more
stars you will learn
now on to number 10 mobile marketing
before we get on to talking about mobile
marketing let's have a look at some
stats related to mobile marketing
first off mobile devices are used for
over 40 percent of online transactions
next we have marketers and advertisers
put 51 percent of their budget into
mobile ads
and finally mobile is responsible for an
average of more than 40 percent of
revenue in leading b2b organizations so
what is mobile marketing
mobile marketing is a digital marketing
strategy that started all the way in
1992. remember sms's that advertise
stuff that's what mobile marketing
started off as the main objective with
mobile marketing is to advertise
products and services to a target
audience to multiple channels on
smartphones tablets and other mobile
devices
this is done through websites emails sms
social media in-app notifications and
other applications
so here are key concepts related to
mobile marketing first we have focusing
on the customer and personalized
marketing
in mobile marketing the primary focus is
on the customer want them to increase
brand loyalty give customers special
offers or show them personalized ads
based on their location and purchase
history
basically by focusing on the customer it
gives them the feeling that the brand is
directly interacting with them and as a
result their loyalty towards the brand
greatly increases
next we have identifying trends with
data by leveraging data different trends
can be identified from there you can
create customer profiles and then with
predictive and behavior analysis you get
an understanding of what will better
grab the attention of a customer
then we have testing
testing provides insights and learnings
that would be extremely important to the
success of the campaign for example say
you do an a b test with that you'll get
the optimal variant of the two as well
as further understanding of what works
and what doesn't
and finally understanding mobile
analytics having some experience with
mobile analytics with some of the
metrics that need to be focused on like
engagement ratio cost per install and
average revenue per user are very
important for mobile marketing
experience with mobile analytics tools
can also help with insights that would
help future decisions and experiments
so if you're interested in getting
certified in mobile marketing you have
options like mobile app marketing 2020
aso advertising and monetization by
udemy and you also have digital
marketing specialist certification by
simply learn
now let's go to number nine crm or
customer relationship management
here are some interesting stats
it is stated that towards the end of
2019 86 percent of customers are willing
to pay 25 percent more for better
customer experience
also crm marketing will be worth 73
billion dollars in 2020
finally businesses that leverage crm
software see sales increased by 29
sales productivity increased by 34
percent and sales forecast accuracy
increased by 42 percent
now that we have looked into these stats
let's understand what crm is all about
crm is a technology with which an
organization's relationships and
interactions with existing or potential
customers are managed
it's basically a collection of
strategies tools and technologies and
crms aim to develop new customer
relationships retain them or require new
ones
along with that it also helps companies
with sales marketing and service
management
crms mainly store data like purchase
history personal information and
purchasing patterns
so here are a few areas to focus in crm
first we have data analytics crms
provide a number of different metrics
that can be analyzed and whose results
can be incorporated into forthcoming
campaigns
now although what metric you focus on
entirely depends on your requirements
here are some of the commonly used
metrics
there's customer churn which is
basically customer attrition there's nps
which is a measure of how satisfied your
customers are
best customer retention cost and first
contact resolution rate which is the
percentage of customer support tickets
that get resolved at the first shot
next understanding how different crm
tools work
there are loads of options to choose
from when it comes to crms there's
salesforce hubspot crm zoho crm
microsoft dynamics and much more
it is really important to have
experienced at least the most commonly
used ones since each of them have their
own nuances advantages and disadvantages
now let's have a look at some of the
certifications
we have options like salesforce
administrator certification training
course by simplylearn dynamics 365 by
microsoft and finally hubspot academy
sales professional credential by hubspot
so now let's go to number eight
at number eight we have designing
like usual let's have a look at some of
the stats
did you know that 32 percent of
marketers saying visual images are the
most important form of content for their
business with blogging in second
well 70 of companies invest in content
marketing which could include visual
marketing strategies
so now let's take a closer look at
designing
with designing the objective is to
communicate as well as promote the
products or services the brand is
advertising in a visually appealing
manner
designing goes hand in hand with a great
copy though
even if you had the best looking
creative in your ad it's possible it
won't catch on if the copy accompanying
it isn't good
you might wonder what does designing
have to do with digital marketing plenty
actually if you have an understanding of
designing yourself in the scenario where
graphic designers are unable to bring
your idea to life you could do it
yourself desiring for yourself what the
content will convey
not only that you might be able to
provide some insight in the designing of
the creative for the ad
next let's have a look at key concepts
of designing
firstly a basic understanding of design
philosophies are necessary which means
you need to know about concepts like
using attention grabbing and relevant
images the golden point rule and much
more
then there needs to be an understanding
of tools like adobe photoshop and after
effects
these are some of the most commonly used
tools for creating creatives and even
the basic experience with these software
could be extremely useful later on
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have certifications like graphic
design by coursera introduction to
graphic design by linkedin and
fundamentals of graphic design again by
coursera
next at number seven we have listening
now let's talk about social listening
social listening is a method to which a
brand can learn about what customers are
saying about them and the industry
online by monitoring digital
conversations
the brand's social media channels can
track analyze and respond to
conversations and feedback improving
their relationship with the users who
may become potential customers and thus
increasing loyalty of present customers
and it's a proven fact that customers
are drawn towards brands that are prompt
in response
now let's have a look at some key
concepts understanding how different
social media platforms work how is each
platform different from the other
where does most of your audience come
from which platform is better suited for
your content those are the questions
that need to be answered
then experience with popular social
listening tools like hubspot and
hootsuite these platforms can help with
a number of different situations like pr
crisis respond to customer complaints
find user generated content to obtain
competitive intelligence take
suggestions and much more
next at number six we have copywriting
first let's have a look at some stats
it is stated that 64 percent of b2b
marketers outsource their demanding copy
needs
next it also says that a compelling copy
draws 7.8 times more site traffic and
produces brand recall which brings
higher engagement rates
now let's talk about what is copywriting
copywriting is an act of creating
promotional texts that could be
advertised in brochures notifications
billboards emails and so on
the primary objective here is that the
written content called copy or sales
copy increases brand awareness and
persuades individuals to take a
particular action be it signing up to a
website buy a product and so on
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of copywriting
first understanding the customers and
the competition so from the customers
several bits of vital information can be
obtained like what kind of writing gets
the maximum amount of engagement what
kind they dislike and much more
likewise from the competition you can
find out what kind of writing they have
success with what they are doing better
from your brand and so on
this one goes without saying but to have
success with copywriting you need to be
well versed with grammar and have
sufficiently good writing skills
let's have a look at some certifications
now
here we have the creative copywriter
academy then we have the idm award in
digital copywriting by the institute of
data and marketing
and finally we have american writers and
artists copywriting course
next up number five email marketing
first let's have a look at some stats
according to statista in 2019 global
email users amounted to 3.9 million by
2023 this is said to grow to 4.3 billion
next it also states that 81
smbs rely on email as their primary
customer acquisition channel and 80 for
retention
next again by statista it states that 49
percent of consumers would like to
receive promotional emails from their
favorite brands
so now let's have a look at email
marketing
email marketing is a method for
performing digital marketing by using
emails to promote products and services
to a highly targeted audience
in a way email marketing could nurture
the relationship with your customers or
completely drive them away
with email marketing customers can be
communicated with directly with
personalized emails helping them stay
updated with items or offers
it also serves a purpose of informing
people about your brand or keeping
existing customers engaged between
purchases
now let's have a look at key concepts
first we have focusing on
personalization and automation
emails can be set up in such a way that
customers are regularly sent emails on a
regular basis to keep in touch with them
inform them about new products and other
forms of engagement
then we have complying with data privacy
rules
privacy has been the talking point for a
while now most recently the gdpr brought
about a number of restrictions that have
to be adhered to by organizations
so it's absolutely necessary that these
privacy guidelines are followed or would
you rather spend 10 million pounds
next experimenting with different kinds
of content
emails can have images gifs or videos
attached to them
and each of them can impact your
customer base in a different manner
depending on their requirements
so different kinds of content need to be
experimented with to determine the one
that works best for you
and finally understanding popular tools
and metrics to be successful at email
marketing it is absolutely necessary to
be experienced with tools like hubspot
and mailchimp
these platforms come with a number of
features like contact segmenting
autoresponders service and app
integration a b testing and much more
next up we have certifications
here we have certifications like hubspot
academy email marketing by hubspot then
email and affiliate marketing mastermind
by utemi and finally advanced email
marketing certification training by
simplylearn
so now that we have reached midway i
have a question for you guys what do you
guys think is in the number one section
let me know in the live chat i'd like to
know what you guys think
if you enjoy watching informative tech
videos like this one consider
subscribing to simply learn's channel to
stay up to date on the trending
technologies and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update in the future
now back to number four social media
marketing
before we go in let's have a look at
some stats
according to statista nearly 50 percent
of the world's population uses social
media
73 percent of marketers believe social
media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business
lastly 90.4 percent of millennials 77.5
percent of generation x and 48.2 of baby
boomers are active social media users
so now let's have a look at social media
marketing
social media marketing involves the
usage of social media platforms to build
a brand drive traffic to your website
and increase sales
this helps marketers achieve their
marketing and branding goals by creating
and sharing content on social media
activities like text and image updates
video and other content that can drive
engagement social media marketing also
enables marketers to perform paid
advertising with this your brand's
content like articles videos and images
are exposed to a high quality targeted
audience
next let's have a look at some key
concepts of social media marketing
first understanding how to work with
different social media platforms is
necessary
every social media platform comes with
its own kind of audience nuances
advantages and disadvantages so it's
important to have experience with them
so that the one that best suits your
requirements can be selected
next we have
monetization on youtube which is also a
social media platform you could monetize
your videos to get some income out of
them other options include affiliate
marketing influencer marketing events
and much more
then we have analytics experience with
social media marketing tools like buffer
and buzzsumo can help organizations by
providing alerts based on keywords brand
names links domain and much more
among other things it also tracks
competitors and analyzes their content
to determine what they are doing better
then we have knowing your brand's user
base and optimizing your content it's
important to understand your brand's
user base to determine what they like
the most on your social media page and
then optimize it
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have advanced social media
certification training by simply learn
then we have social media marketing on
linkedin learning and finally hootsuite
social marketing certification by
hootsuite
and now for the top three number three
pay-per-click or ppc first let's have a
look at some stats
33 percent of people click on paid
search ad because it directly answers
their search query
it also states that paid ads have a
11.38
ctr on google
and finally according to google
businesses make an average of two
dollars in income for every one dollar
they spend in google ads
now let's talk about ppc
it is a form of online advertising in
which advertisers spend a certain amount
of money each time their advertisement
is clicked this process if done properly
can drive people to your website without
having to get them organically
search engine marketing is one of the
most popular methods to perform ppc
for ppc most search engines are part of
an automated process performed by the
search engine to determine how relevant
and valid they are to appear in the
search engine result page
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of ppc
first it's important how different
search engines and their advertising
works
each of them have their own but somewhat
similar rules prices restrictions and so
on
then we have google ads one of the most
popular and lucrative players among the
search engines google ads provides
marketers with a sizable chunk of the
internet to advertise to
it is important to properly understand
how google ads works and how its many
features and functionalities can be used
efficiently
for more on google ads why don't you
check out introductory video on it i'll
link it in the chat
next analytics different metrics like
cpc or cost per click clicks
click-through rate and quality score
need to be understood so that optimal
and well-informed decisions can be made
finally we have copywriting and visual
design ability as i mentioned earlier
either of these don't work without the
other which means the experience in both
these concepts would be greatly
beneficial for the individual and the
organization
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have google ads certifications by
google then advanced pay-per-click ppc
certification training by simply learn
and finally we have microsoft and
excellence program by microsoft
now for the top two search engine
optimization
let's first look at some stats
according to zero limit web on the first
page alone the first five organic
results account for 67.60
of all the clicks
and according to google where to buy
plus near me mobile queries have grown
by over 200 percent in the past two
years
and finally according to hubspot 57 of
b2b marketers stated that seo generates
more leads than any other marketing
initiative
so what exactly is search engine
optimization
search engine optimization or seo refers
to the method adopted by an organization
to grow the quality and quantity of
website traffic by making it more
visible to the users of a particular web
search engine
this is possible with the help of
organic search results seo improves
unpaid results and doesn't count traffic
obtained from paid ads
next let's have a look at some key
concept of seo
technical seo the technical side of seo
like server side settings site maps
server response code rewrites and so on
will help you take advantage of both
page level and server level optimization
to ensure they are found by search
engines this by extension helps generate
traffic and conversions
next content marketing it is important
to be well versed in content marketing
as both seo and content marketing cannot
exist without the other
content marketing provides high quality
content and seo provides the appropriate
keywords that would help it get noticed
by search engines
next link building
the process of search engine
optimization can only be successful if
there's a combination of both external
link building and internal link
optimization
one builds links with credible websites
and the other performs link optimization
on your own properties and social media
platforms
now we have site usability seo must
focus on good site usability this is an
indication of how objects are placed in
your website and if the information
provided is useful for the users
it also indicates if the site is easy to
use and navigate
then you need to have experience with
tools like moz and google analytics to
take appropriate inferences from the
data obtained
and finally we have google analytics and
google webmaster
google analytics will help with tracking
and reporting website traffic google
webmaster will help track your website
search performance with the help of
google search console and additional
resources
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have seo training course by mers
which is provided by udemy and we have
search engine optimization training
course by simply learn and finally we
have hubspot seo training course
provided by hubspot
finally number one it's data analytics
data analysis is a process which looks
into collecting and organizing data by
doing so helpful conclusions are drawn
these conclusions can be incorporated
into the upcoming campaigns of the
organization
the information that is analyzed is
collected with the help of analytical
and logical reasoning
here are some key concepts of data
analysis first understanding popular
data analytics tools like apache spark
tableau and sas can be greatly helpful
in the process of data analysis
then we have google analytics google
analytics is a tool that helps
businesses analyze their website it
records activities of users visiting
your website along with additional
information like their age gender and
interests
this is then sent to the google
analytics server and then can be used by
you to make decisions regarding upcoming
campaigns
then we have data visualization
data visualization enables data to be
translated into a chart graph or other
visual component
understanding data visualization would
help with understanding data in a quick
and clean manner it enables brands to
identify emergent trends and to respond
to it quickly
with it the brand story can also be
shared with others thanks to being able
to create a narrative with graphics and
diagrams
and finally a clear understanding of
data structures fundamentals and basic
statistics can greatly ease the process
of data analysis
now let's have a look at some
certifications here we have introduction
to data analytics for business by
coursera then we have data analyst
masters program by simply learn and
finally we have micromasters program and
marketing analytics by edx
hey guys welcome to this video on
digital marketing career jobs resume
salary skills roles and responsibilities
so without further ado let's jump right
into it
the 21st century has given us many
things to be thankful for from
technology to health care our lives have
greatly improved for the better and many
of these things wouldn't have been
possible without the internet
not counting about the several ways it
has improved our lives the internet has
also made the life of marketers a whole
lot easier
earlier unless you had lots of money or
were very popular your brand's
popularity would be limited to your
locality
but thanks to the internet you can
advertise your content to anyone
anywhere in the world the whole world is
now your marketplace
and that is because of digital marketing
which is the process of advertising
goods services and your brand with the
help of digital channels like websites
social media platforms search engines
and so on
digital marketing has the following
types
search engine optimization
content marketing social media marketing
search engine marketing
affiliate marketing
native advertising
marketing automation
and email marketing
but you might be wondering who can
ensure these digital marketing concepts
are incorporated into a brand's
marketing campaigns to ensure the best
possible output
a digital marketer of course so now
let's talk about everything related to a
digital marketer
but before we can get started let's go
to a more familiar setting on where a
digital marketer belongs and strives
the office now let's start by talking
about
who is a digital marketer
a digital marketer is someone whose
objective is use digital channels like
search engines social media platforms
affiliates and other opportunities to
generate leads and build brand awareness
everything the digital marketer is aimed
at helping the brand grow
but that's not where his or her
responsibilities end a digital marketer
is also responsible for developing and
managing marketing campaigns this means
that the success of the entire marketing
efforts of a brand or an organization
entirely depends on how competently a
digital marketer develops the marketing
campaign
the work doesn't end there though the
digital marketer also needs to manage
the campaigns
next like we mentioned earlier he or she
needs to acquire leads and drive traffic
to the brand's website taking advantage
of the digital channels we mentioned
earlier alongside providing high quality
content
the digital marketer also needs to
perform competitive analysis and
industry benchmarking to understand what
kind of content works best within your
industry the kind of content that your
competition posts and what works for
them
they're also responsible for using tools
like buffer
hootsuite and sprout social to measure
and optimize marketing campaigns based
on data obtained from the tools
and finally they're responsible for
improving brand awareness by advertising
the organizations or brands content on
digital marketing channels
let's now talk about the skills required
to become a digital marketer
now let's have a look at the different
types of digital marketing
there's search engine optimization
content marketing social media marketing
search engine optimization affiliate
marketing and email marketing
let's talk about search engine
optimization first
search engine optimization is the
process of improving the overall quality
and quantity of the organic traffic
coming to your website via search
engines
with seo you're able to attract visitors
who would be actually interested in the
products or services that your brand is
offering without having to pay a single
penny
the process of seo has two parts
on page and off page seo let's have a
look at each of them in detail first
let's have a look at on-page seo
on-page or on-site seo is a method of
search engine optimization that involves
the optimization of elements on a
website like its content or html code to
help increase the amount of traffic
coming to your website and improve its
search engine rankings
it also helps users easily understand
what a page is all about and whether or
not your page addresses their search
query
on-page seo is possible with the help of
keyword research technical audits
on-site optimizations and enhanced user
experiences
next we have off-page seo off-page or
off-site seo refers to actions taken
outside your website to affect your
rankings in search engine result pages
it involves promotional methods to
improve search engine and user
perception of your site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and authority
off-page seo can also be performed with
the help of link building which is
getting other websites to link back to
your website
some of the popular seo tools are moz
google keyword planner
and ahrefs
next up we have content marketing
content marketing refers to the process
of marketing that focuses on creating
and sharing valuable relevant and
consistent content like blogs videos
infographics and case studies to bring
the attention of a targeted online
audience to the brand's products and
services
the process of content marketing
involves firstly to decide what goal you
want to achieve with your marketing
campaign do you want more subscribers
more conversions
increased leads
that's what you need to decide here then
you need to set up buyer personas
a buyer persona is a profile created
based on research that represents the
target customer that might enjoy your
products or services
with this you can identify the ideal
audience that might be interested in
your content
next you'll need to perform a content
audit it involves taking a look at all
the content on your website and
assessing its relative strengths and
weaknesses in order to prioritize your
future marketing activities
then you need to choose a content
management system of your choosing
there are a number of options available
like wordpress mailchimp and squarespace
you will need to keep brainstorming for
new forms of content that will attract
the attention of new audience
you will need to focus on a particular
form of content you want to focus on and
finally you'll need to publish and
manage your content
now let's talk about popular content
marketing tools
there's buffer basumo follower wonk and
hootsuite let's now talk about
the next type of digital marketing that
is social media marketing
social media marketing refers to a form
of marketing that involves the usage of
social media platforms to connect with
your audience to build your brand to
increase sales and to drive traffic
you'll need to listen to an engage with
followers analyze results and run social
media advertisements the process of
social media marketing involves like
before you first need to determine what
goal you want to achieve
you need to determine whether you need
increased conversions
email signups lead generation or any
other marketing goal
at this stage you need to determine what
your audience enjoys the most
you need to find out which files get the
most amount of engagement likes or
shares
then you'll need to research about your
competition within your niche
see what kinds of content they post what
content of theirs receives the most
engagement from their audience and how
you can make similar content
you will then need to perform a social
media audit through which you can
analyze content on your social media
profile and understand their strengths
and weaknesses to determine what kinds
of content you can post
then you will need to create an account
on a social media platform of your
choice
like linkedin facebook instagram twitter
or youtube and start creating marketing
strategies on how to make the most out
of them
you should also take into consideration
other brands that have already
established themselves in social media
for inspiration
you can analyze what kind of content
they post and how you can replicate the
same
you will then need to create a social
media calendar these are spreadsheets or
applications that will enable you to
plan your social media posts in advance
you can plan when content will be shared
manage them and track the deadlines
and finally you will need to keep
testing evaluating and making
adjustments to your marketing campaigns
to finally reach the sweet spot where
you have a perfect social media
marketing campaign
here are some of the popular social
media marketing tools there is hootsuite
tweetdeck sprout social and buffer just
to name a few
next up let's have a look at search
engine marketing
search engine marketing or sem is a
marketing process that involves websites
increasing the amount of traffic as well
as their visibility on search engine
result pages by taking advantage of paid
advertising
let's now take a look at the process of
search engine marketing
first off as usual is to determine what
goal you want to achieve with your sem
campaign
more leads
conversions
subscriptions
you decide
then you will need to research what
kinds of keywords you want to advertise
on
this is a really important decision that
carries a lot of monetary weight as
choosing the wrong keywords may have
your brand competing against large ones
in a bidding battle you have no chance
of winning you will then need to decide
on what keywords you want to advertise
and then start bidding on them to ensure
that the user sees your ad when they
search for that particular keyword
you will need to set up a headline for
your ad campaigns as a well-written
headline for your ad can make the
difference between a potential customer
coming to your website and buying your
products and then being completely
turned off by your brand
you will need to monitor your campaigns
and measure how well you're doing so
that you can make the appropriate
adjustments
and finally you will need to make sure
you make regular optimizations and
adjustments based on the data you've
collected and retarget potential
customers to renew their interest in
your brand
some popular search engine marketing
tools are google ads
facebook ads manager
ad role and binge ads just to name a few
next up let's take a look at affiliate
marketing
affiliate marketing is the process of
paying an affiliate who could be a
particular website or other entity to
advertise a merchant's products
the affiliate usually promotes the
product and earns a commission for each
sale they make
this is usually done using referrals via
registrations
email sign ups conversions and
subscriptions
here's the process of affiliate
marketing first you will need to decide
the affiliate network you want to choose
the affiliate network is like a favor
for both merchants and affiliates
here a merchant gets to decide which
affiliate they want to work with and
vice versa
as a merchant you will need to set up
specific rules
guidelines
image specifications
commission costs and other details that
an affiliate needs to accept before they
can apply to advertise for you
after this affiliates apply to advertise
on the merchant's behalf
the merchants decide which affiliate
they want to go with and would be the
best representation of their brand
now once an affiliate has been selected
he or she places ads on their website or
the platform of their choosing
advertising the merchant's products
interested customers then click on these
ads and are sent to the merchant's
website
if customers make a purchase the
affiliate network makes a note of it the
transaction is then validated and
credited to the affiliate
and finally the affiliate is given his
or her commission and likewise the
process repeats itself
here are some of the popular affiliate
marketing tools
we have cj affiliate
volume
even and has offers just name a few
again
now we are having a look at the last
type of digital marketing and that is
email marketing email marketing is the
process of using personalized emails to
convert prospective users into potential
customers here's the process of email
marketing first you decide on what goal
you want to achieve with your email
marketing campaign
then you decide what kind of emails you
want to send is it a welcome email a
newsletter a lead nurturing email a
re-engagement email that's what you've
got to decide here
next you can choose an email marketing
tool of your choosing
these tools can help you with templates
for emails create email lists track
performance and do much more
you will then need to attract users with
a reason to subscribe to your emails
with attractive opt-in advantages like
exclusive access to sales discounts and
so on
you will need to plan emails and their
respective follow-ups with an email
calendar
you will also need to create an
attractive subject line and copy that'll
attract the attention of potential
customers
but the job isn't done after creating an
attractive subject line in copy your
email also has to have an attractive
design
and finally you will need to perform a
or b tests and use analytics to measure
how well your campaign is doing
based on this you can make the
appropriate adjustments to make sure the
upcoming campaigns are a success
some popular email marketing tools are
mailchimp hubspot sendinblue and marketo
just to name a few
now let's take a look at some digital
marketer carriers
here are some of the most popular job
roles you can have we'll be talking
about the salaries of these job roles
courtesy of glassdoor
first we have digital marketing manager
a digital marketing manager earns
approximately 75 000
per annum in the us
in india he or she can earn
approximately 7 lakh rupees per annum
next we have seo manager in the united
states an seo manager earns
approximately 62 000
per annum
whereas in india an seo manager earns
approximately 5 lakhs per annum
then we have search engine marketing or
ppc expert a ppc expert in the us earns
approximately seventy four thousand
dollars per annum
whereas in india a ppc expert can earn
approximately four lakh rupees per annum
next up we have the social media manager
in the us a social media manager earns
approximately fifty thousand dollars per
annum in india he or she can earn
approximately five lakhs per annum and
finally we have the content marketing
manager a content marketing manager can
earn approximately 65 000
in the united states
in india he or she can earn
approximately 5 lakh rupees per annum
let's have a look at a sample digital
marketer resuming
first off you start off with the usuals
like name address and the other stuff
following this you will need to add a
brief summary of your years of
experience and the different important
skills you have experience with
in this case this person has two years
of experience in just about every
important type of digital marketing your
summary can vary based on the job role
you're looking for
you give them links to your socials and
then add experience
this is the part where you can highlight
your achievements during your years of
work
here you can see how this person has
brought growth in just about every
channel he's gotten into the most
important part to remember here is that
the stuff you add here must be
quantitative with actual stats about how
your work brought growth to your
organization
again depending on the job role you're
applying for you can choose to elaborate
on some of your achievements over others
then you can cover the different tools
you've got experience with make sure you
add relevant tools related to this job
role you're looking for
for example for the role of a sem expert
having experience with google ads and
google analytics is mandatory so that
has to be a part of this list
you can add concise details about your
education and then talk about the
courses you've completed
having completed the right courses can
have a significant impact on your higher
ability
so how can simply learn help you
here's how
here are some of the advantages of
taking simply learns course
simply learns job assist access to more
than 45 projects access to tools worth
more than 500 dollars get oncp certified
master concepts of seo email marketing
mobile marketing ppc web analytics
social media marketing and so much more
thank you for joining and today we're
going to cover digital marketing
interview questions and answers so
thanks for joining again and here's how
it's going to work so we broke out a few
questions and answers uh in different
categories a lot of you are going to be
interviewing for some jobs out there and
some of the jobs maybe an seo manager or
search engine marketing manager or email
marketing manager or content marketing
manager or social media manager so
we broke up those questions into those
areas and so that's what we're going to
do we're going to start with seo we're
going to go through some questions and
i'm going to explain the answers to
those questions so if you have any
questions to these questions or answers
feel free to just comment right below
this video and we'll get back to as soon
as possible so let's get started we're
going to start with seo search engine
optimization we're going to go through a
series of questions and i'm going to
answer those questions for you okay so
the first question that you might be
asking an interview is differentiate
between do follows and no follows okay
so if you take in or listen to my seo
courses on youtube for seo we we talked
a lot about do follows and nofollows and
and simply put i mean do follows are
just signals to the search engines to
follow the link so there's a link on
site a pointing to site b
we're gonna basically tell google bing
and some of these other search engines
hey go ahead and follow that link now i
know files just the opposite so no
follow link doesn't allow the search
engine crawlers to follow it so if we
have a link on our site
site a pointing to
site b
we can put a nofollow tag in there and
what that's going to do it's going to
signal to the crawlers hey don't follow
this link so
in the end if the crawlers don't follow
the link then there's not going to be
any link juice passed and so google is
not going to give you credit or give
that site credit for having a link
pointing to it or pointing to another
site or from another site and so it's
all about linking so we can control if
there's links on our site whether we
want the crawlers to recognize those or
not simply with no follow tags so just a
reminder linked jews is the reputation
of equity passed from one website to
another so if you have a link on another
website and that website is of high
quality meaning their page authority
their domain authority is high they have
a lot of content you know they're not
spammy they're really rich and they're
relevant then you may want to make sure
that the link pointing from that site to
your site is a nofollow so that way that
google can recognize the link from that
site to your site and basically that
reputation is going to be passed on to
you okay so that's a do follow versus a
nofollow and why would we do a nofollow
well it depends it really depends a lot
of social media platforms like facebook
have no follows if you have a lot of
content you may not want to be pushing
out a lot of do follows it could
actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link juice onto and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an seo perspective if i have a site
and i have a lot of external links
pointing outward to other sites i'm
going to be particular about who i allow
the search engines to follow and what
links i allow not to follow so here's an
example of what they look like so do
follow is simply just the href notice
the nofollow has the the tag appended to
it the href tag with a nofollow so if
the search engine's crawling your site
and they see that nofollow there they're
not going to follow that link and vice
versa if there's a link on another site
pointing to yours and there's a no
follow there you're not going to get
credit the search engines aren't gonna
pick up that link okay so question two
what is 301 redirect and how is it
different from a 302 redirect so
301 redirects tell users and the search
engine specifically that an original
page has been moved and this is the
keyword here permanently so permanently
moved we're going to explain that in a
minute so it's just moved from one page
to another and so
if we
don't have a page anymore we have a new
page let's just say you built a new
website with new urls you want to make
sure the old page is pointing to the new
page with a 301 redirect so if a 301
redirect is permanent then a 302 is
temporary so we want the search engines
to
recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
google to
not keep that page in its search engine
rankings because it's temporary so why
would google want to keep a temporary
page or even a page that is pointing to
another page on a temporary basis so
they may remove both pages from its
index okay but if we have something
permanent in place google may say okay
this page is permanently linking to
another page or redirecting to another
page therefore it's stable it's
permanent we're going to keep that new
page in the index and eventually remove
the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in google search index
and we get it sometimes pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in seo
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the nofollow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from quite quality sites
it's going to improve the credibility of
our site especially if it's a do follow
tag so the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get more of a lion's share of
the traffic for certain keywords that
our pages are found for and if our pages
are found and getting traffic then
because we have increased rankings we're
likely going to have increased traffic
and then it's just a snowball effect so
more traffic leads to more engagement
and conversions so the whole idea for
seo is remember you have an on-page
strategy and an off-page strategy
building external links is part of an
off-page seo strategy and we want to
make sure that you know we are
relevant in the form of a link or in the
form of content on other high quality
sites being on a high quality site
only benefits us because again increases
our domain authority google sees this as
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on youtube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with seo because videos are
found youtube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on youtube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so
make sure you go ahead and follow the
best practices of having engaging in
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing the video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty i.e low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of the title they're going to want
to probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on twitter facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant that's going
to grab somebody's attention
and then again we set it similar to the
video tags we want to use relevant
hashtags again just as you would with
twitter and facebook go ahead and throw
some hashtags in there that people could
see because people search via hashtag
and then
this goes about saying you did all the
work created a really great video it's
engaging it's informative you optimized
it feel free to promote your video on
other social media platforms okay don't
just stick with youtube per se
so the benefit here is if you post it on
facebook or linkedin or whatever
platform of your choice and it gets
engagement people click on the link go
to youtube they're gonna like it and
then other people are gonna see that
engagement they're gonna see how many
people liked it or how many subscribers
you have so
promote your videos to help you with the
ranking of the video on youtube so that
does play into it so go ahead and
promote it so other people can watch it
like it comment etc and that's going to
engage other people to want to do the
same so what is mobile first indexing
this is a really important and timely
question mobile first indexing means
google's just using
mobile friendly content for indexing and
ranking websites so in other words
google for example has two bots they
have the traditional desktop bot and
they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody that has a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone bot and so with that
smartphone bot goes to your website and
starts crawling what do you think
they're looking for their smartphone bot
they're looking for mobile friendly
content if it's not mobile friendly
meaning the page isn't designed for a
smartphone browser or let's just say the
images are way too large or you have to
expand the text just to read it you know
a lot of these these issues that
somebody would have just simply trying
to read something on a web page on their
mobile device google's not going to grab
that content so you want to make sure
it's mobile friendly so it gets indexed
and so if your website has a responsive
design google will rank your website
based on its performance on mobile
devices okay so you want to make sure
that your website is mobile friendly and
if you're in an interview and somebody
asked this question you could even take
it a step further and say look i'm going
to measure how friendly my my website is
for mobile devices in google search
console because google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but i
can tell you if i'm google and i'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bob and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly i'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asks you this question because how
are you going to know if one of your
pages is mobile friendly or not if you
don't look at a report so keep an eye on
google search consoles
mobile usability report okay number six
list down the most important local seo
ranking factors okay so
organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or
you're looking for a coffee shop so what
you want to do is you want to create a
web page for every product and service
okay you also want to opt for your
business listings on google my business
and and there are plenty of other local
business directories out there like yelp
for example or bing even has one so go
ahead and also make sure you have a
business listing as well but since
google in the united states has a huge
market share you want to start with
google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so nap is
name address phone number so
you want to make sure that that's
current and consistent so if you have a
number on your website make sure it's
the same number on google my business
okay you can embed a google map on your
website you could certainly optimize the
meta tags and content not only on your
web pages but within your google my
business directory so you can add your
business to other local directories like
i mentioned yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews the hat you
have the better off you are okay so i
always say this with the with local
search three of the main factors in
showing up for local search on say
google is obviously the key word the
second is the proximity of where that
person is and then third is the reviews
so you can't really control the
proximity but you can control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
keywords let's just say for your product
and service pages on your website but
also you can translate that over to
google my business okay so working in
those keywords making sure your your
number your address your name they're
all consistent and and really just
spreading
your the the business out on other
directors that's really all these are
really key factors for local seo okay so
question number seven how to avoid
duplicate content getting penalized for
duplicate content so for example if you
have two different versions of a web
page you may result in a duplicate
content issue so it's just seo 101 you
never want to have two two or more pages
with the same content so what do we do
well we can avoid this in having google
penalize us by again setting up a 301
redirect remember three or ones are
permanent we can also use what they call
a canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and the third option is opt for
preferred domain in google search
console okay so if you have multiple no
names make sure you set up a primary one
and search console so those are ways to
work around it of this three i would
always go with the canonical tags
because that's just a tag that's going
to sit on the page it's going to alert
google as to what the original is just
in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are gonna have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell the search engines hey
this is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible and what i mean
by simple as possible really i mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images in other words don't have such a
large image size if you don't need
something very large don't have it okay
you want to improve server response time
what do we mean by that well your site's
sitting on a server somewhere you can
own that server or you can be renting it
out from say amazon web services or
let's just say godaddy as your register
they also have web hosting well if you
have it on say godaddy's server you may
be sharing that server with other
businesses and at certain times of the
day other businesses may get a lot of
traffic and suck up a lot of bandwidth
what is that going to do that's going to
reduce the server response time for your
site and so you want to make sure you
have an idea of you know what server
your web page your website is on and you
want to be able to can have some control
over that because if your server
response is slow that's going to slow
down everything else in terms of loading
in the browser and that's not going to
be good for seo okay optimize your code
what do you mean by optimizing mimifying
when we see mimifying we mean get rid of
some of the redundant code if you have
css you know get rid of chop some of the
get rid of the javascript you're not
using so that's what we mean by
optimizing code reduce redirects okay
ideally you just want to have one
redirect in place you don't want to
create a daisy chain so to speak of
redirecting and redirecting after that
that's never going to bode well and it's
going to slow things down as well enable
browser caching so if you enable browser
caching basically if somebody comes back
to the page they've been on say two days
ago they're probably going to see a
cache version of that page and then off
for the content delivery network as well
so
these are some of the ways to reduce
page speed now if you're curious about
the page speed of your website you can
always go to google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just google pagespeed insights or even
just something generic like google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
page speed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a url when you plug
in the url google is going to analyze
the url for both mobile and desktop and
so here we could see google gives a
score so we could see the score from
mobile and we could see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here i could see
some of the issues that the site may be
having in terms of page load time for
their desktop if i flip over to mobile
you know here i can see some other
issues for example they have a server
static assets with efficient cash policy
now if you're not sure what the heck
that means you can always just click on
it and you can see some specifics here
and or you can just always google it as
well uh here you got to reduce the
impact of third-party code okay so
that's another thing uh reduce
javascript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
made about coding okay some sometimes
too much code or code not functioning as
well as it should will tend to slow down
the site okay so you can use pagespeed
insights you can always get a glimpse of
how pages are loading simply by also
going to for example google analytics
under behavior okay you can go to site
speed and if you click on overview okay
google what google does is they do a
sampling of pages over time and in this
case based on 89 page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific pages
load your site overall simply by looking
at the site speed overview report in
google analytics to get a sense of
how quick your pages are loading now
are certain factors that do affect low
time so obviously the way the page is
built with the code the images etc but
also the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be in the united states and have
worse network service than you do say
in
you know
ivory coast in africa okay so it really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings and google analytics
and you get a sense of what pages do not
load fast which ones do and maybe hone
in on the pages that aren't loading fast
and address those pages first okay so
you have two tools at your disposal one
google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual target short tail and long
tail keywords okay so
remember short tail are usually one to
two keywords very broad in nature long
tail keywords maybe three four keywords
in a query or maybe an entire sentence
those are considered long tail keywords
so usually short tail keywords have
higher volume but also higher
competition longer tail keywords usually
have lower
volume but also lower competition but
the great thing about long tail keywords
the conversion rate will tend to be a
little bit higher than say a short tail
because it's less vague and more
specific so you can use short tail
keywords if you're trying to drive a lot
of visitors because those keywords are
going to be vague or broad in nature
long tail keywords are used for targeted
pages such as product pages and articles
so if you have a specific product with a
long name you can certainly optimize
that page for that product name again
the product name may have low volume but
if somebody types in exactly that
product name you show up the chance of
you them converting are going to be very
high so you don't have to always be that
specific with the product name but try
and be as specific as you possibly can
in order to get somebody to click on
your link in the search engine results
and get them over to your site to
convert okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague
a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say long tail
where hey maybe you're just honed in on
a few set number of products and you're
not care you don't care a lot about the
traffic you just care about getting the
relevant traffic to your site to convert
okay number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of seo
okay so if somebody asks me this
question in an interview what am i going
to focus on when developing a website
well the answers are right here yes we
talked about mobile mobile is so
important because a lot of websites are
going to be
indexed with google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture navigation we want to have
a simple url structure okay no overly
cumbersome the navigation should simply
be clean and need okay if you have five
products okay maybe
you have uh in your navigation you have
something called products with all five
listed or you have all five products in
the main navigation the key is you just
wanna make it clean and neat and easy
for somebody to find the the rule of
thumb is if it's good for the end user
probably gonna be good for google but if
complicated for the end user it's
probably gonna be complicated for google
you always want to create a sitemap now
what is that sitemap a sitemap is simply
just a formatted file with to that
includes all your urls and assets your
images and your videos they're going to
be sitting on your server as well so you
want google or these these bots to be
able to find your pages and assets and
by the way you want to take it a step
further and make sure you upload that
site map which is sitting in the root
directory meaning domain.com
sitemap.xml okay you want to take that
sitemap and make sure you input that
sitemap location in google search
console that way google search console
has a one-way ticket to grab the
elements in the sitemap another
important element to focus on while
developing a website is having a robot's
text file and all a robot's text file is
it's like a walk i always say to a house
so if you lock a door in your house
nobody's going to be able to get in that
door so that's all a robot's text file
is you're telling google and these other
bots that are coming across your site
what's locked and what's not logged
meaning what they have access to what
they don't have access to so you want to
be able to make sure you have a robot's
text file if you're trying to
not index specific pages of your website
because if you tell google don't crawl
these pages or this directory they're
not going to get crawled if they don't
get crawled they're not gonna get
indexed so robot's text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and while
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
google know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website i'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
it indexed so
there's a lot of reasons to have
robots text files that's the main reason
site map you want google to get these
pages and assets quickly okay you want
to make sure that your site architecture
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
because that's what's going to keep
people on the website and engaged and
when i say content i don't necessarily
just mean words i also mean videos i
also mean images you know something
interactive okay you want to keep people
engaged that's the key behind it trust
me if an end user finds your site
engaging google is likely going to find
your site engaging okay so those are
good brownie points to bring up if
somebody asks you this question in an
interview so just to recap here it's
important to have a better site
structure so the bots can easily access
and mix the content with a responsive
design helps to make your website mobile
friendly and user friendly would also
increase the amount of time a user
spends on your website which may improve
your site's ranking sitemap is simply
just a file that helps search engine
bots to understand the structure of the
website okay how many pages are on your
website and where are they located along
with the videos and images okay and then
the robot's text just instructs the
search engine crawlers to understand
what pages should not be indexed okay
this is simply just a text file and it's
added to the root directory again think
like a door think of a lock okay you can
tell you can lock whatever doors you
want in your house then give it that way
okay so those are our questions for seo
again if you have any additional
questions or if there are other
questions maybe you've been asked in an
seo interview then go ahead and add them
to the comments section below we'd love
to hear from you now we're going to turn
our attention to search engine marketing
so let's turn our full attention to
search engine marketing so we're moving
away from seo and over to pay per click
and so you really have to know your
stuff here you really do uh so a lot of
the questions we're gonna ask gonna be
centered around google ads formerly
known as google ads words and so if
you're familiar with google ads the
platform then you should have no
problems whatsoever answering these
questions but that's why we're here and
that's why you're watching so
there's anything you want to add to any
of these questions as a reminder feel
free to comment under the video and so
right out of the gate question 11 what
is ad scheduling so ad scheduling is a
feature in google ads and really all it
does is allow you the advertiser to set
up certain hours or days you want your
ads to shout it's as simple as that so
if you have a customer that you're
running
ads for on google search and
let's just say they have a restaurant
and they're closed during certain hours
of the week then you can go into the ad
scheduler and schedule your ads to not
show when they're closed as an example
okay because if somebody calls and
they're not there to answer the phone
then it's not going to be good for the
restaurant or you the advertiser and so
that's why they have the ad scheduling
so it ensures your ads are not running
when they're performing poorly let's
just say
you know you're running a business and
you just don't get that much traffic
during the weekends well you can go in
and adjust accordingly it also there to
make sure you could serve your customers
when you do
have limited client service hours so
let's just say you have a customer
service team that's going to answer
phones for a couple hours a day well
again you can schedule your ads to show
during those couple of hours a day and
then really what it comes down to is
you're making sure you could satisfy
customer demand and supply and so that
means showing your ads when you you can
best fulfill the customer's needs okay
and so that's really what it's all about
uh and that's what ad scheduling is so
take advantage of ad scheduling schedule
it according to the business hours
schedule according to how they can best
serve the customer schedule the ads when
it's performing best and don't schedule
the ads when you know you're gonna have
poor performance okay so next question
what are the different ad formats
available on google ads it's a trick
question because it really does come
down to what network you're advertising
on so google has two networks the search
network and the display network okay so
on the search network there's only one
ad format and that's text okay so google
recently
changed the format of the text ads now
they're called expanded text ads so here
you can see you can have up to three
headlines and two description lines and
then you can also have ad extensions and
so you can see here underneath the ad
you have what they call site links so
shop by category in here headphones on
ear headphones those are all site links
to specific pages on the site so
text ads are available only on the
search network but they're also
available on the display network as well
then you have responsive display ads now
the sponsored responsive display ads are
only on google's display network okay so
here you could see
some samples of responsive display ads
and these ads adjust their size and
format depending on the space available
so again you could have text ads or you
can have display ads now display ads
again come in different sizes so you can
create ads for a variety of different
sizes for example 250 by 250 or 468 by
60. so those are some of the different
ad types there's there's a plethora of
different ad sizes you can choose
however your ads not going to show on a
website if they don't have that
particular size available so it's always
best practice to create different ads
but create ads in different sizes as
well okay and then have a backup text ad
as well just in case the site doesn't
even display a display ad for you or
serve up a display ad so you can have a
text ad as a backup okay so lots of
different ad sizes but this is the
second ad format that's responsive
display and again the responsive part is
google will automatically
show the ad that's best performing based
on a series of headlines descriptions
and images that use you provide google
and so the responsive part is hey if
this combination of headline description
and image work best meaning it has the
best click-through rate then google's
going to serve up that ad so that's why
they call it responsive so
obviously gonna have just an image ad
that's not responsive again across
different ad sizes you know they could
be again 250 by 250 300 by 300 468 by
six there's a number of different sizes
google can provide you that information
but the one thing to note here is that
when you do create an image ad it could
be
jpeg it could be
interactive or it could be static so
different types of image ad formats like
png for example or
it could be a static or it could be
interactive so
definitely take advantage of the
different opportunities uh meaning a
static ad versus an interactive ad you
may want to have two variations of that
so you could see which one works best
okay there's also app promotion ads so
these ads are used to drive app
downloads so you're going to have to set
up a campaign accordingly okay but here
you can see this is what it looks like
with a call to action so it allows you
to go ahead and click and install that
app so that's an app promotion again if
you have an app and you want to promote
it you can use this type of ad format to
align with a campaign that's driving
traffic to download your app okay and of
course you have video ads well google
owns youtube and so if you have videos
you have the opportunity to advertise on
youtube okay so these ads can be
standalone or inserted into other
streaming video content and so to me
video ads work well with specific
strategies and what's one strategy you
would use a video ad for brand awareness
or education explainer videos and so
youtube allows you the advertiser the
opportunity to get your ad your service
your product in front of a lot of
eyeballs so that's the beauty of video
ads they attract a lot of eyeballs and
definitely help with the strategy of say
brand awareness another ad format going
back to the search network is shopping
ads so if you sell shoes then you may
want to think about having a campaign
for shopping so shopping ads work with
google merchants so google merchant is
another google product and basically
google merchant allows you to manage
your inventory so if you have a hundred
different types of shoes that you're
selling you can upload your inventory to
google merchant connects and talks to
google ads so basically what you're
doing you're setting up your your
campaign and google ads and connecting
your inventory from google merchant to
google ads and so the great thing about
the shopping campaign is it puts your
product front and center it puts the
price it puts any promotion that you
have and it puts the brand all front and
center so when somebody does type in
let's just say lime green sneakers or
women's sneakers and this particular
shoe shows up here the third one from
the left then somebody's gonna see it's
from the united colors of benetton it's
a woman's shoe it's on amazon and it
costs 45
so the great thing about shopping ads is
if somebody's interested they're gonna
click okay if somebody's not interested
say well you know it's a little bit more
expensive i can get something similar
another shoe on amazon for less okay
they're probably gonna click on that
particular ad so again the great thing
about shopping ads put your product
front and center with any promotion the
price the brand so if somebody clicks on
it then they're probably serious buyers
okay so that's the beauty of shopping
ads it allows you to get your product
out there and on the search network it's
a cost per click so you're only paying
for the click so if somebody looks at it
but doesn't click you're not paying for
that so that's the beauty of shopping
ads and so
you can showcase your shopping ads so
these ads have an image and a
description that expand when clicked so
you can provide more information more
product and store information as well
you also have call only ads okay so call
only ads are enabled to users to connect
with your business directly using the
phone number provided okay so it allows
somebody on a mobile phone who in this
example is searching for drywall repair
well if you're in the business of
drywall repair you can have your ad show
up on mobile with the phone number and
somebody can easily click on that phone
number and just call you directly now
the way
call only ads work is you're still
getting charged for the click okay so
anytime somebody clicks and calls you're
gonna get charged and you're gonna get
charged just as you would if somebody
clicked on your ad so it works the same
way so it's a cost per click again this
is on search so search is cost per click
and the beauty about call only is again
you can track the calls writing google
ads so you can have google ads track how
many people click on the number and you
can even count those calls as
conversions if they meet a certain
criteria for example the criteria is
somebody
talks to you for a minimum of 60 seconds
or one minute then google will count
that as a conversion so you can monitor
calls right in google ads and it's a
cost per click model so you can actually
see what the average cost per click is
so moving on question 13. okay what is
rlsa and how does it work well
rlsa stands for remarketing list for
search ads so if you're familiar with
remarketing on display it's similar they
just call it rlsa okay so it enables you
the advertiser to customize your ads for
people who have visited your site just
like a typical remarketing campaign okay
so you could tailor your bids and ads to
these visitors when they're searching on
google and search partner sites okay so
they're two basic strategies for using
rlsa okay so you can optimize bids for
existing keywords for visitors or you
can bid on keywords that you don't
normally bid on just for people who
recently visited your site or converted
on your site the key here is you're the
one that's picking the customer you're
the one that's enabling the list if
you're trying to target people who went
to your site and didn't convert well you
could certainly optimize your bids for
existing keywords for people who went to
your site and did convert or you could
set up a whole new campaign for rllsa
and have a different set of keywords
with a different ad because you know who
you're talking to you're talking to
somebody who's already been to your site
they know your brand they just didn't
purchase and so this all happens on the
search network and that's the beauty of
remarketing is one you know who your
audience is because you're the one
establishing that audience and two
you're the one creating the ad so you
can talk directly to that audience when
they see your ad again in this case on
search so that's rlsa remarketing list
for search ads i recommend pretty much
any industry any client any customer run
remarketing list for search advertising
and remarketing for display so those are
two key campaigns you should always
recommend running to a client because
one again you're defining the audience
two
you're the one that's talking directly
to the ones because you know who the
audience is and three if they see the ad
and they click on it again because it's
cost per click then the chances of
converting are going to be higher
because they've already been to your
website they know who you are and so if
they click on your ad again then they
must be interested so those are all the
benefits of running an rlsa campaign
okay so number 14 what types of
audiences can be used in gdn google's
display network so a lot of different
audiences here okay so let's go through
them so you have affinity audiences so
basically affinity audiences are
basically
what are people's interests and habits
what do they have an affinity for are
there food sites travel sites shopping
sites fashion okay so that's what
affinity really relates to okay then you
have in market custom intent life events
these are what they're researching or
planning for so again it could be travel
it can be finance etc okay you have
remarketing we just went over that with
remarketing list for search advertising
rlsa and so with the remarketing it's an
audience that has interacted with your
website so they either came from mobile
or came from mobile and didn't convert
or female came from mobile and didn't
convert so you're the one defining the
audience there you also have a similar
audience so this is what google creates
on your behalf so these are users with a
similar interest to your site visitors
so google is monitoring the type of
traffic that's coming to your site and
based on that traffic they're going to
create a similar audience and then you
have a custom match so what you know
about your customers activities
basically so these are all the different
audience types and you can see the
different types of ads available okay so
notice the far right column video ads so
video ads are available to every one of
these audience types why because youtube
so google knows what people's interests
and habits are based on the videos they
watch they know what they're looking for
okay they
you know that they've been to your
website because they're cooking so you
can remarket them okay so video ads are
very powerful tool for any one of these
audience types so next question what are
the types of keyword matching available
in google ads okay so this is a good
question
very important if you're going to manage
a google ads account and a campaign you
have to be aware of the different match
types you can't just go broad match
that's a sign of somebody who doesn't
know what they're doing is by bidding on
a one keyword phrase that's a short tail
keyword if you think back to seo we have
our long tail and our short tail
keywords the worst thing you could do is
bid on a keyword short tail keyword
that's broad match because what is broad
match basically broad match or keywords
that appear when a user searches any
word in the phrase now you could define
specifically
what you want your ads to appear for in
terms of keywords and when i say
specifically you can use a phrase match
so phrase match are ads that appear only
when a user searches for that exact
keyword phrase in the precise order but
with some additional words in the
beginning or at the end of the query
okay so usually these are sentences so
you could be you know bidding on red
adidas running shoes and somebody could
type in looking for red adidas running
shoes in portland oregon as an example
okay so as long as red adidas running
shoes are in order in that keyword
phrase then your ads going to appear
because it's a phrase match and then you
can get really specific by doing an
exact match so exact match are keywords
that are triggered only when
that keyword and exactly that keyword
phrase is queried so if you do an exact
match for
red adidas running shoes and somebody
types in only red adidas running shoes
then that's an exact match and your ads
going to appear so let's take a look at
these again so you got broad match okay
we got a term cheap smartphone so if
somebody types in smartphone cheap phone
smart mobile phone cheap any one of
those combinations your ads going to
appear now there's one thing you can do
for broad match and it's called broad
match modifier so you could put a plus
sign in front of the keyword for example
let's just say you really want to
emphasize the word cheap okay you're
selling really inexpensive smartphones
okay not just any smartphone but in an
expensive smartphone so you can put a
plus sign in front of cheap and so
somebody puts in you know just
smartphone or smart mobile your ads not
going to show up because the word the
keyword query has to contain sheep so
anytime you put a plus in front of the
keyword query you're bidding on then
that means that keyword has to be part
of the keyword phrase so that's a a
broad match modifier if you will and
that prevents you from getting unwanted
impressions so we have phrase match
again blue smartphone so somebody could
type in smartphone in blue color cheap
blue smartphone notice though the second
one where it says smartphone and blue
color your ads not necessarily going to
show up because guess what blue
smartphone is the keyword query and
you're at your the query here is not in
that order so remember in order for you
to show up for phrase match the keyword
has to be in that order so i'm looking
for a blue smartphone
that is less than 100
okay that could be somebody's query blue
smartphone was in that query in that
order so if somebody says looking for a
smartphone that happens to be blue less
than a hundred dollars then your ad is
not going to show up so remember it has
to be in that ex precise order one thing
i want to go back to on the phrase match
notice that there's quotes around the
keyword anytime you see quotes around
the keyword that signifies a phrase
match because if we look at exact match
notice there are brackets around the
keyword red shoe that signifies is an
exact match so if you put brackets
around a keyword then you're signifying
signaling to google that this is an
exact match and i only want to show up
for the keyword red shoe well the only
option that will work here is the second
one red shoes okay so because that's an
exact match okay so disregard the first
and the third one because shoe and red
color is not going to work and footwear
that's red is not going to work because
this is an exact match so you're saying
i only want to show up for the keyword
red shoe and google recognizes plurals
and singulars together so somebody did
type in red shoes then your ad is going
to show up okay so moving on what are
some of the reasons as to why your ads
could have been rejected it happens to
the best of us and if you're writing ads
and they get rejected it could be for a
number of reasons so at the end of the
day you're violating google's
advertising policies so
some of the policies that could have
been violated are and just some of the
many we're just listing some here
prohibited content prohibited practices
restricted content or editorial
technical so when you look at prohibited
content i will say this you're not going
to be able to sell drugs even if you're
selling pharmaceutical products that's
considered drugs and that's going to be
prohibited or prohibited practices like
selling drugs online that's illegal in
the state so you're gonna definitely get
flagged for that okay so there are a lot
of different ways in which your ads can
be disapproved okay but if you do see
restricted content then that means you
can't advertise but with limitations and
usually those limitations are restricted
to say only google search and not google
search partners or to a specific
geography so usually the key here is if
somebody asks this question okay there
are a lot of different reasons google is
usually going to provide the specific or
the reason why it got disapproved and
they're usually going to include a link
that you can refer to okay so at least
google does that much they're not going
to leave you in the dark and tell your
ads just been disapproved they're going
to tell you why and include a link that
you can go to figure out how you can
best resolve the disapproved ad so what
are the different kinds of bidding
available in google ads so we already
covered part of this earlier on so
remember google search network is only
cost per click cpc when we talk about
google's display network you have three
options cost per click cost per view and
cost per impression and cpm is cost per
1000 impressions so you're paying per
1000 impressions impression is when
somebody actually sees your ad cost per
view
is actually somebody looking at your ad
for at least 30 seconds or the entirety
of the ad so if the ad video ad only
runs 15 seconds and somebody watched the
entirety then you're going to pay per
cost per view so if your video is two
minutes long and somebody watched 30
seconds you're gonna pay cost per view
okay so again let's go through these
cost per click it just enables you to
set up a maximum price on the cost of
somebody clicking on your advertisement
you only pay when somebody clicks on
your ad okay cost per view again this is
the default method to set the price
you'll pay for your video ads okay you
only pay when a viewer watches your
video advertisement for at least 30
seconds and then cost per 1000
impressions so this is the amount you
pay each time your ad is displayed in
the search network and you pay for
impressions that are generated for your
ad and you're paying for everyone
thousand impressions so the m is
actually the normal uh roman numeral for
1000 so that's where the impart comes in
so you're paying for 1 000 impressions
so every 1 000 eyeballs you're going to
pay a price and so cost per impression
is good for brand awareness if you're
trying to generate a lot of eyeballs
onto your brand then you'd want to go
with a cpm model okay so question 18
what are some automatic bidding
strategies so let's define automatic
bidding strategy automatic bidding
allows google take over okay not you
google's taking over and they're the
ones setting the bid amounts
automatically and it's gonna be based on
criteria and some of that criteria is
gonna be centered around conversions so
if google bids on your behalf
automatically basically what they're
doing is they're collecting data on the
behavior of your ads and so if your ad
is likely to get the click or conversion
then google is going to set the bid
amount so you can win that auction in
order to get the click or the conversion
so
there are different types of bidding
strategies but remember you have to
align a bidding strategy with the
strategy of the campaign so for example
if your goal of the campaign is to
increase site visitors you just want
people click on your ad and go to your
website then you're going to have an
automated bidding strategy of maximize
clicks that aligns with your campaign
strategy so this strategy automatically
sets your bids to help to get as many
clicks as possible within your budget so
google is going to do its best based on
historical performance of the campaign
to generate traffic to your site that's
the goal that's the biz strategy okay
let's take a look at some others so hey
the goal of our strategy campaign is to
increase visibility so that's an easy
one remember cost per impressions hey we
want to maximize how many people look at
our ads okay so target impression share
so this bidding strategy allows your
bids to show at the top of the page okay
so you're getting the impression so
people are able to look at your ad okay
so you're telling google hey i want to
be shown at least 50 of the time when
somebody types in a keyword that i'm
bidding on so they're going to make sure
that they meet your target impression
share 50 so they're going to set your
bids automatically to make sure your ad
shows at the top of the page so it's
seen at least 50 percent of the time
that's the goal of the campaign and
that's the bidding strategy goal we set
up a campaign to drive conversions so
there are a couple of bidding strategies
against conversions so target cpa so
this strategy sets a search or display
bid to get as many conversions as
possible but there's a caveat here cost
per acquisition is what cpa stands for
so we're trying to get as many
conversions as possible but at a certain
cost
for example if i'm selling t-shirts for
ten dollars do i want to pay 20
cpa for every sale do i want to pay
google 20 no i'd be losing money i'd be
out of business okay so if i'm selling
t-shirts for ten dollars on my website
i'm probably gonna put the cpa about two
dollars or three dollars again depending
on my cost of goods so if i factor my
cost of goods i'm trying to make a
profit then i'm going to tell google
look i'm trying to get some sales but i
don't want to lose money getting the
sales so you're going to put in a
threshold and that threshold is your
target cpa and so google is going to
automatically bid and win the auction
for keywords when they feel those
keywords can get you a target cpa that
you put in for example two dollars okay
so the goal of our campaign is to meet a
target return on ad spend meaning return
on advertising spend meaning we're
getting more revenue than we're spending
that ratio needs to be positive so
google's gonna help us again adjust our
bids to make sure that our return on
advertising spend meets our criteria so
we can put a roas as 100 200 etc and
google's going to adjust our bids
accordingly based on the keyword that
they think will meet that criteria of
100 or 200 so that's target return on
advertising spend and that's there to
see if google can help you generate a
profit so we have another campaign set
up we're trying to get more conversions
we have a budget we want to spend the
budget but we all we want to get
conversions so this is a giving the
bidding strategy here would be maximize
conversions so this strategy sets bids
like all the others it automatically is
going to adjust your bid that is google
it's going to adjust the bid to help you
win the auction based on historical
performance so if a keyword and
historically has performed in terms of
conversions you better believe google's
going to try and win the auction on your
behalf to get the click to get that
conversion and that's maximize
conversions okay moving on question 19
and this is probably the most important
question that you're going to get if an
interview asks you this question this is
what google ads is all about quality
score so what is quality score so simply
put quality score is a score between one
and ten given every keyword you've been
on and basically between one and ten and
space google's giving you the score the
quality score of that keyword and so how
does google come up with that score
between 1 and 10 well there's three main
factors here one is expected
click-through rate the second is ad
relevance and the third is landing page
experience so obviously a higher quality
score
the better off you are okay a low
quality score it's not going to bode
well for you and so if you have a low
quality score google actually
will tell you
which of these three components you're
not scoring very well on so you're
either going to get a below average
average or above average for each of
these three components that make up
quality score and i will tell you this
if i were to divide them up into thirds
click-through rate expected
click-through rate is more important
than the other two so that's about
two-thirds of quality score an expected
click-through rate is basically google
saying look other advertisers have been
on this keyword and their click-through
rate has been historically around say
for example three percent so if you
can't get three percent then your
quality score is going to suffer ad
relevance is simply does the ad or is
the ad relevant to the keyword you're
bidding on likewise for the landing page
but the landing page experience a little
bit more subjective because the landing
page has to load well fast no pop-ups no
a lot of external links nothing spammy
no ads being served up so a lot of
factors in landing page experience
google wants to make sure somebody
clicks on your ad that they're gonna
have a good experience when they land on
that page and so
quality score is so key here it is very
key because if you don't have a good
quality score the repercussion means
you're going to have to bid higher
because quality score times bid
equals ad rank so for every auction
whoever has the highest ad rank is going
to be at the top of google search
results so if you have a low quality
score let's just say one and you're
bidding four dollars on that keyword
then your ad rank is four one times four
is four so you gotta keep that in mind
because other advertisers could have a
higher ad rank or better quality scores
for that keyword so again expected
click-through rate this just shows how
likely it is that your ads will get
clicked when shown for a particular
keyword google expects a certain number
here you should always try to achieve
the highest click-through rate possible
and click-through rate is simply how
many times your ad was seen versus how
many times it was clicked that's all
click-through rate is clicks divided by
impressions so you should always try to
achieve the highest click-through rate
possible that will avoid getting a low
quality score add relevance so add
relevance simply means how relevant is
your keyword to the ad okay so if you're
bidding on red adidas running shoes then
make sure your ad discusses and mentions
multiple times naturally red adidas
running shoes okay and remember with
those text ads you have three headlines
you have two description lines of up to
90 characters you have side extensions
okay you have path one and path two that
meaning you can add additional keywords
to the end of a url so you have lots of
opportunities to make sure the ad is
relevant to the keyword and then landing
page experience again this is a little
subjective but hey google is going to
use landing page experience to estimate
how relevant and useful your website's
landing page will be to people who not
only click on your web but land on that
page so does that page load fast does it
have any unnecessary pop-ups does it
does it have some quirky external links
that looks spammy okay you got to take
all these things into consideration and
think about the end user here then last
question for search engine marketing so
what are the hard marks of a good ppc
landing page so going back to landing
page experience this is a good segue so
you always want to make sure you have an
attractive and powerful headline on the
page remember it's got to be a nice flow
you're bidding on a keyword somebody
types in the keyword they see your
attractive ad they click on that
attractive ad which has the keyword in
it they click on the ad they go to
landing page they want to be able to see
something very similar to what they
typed in the ad they saw they want to be
able to see it seamlessly on the landing
page and so that attractive and powerful
headline should include that key word
should also have persuasive copy that
can convince prospects to convert to me
bullet points always work here simple
bullet points easy to read easy to
understand easy to just convey the
positives about what you're trying to
sell or convert have engaging media like
videos videos always help because
they're interactive it keeps people
engaged longer or have some really good
images don't just go stock photography
you know compliment the video with some
images and then your landing pages
should have enough white space to draw
attention to specific elements on the
page and meaning don't cram the page
together because remember users are also
coming to these pages via mobile so you
got to take that in consideration as
well so cramming your pages full of
content videos and images is probably
not going to bode well so make sure
there's breathing room for people to
read understand and react and those are
hallmarks of a good ppc landing page
some other factors here adding trust
indicators like
some statistical evidence meaning how
many people downloaded your app you can
always have testimonials you know
third-party sales of approval like
better business bureau you know privacy
policy links help okay so you want to
add some things in there that's going to
you know give you credibility having a
properly designed lead capture form to
collect visitors information is always
helpful if you're trying to get that
conversion then have a lead form make it
simple don't have a lead form with 20
forms or fields you know have a simple
name email address make the phone number
optional and have one feel that they can
type in specific information and then
last but certainly not least have a good
call to action so make sure that call to
action aligns with what you're trying to
do again selling those red adidas
running shoes if they're on sale then
you know make sure the call to action
aligns with that sale you can always say
you have 20 off for the next two days or
you know 10 off if you purchase today so
have some good strong call to action
okay let's turn our attention to email
marketing so email marketing's
traditional digital marketing channel
it's been around a while and you're
gonna be asked some questions that are
going to encompass a lot of things
related to the delivery of emails we all
check emails on a daily basis we all
receive them sometimes we receive emails
unsolicited sometimes we sign up to
receive emails sometimes receive emails
from friends sometimes we receive emails
where we're working or previously worked
so most people have an understanding of
email however as a marketer there's a
little bit of a different twist to it so
we have to understand the intricacies of
how email marketing works so you're
gonna be asked some questions and really
the first question here is what's the
difference between a hard and a soft
balanced email so if you're a digital
marketer you're in charge of sending out
lots of emails let's just say thousands
or i mean it could be in the hundreds of
thousands of emails you're gonna get
some bounces and so you really want to
know the difference between a hard and a
soft bounce so a soft balance just means
that the email message reached the
recipient's mail server but bounce back
is undelivered so think of it as
delivering actual mail to a post office
so it actually reached the post office
but it bounced back because
maybe the
you know person's email box was full
maybe their account was temporarily
disabled or maybe the email server
wasn't necessarily able to handle that
email now hard balance is an email that
that is rejected because it's an email
when it happens when the email has been
permanently rejected so for example
maybe the the the account is no longer
valid and so let's look at some reasons
again as to why a soft bounce would
happen so for example the inbox is full
or
the recipient server's down so reach the
post office but there was a problem
actually getting it into the hands of
the owner so to speak where the hard
balance a little bit different let's
just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted or
you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay a spam or something to that
effect so the email server is going to
identify that and it's not even going to
reach the recipient so
a lot of different ways in which an
email may not make its recipient so now
the most important thing to know here i
just the important thing to know is
listen when you send out an email you
got to pay attention to how many get
bounced back and so next question here
what would you do to improve the
click-through rate of your email so
click-through rate is simply how many
people have seen your email and how many
people actually clicked on a link in the
email so if a hundred people saw your
email but only one person clicked then
it would be a one percent click-through
rate so we want to be able to make sure
we have a high click-through rate so
remember emails are going to people who
likely signed up to receive your email
and even if they are expecting an email
or they're not expecting an email you
still want to follow some of these best
practices here one is to create a
compelling subject line so you want to
make the subject line something that
people are going to notice take note of
or take an interest in and say hey
what's this all about that's pretty
interesting and open the email so use
preview text effectively obviously you
want to make your email mobile friendly
because most people look at their emails
on their mobile phones you want to
create engaging content okay so the
content that's in the email obviously is
going to have some links so put some
strong call to action in there and
that's one of the bullet points down
below place a cta where it's easily
visible so keep in mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good ctas in a visible location so
always check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them as visual as possible don't
make them so text heavy you can always
segment your emails meaning if you're
sending out an email let's just say to
100 people okay maybe you want to divide
it up boys or girls maybe older or young
maybe you know living in one part of the
country versus another part of the
country i mean those are examples of
segments so break up the email don't
send it to
one mass email to everyone that way you
can personalize the email if an email is
personalized the chances of somebody
clicking on it are going to be greater
and then a b tester emails and when we
say a b test you know you could send out
the same email twice except one segment
is going to say get one version of the
email the other segment is going to get
another version of the email and what
are the different versions maybe the
subject line so the subject line is
different on version a versus version b
or maybe the call to action is different
so you always want to
send out different versions of the same
email to a different segmented audience
that way you can actually see which
segment or which version got the most
clicks okay so next question here is how
to inform your customers about company
news and establish a relationship with
your target audience okay so again how
do you inform your customers about
what's going on in the company and how
are you going to establish a
relationship with that audience who's
receiving that email well newsletters
are always the best answer here so
somebody signs up for your email let's
just say they actually purchase a
product from you newsletters are great
way to reach out to that audience to get
them to stay up to date with the latest
product or an improved version of the
product they purchased and then that way
they can come back and continue to
purchase the product so newsletters are
great way to reach out to
your audience and actually talk to your
audience and you're not talking verbally
you're talking to them via email so you
send out that email campaign maybe it's
once a month hey we noticed you bought
this product we have similar products
just like the one you bought or hey you
know if it's a software maybe hey we've
got upcoming updates to our software
make sure you go to the website and get
the updates or we have a new and
improved version so all these things you
want to communicate to your audience via
email that's going to get them to get to
the website and that's going to get them
to you know purchase more update upgrade
whatever so newsletters the way to go so
again some basic tips here you want to
create your newsletter with 90
educational and 10 percent promotional
so remember you're sending out a
newsletter to people who likely signed
up so you're educating them about your
products always create interesting
subject lines you want whether they know
you or not you want to create the
subject line so somebody's going to
click on it so make sure you design your
emails appropriately okay so if you know
you're sending let's just say baby
products to mothers or expected mothers
in fact this is a real life example
because i used to work at a gap and
baby gap was you know one of the emails
groups i was responsible for so we
created an email template with softer
colors your yellows your your light blue
you know it wasn't black or dark red or
anything that's going to be you know
heavy we knew who our audience was and
we designed the template accordingly and
of course using compelling images so for
selling baby products you're going to
put baby product images in there i mean
it's common sense but you'd be surprised
you gotta pick and choose your images
carefully especially if you're sending
to an international audience because
images can be misconstrued and just like
we mentioned with the click-through rate
you always want to
have a clear cta always make sure you
have a cta in a visible position because
most people are going to look at that
email in a mobile phone okay and then
always make sure you include your
contact information in the newsletter so
somebody knows where to find you how to
contact you where to go maybe they have
a product they want to return okay so
you always want to put that contact
information normally it's at the bottom
of the email but these are all best
practices so
here's some examples okay we got you
know check out the latest cosmetics from
our new collections notice the image and
notice the call to action so you can see
trendy collections you know we got some
other products you may want to buy okay
five important skin care products that
everyone should have view more so you
always want to have that call to action
in a very visible place so define
following metrics open rate
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate so these are metrics
related to email marketing so you're
gonna have to know what these are so we
already mentioned click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices for improving the
click-through rate so for those of you
that remember what that is go ahead and
put that in the comment section below
just a little pop quiz for you if
anybody remembers click-through rate but
let's take a look at open rate so open
rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who actually open
the email so if you send it to
x amount of people how many people
opened it that would be the open rate so
how many people open it but you're gonna
take out the people who bounced it
whether it's a soft bounds a hard bounce
okay you're not gonna count those people
so
if you have let's just say
20 people opened the email and you sent
it to a hundred people then and you had
nobody balanced then it would be a
twenty percent open rate okay
click-through rate again pop quiz it's
just how many people actually clicked on
any of the links in your email and
that's just divided by the number of of
the emails you've sent out the response
rate okay so response rate is the
percentage of the total recipients who
clicked on the link of your email
campaign and actually completed an
action so what is that action well it
could be downloading something watching
something purchasing something so that's
the response rate similar to conversion
rate if you're working in a digital
marketing channel and you're driving
traffic to the site you want that
traffic to do something well it's no
different in email marketing we want
people to take action we're just going
to divide that by the number of emails
delivered and that gives you your
response rate so let's just say you did
send in 100 emails you did get 20
percent open it and of this twenty let's
just say one person went on a purchase
well you'd have a one percent response
rate and then afford rate the simply the
forward rate refers to the rate at which
your subscribers share your email uh
with others friends family etc and you
may have that as a call to action in
your email in fact that's a best
practice so it's just the number of
clicks on a share divided by the total
number of delivered emails and you're
going to multiply that by 100 to get the
percentage and so most email marketing
platforms do measure forward rate okay
let's take a look at question 25 here
how do we capture inactive customers
what you want to do here is re-engage
subscribers with gamification
opt for subject lines like we have been
missing you or did we do something wrong
you want to run a poll or a competition
and re-engage their subscribers again
trying to get people involved these
first three are all about getting people
involved so personalize your emails talk
to that person as if hey look i haven't
heard from you in a while about coming
back and taking a look at our new
products just as you would a friend say
a design always matters especially
knowing that you're talking to customers
who haven't been active okay this is a
segmented audience somebody who's
inactive so you want to have the right
design the right message the right
subject line that fits with that
customers and activity so you want to
try and do everything you can to get
that customer back and then you want to
follow a consistent schedule okay so
ideally when you schedule an email you
want to schedule the best time so you
have to know your audience obviously and
then you can always ask for feedback why
are they inactive why haven't they
purchased in a while so the whole idea
here from gamification like trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive to
adding polls to really personalizing it
these are all things that you can do to
get your customers back so 26 so what
are the different ways to segment buyer
personas so again when we talk about
segmentation we're talking about taking
a smaller piece the entire pie so what's
one way to break up that pie if you will
by geography okay so with geography you
could target your audience based on that
area and it could not necessarily have
to be by a part of the country it could
be all the way down to the province the
state the actual city the county okay if
you live in a small village okay all the
way up to the continent okay so think
about how you would break out the
segment by geography now obviously if
you break it out let's just say the
united states to the southern part well
the southern part you know in the winter
in the united states the southern part
is not going to be as cool to say the
northern part so that should tell you
hey we're going to send out an
email in the winter we're not going to
use snow and blizzards as our theme
we're going to use probably a little bit
of sun so breaking it out by geography
helps you understand where your audience
lives you also have demographic
segmentation and this is simply just age
education income gender you know where
people work okay nationality anything
that's going to identify that user so
this is the best way to segment if you
know who your audience is by income or
gender i mean you're talking to a group
of like-minded people if they're all the
same age from the same generation then
you could talk to them appropriately and
you're not going to talk to an older
person the same way you would a younger
person so think about
demographic segmentation because it
really helps you hone in on your
messaging and you have behavioral
segmentation so behavioral is based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something how long did they stay on the
site what products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at behavior
and decide how you want to break out
your emails by behavior and this is a
really good way if you're not even sure
who your audience is or where they live
and how old they are you could certainly
break out your audience by behavior
because you know who these people are
based on what they've done previously
because you're going to track that
information with analytics so you know
one way is obviously if somebody's
purchased that's a good way to segment
because you know these people believe in
you believe in your business believe in
your product so the way you can message
to somebody who's purchased before is
going to be different than somebody you
don't even know who they are if they
purchased or not okay so behavioral
segmentation to me is one of the easiest
things the easiest ways to segment your
email list 27 how would you drive repeat
customers through email marketing for
the below scenario okay so this is a pop
quiz if you will again for those of you
that got click-through rate correctly
kudos let's see if you can go two for
two here okay so if you know the answer
to this go ahead and comment below but
let's just say give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for
audiences based on the following if i
had an audience between 20 and 30 years
old that were female and the product
were sandals okay what would some of
your subject lines be so i'm gonna give
you a minute to think about that and put
it in the comment section below now
remember this is an interview based
question so you're going to have to
think on the spot i'm going to give you
a minute but if somebody presented that
to you in an interview you need to be
able to you know react fairly quickly
and come up with some really attractive
subject lines here okay so here you go
here's another one uh so give a few
examples of subject lines to drive
engagement for 20 to 30 females for
footwear so you got friday sale coming
up buy branded sandals at the lowest
price okay so i like this one because
it's got a strong call to action buy
here you go this is even better because
50 off on branded sandals and free
shipping i mean who can't beat free
anything including shipping and if it's
50 off i mean these are key things
you're putting the promotion and
percentage off all in the subject line
so that's really going to grab
somebody's attention weekend sale for
women starts now okay with a little
emoji that never hurts so those are all
good subject lines they all tend to work
because they all have an element of a
best practice in there so
here you got you know the friday sale
coming up is just giving people notice
okay the stronger call to action on the
buy you're putting the promotion in the
subject line and you know using an emoji
to really just drive home the point so
all these subject lines will work and
hey at the end of the day remember you
want to test your subject lines okay
moving on to the next question speaking
of testing what is a b testing and give
some examples of a b testing okay so we
talked a little bit about a b testing
with subject lines so simply a b testing
when it comes to email marketing it's
just a method to analyze which of the
two email campaign strategies is most
effective all right you know you're
gonna do it based on open rate you can
do it by saying click rate you can do it
based on response rate and remember
you're putting one version of the email
against another version whether that be
the subject line whether it be the
content call to action whatever so
that's ideally what you're trying to do
you're trying to figure out what works
for your audience that's the end goal
for email for a b testing and email
marketing what's going to work and i
would highly suggest you should always
do a b testing for subject lines always
so some of the variables that you can
test again subject lines okay you always
want to try if you got a promotion hey
will the percentage off work likely it
will but let's test it up against
something else like you know a generic
word like discounts you can always test
the design you can always test the
personalization the preview text you
could try out images call to actions
exclusive offers what particular offer
is gonna work okay so if you're testing
offers then obviously that's gonna be
response rate if you're testing ctas and
that's gonna be click-through rate if
you're testing subject lines that's
going to be open rate so you want to be
able to test different elements of the
email to figure out what works and what
doesn't work okay so how to prevent
email from getting into spam so if
you're an email marketer this is your
worst nightmare you don't want your
emails to get spammed so that doesn't
bode well for you so most email
marketing platforms like mailchimp or
constant contact measure spam so some of
the important ways to prevent this is
hey improve your open rate remember
going back to the first question second
question you want to have really good
subject lines here okay and you want to
segment your audience so if you know who
you're talking to and you have a cool
subject line that's going to get
somebody to react and open and that's
going to prevent somebody from spamming
your email okay you can always customize
your from to make it look like it's
coming from in this case rob sanders
check if you have included an
unsubscribe link okay so give people the
option to unsubscribe they don't have
the option to unsubscribe they could
just report you as spam make sure your
emails work on different devices okay
you want to optimize your images for
email make sure they're not big and they
don't fit on a mobile device okay prefer
more text and fewer images and then
avoid grammatical issues you want to
come across as professional you don't
want somebody looking at your email like
who sent this why are you sending this
to me i don't want to hear from you
again i'm going to spam you you want to
prevent that and that means a
professional looking email professional
content with a really good subject line
and some imagery to go along with that
hey you may just get somebody to open
that email and get them to convert
that's the idea behind it so these are
ways to prevent somebody from actually
spamming you and then what are the best
practices for email subject lines so the
subject lines of most probably the most
important element in email marketing so
we talked about that little pop quiz
with the sandals targeting 20 to 30 year
old women you know to me i like the
subject line with the 50 off so that was
a number in the subject line so people
can actually see hey wow i get a whole
50
that works better than just a discount
okay remember one of those subject lines
had an emoji so don't be afraid to
include emojis in there for example when
i send out emails using you know during
the spring you might want to use flowers
perhaps to signify hey it's spring
winter's over so personalize the subject
lines remember that goes with segmenting
so if you know who your audience is your
subject lines can be a little bit more
partial okay so off for title case
subject lines okay so instead of making
it grammatical for example okay you want
to keep your subject lines short and to
the point remember you want to say
something that's going to draw
somebody's attention if you make it long
and drawn out and boring then people
aren't going to open it develop a sense
of urgency like hey we got 50 off
through friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's thursday i
better open this email and check it out
and again grammatical mistakes that goes
without saying you always want to
preview your emails before you send them
out so if you preview your emails before
you send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you to
prevent any mistakes but also give you
feedback on the imagery the design etc
okay so these are all best practices for
good subject lines okay so subject lines
are most important element for email
marketing so just keep these in mind
subject lines and having good subject
lines is the way to get people to open
it and from there that's half the battle
somebody can open the email then you've
just
set yourself up for better performance
okay let's turn our attention from email
marketing to social media marketing one
of the interesting channels hot trend
channel a lot of people want to get into
social media marketing a lot of jobs
available but you have to know what
you're doing so let's get into it uh and
here's some questions you might be
asked in an interview related to
social media marketing social media
marketing is very interactive
a lot of people posting information
whether it be a tweet a post
sharing liking engaging commenting i
mean a lot of things going on in social
media so some of it is going to probably
be good most of it's probably going to
be good but every once in a while you're
going to get a negative comment so
you're probably going to be asked this
question how do you respond to negative
comments well very simple you got to be
quick to acknowledge okay don't sit on
it you know don't waste time
him and hot how you're going to respond
you really have to acknowledge the
comment and start the process of
constructive engagement to turn the
negative experience into a positive one
so let me just expand on that for just a
second we know you like your brand we
know you like your product we know
you're very proud we get that i'm proud
i like to defend sometimes my beliefs
however you got to put that aside when
it comes to social media why because
everybody is watching you and everybody
can read what you write so you the
spotlight is on you not necessarily the
consumer the customer who wrote the
negative comment so you really have to
be cognizant here and conscientious of
what you post in response so be quick
but be constructive because you want to
turn that negative into a positive
that's really what it's starting with so
how do you do that well how do you be
constructive well see it from the
customer's point of view take off your
ownership hat if you will your manager
hat and put on the customer's hat always
look at something from somebody else's
perspective try to understand why that
person wrote that negative comment and
ask yourself how you can make it right
so if you're the customer and you are
your customer when you go to the store
and buy food you're the customer when
you go to the store and buy clothes when
you buy a car you're the customer so ask
yourself what you can do to make it
right why you're thinking in the
customer's perspective or looking
through their eyes if you will to me
it's it's not an easy thing to do but
it's something you have to do okay so
always look at it from a customer's
point of view and then take it out of
the spotlight so
really because everybody's looking at
you waiting to see how you respond and
remember this customer that wrote the
negative comment can certainly share
your comments to the world so you got to
be really really careful i mean how many
times have we seen on youtube you know
poor customer experience going viral on
on via video so you just gotta really be
careful here so take it out of the
spotlight so offer to resolve the
customers problems in an appropriate
forum offer up your phone number an
email give them a link to a feedback
form or get their email or phone number
and call them these are the best ways to
really bend this into a more positive
experience for the customer i mean at
the end of the day could become
something really small and silly but
don't make a mountain out of a mall hill
if it is something small and silly how
you respond could make it into more than
what it really is so be quick be
constructive look at it from the
customer's point of view and offer as
much support as you possibly can okay
that's how you want to respond if
somebody asks that question in an
interview some other comments here so
keep track although the issue might be
solved it doesn't necessarily mean the
commenter has gone away so follow up
with them if you resolved it follow up
with them a month later hey surprise
them two months later give them a
discount okay you'd be surprised
positivity goes a long way and it's
always nice when somebody actually
follows up with you after the fact just
to make sure they want to know that
you're taken care of and then don't feed
the social media trolls okay so ignoring
trolls across social media will make
sure they don't enjoy the notoriety it
brings so don't even allow the
negativity to feed itself so that's why
you really have to stay quick
constructive you know look at it from a
customer's point of view and just turn
this whole experience into a positive
experience it's an opportunity for you
to hone your skills let's move on to
another question so somebody may ask you
to give an example of a successful
social media campaign okay so if you're
going in to interview for social media
manager job you probably want to do your
homework in advance look at what other
people have done so here's a good
example spotify you can see the spotify
ad here with ed sharon spotify mind the
search and playlist data of its user
base to develop a thematic branded ad
experience on billboards in 18 markets
around the world first of all let's just
take this and break it down and sharon's
popular you can see here be as loving as
the person who put 48 ed sheeran songs
on their i love gingers playlist so
messaging is everything okay and then
you could see what spotify did they mine
the search and playlist data of its user
base okay so they try to understand
their audience going back to email you
gotta understand your audience okay then
they use that to develop a branded
experience on different markets around
the world so they took an audience and
they really marketed this around the
world okay to something that was really
hot and trendy i'd love to see how this
thing actually performed my guess is it
did perform fairly well because when
you're spotify you're gonna pick
something hot and trendy to get people
to react and said to me this seems like
just on the surface a very successful
social media campaign here's some other
things uh you can see these ads were
featured on the sides of buildings
subway platforms a long busy streets so
it wasn't just digital per se i mean
they really went full bore on the
billboards and those billboards were
everywhere on the sides of buildings
again in 18 different markets so you can
see it wasn't just necessarily ed sharon
per se but you know they had some good
messaging and gr enjoy green light at
every red light that's pretty cool i
guess if you're stuck in traffic in the
middle of a city less fake news more
fake magic so they really took and honed
in the type of music put some good
messaging behind it and really put it
out there so it doesn't always
necessarily have to you know necessarily
be digital per se but they what they did
was
they did post this on the sides of
buildings and subway platforms and
throughout different city streets for
maximum visibility for their fans to
upload to their social media okay so do
your homework okay and on this next
question you certainly want to do your
homework so if you're social media
manager you're probably going to be
involved in some facebook advertising
okay so this is a basic straight up
question what are some of the different
types of ads you can run on facebook you
know you can do single image ads most of
us have probably seen that you can do
multi-product lead ads slideshows
collection ads video ads i mean you got
all sorts of a variety different ad
formats here okay so let's take a look
at these ad formats single image again
most of us have seen it okay it's just
simply a single image that you know has
allows you to put some text at the top a
link at the bottom or linked to your
website or your facebook page and a
strong call to action okay so facebook
has that built into their ad platform
okay so the ad images need to be 1200 by
628 pixels it's a pretty nice size image
multi-product ads so multi-product ads
are
represented in carousel form so
basically it allows you the end user to
view the range of products just by
scrolling and notice each one of these
products has a call to action so here
you can see simply learn offering up all
the different courses they have to offer
so if you have a customer that has
multiple products this is probably the
way you want to go so video ads are very
popular on facebook so video ads usually
range from a few seconds all the way up
to 120 minutes and again video is very
engaging if you have video use the video
okay because they receive about 10 to 30
percent more views than other forms of
ads okay who doesn't like engaging with
video pretty simple you have lead ads so
lead ads allow you to obtain user
details like name phone number email
right in facebook's environment so it
allows you to collect information right
then and there so lead ads can be
effective if you're trying to get people
to sign up for something slideshow so we
looked at those multi-product ads where
you had the carousel slideshow simply
just allows you to rotate different
creative with nice imagery so the key
here is nice imagery okay you want to
put your best foot forward choose the
right imagery just like going back to
the email marketing you know going back
to pay-per-click you want to use some
effective ads here and images in the ads
okay you also have collection ads that's
another option on facebook so collection
x ads combine video slideshow or product
images taken from your product catalog
so i would recommend this for users who
want to advertise several of their
products at once okay again simply learn
has a lot of different courses a lot of
different thousands of courses so you
know collection ads works for them you
can see here you got social media
certification you got ppc certification
seo certification okay these are all
different certification courses you
could take it simply learn and they want
to go ahead and promote all those
courses together so lo and behold
collection ads offers the best option
here so pay attention those different ad
formats on facebook okay next question
how can you use the holiday season for
social media marketing well this is a
nice segue from the previous question
because you know you have on facebook
all these different ad types so you
could change your ad placements to ones
lesser used by other advertisements you
can also set up clear simple and
compelling offers for your users the
holiday season you're likely going to
have some sales and again make sure your
images have under 20 of text okay that's
a standard across the board but again
you want to have nice imagery so think
about all those different ad formats on
facebook think about the holiday season
and how you can accentuate your ads here
okay i'm thinking video here i'm
thinking a promotion in the video i'm
thinking a collection ad where you can
run different products maybe with a
promotion with some nice imagery during
the holiday season so you definitely
have a plethora of options not just on
facebook but across social media for the
holidays because normally you're going
to have promotions some other things you
can do to
really maximize the holiday season for
social media and that's make
advertisements emotionally resonate with
your audience the holiday season is a
time really where you reflect on the air
you get together with friends and family
and it's religious and you know it's a
feel good in some parts of the world the
weather changes so you want to resonate
on that okay you want to resonate on
that emotion okay you always holiday
season or not you want to monitor
reports to scale successful ad campaigns
and obviously the ones that aren't
performing you want to pause okay so
with the holiday season you're likely
going to have an uptick in traffic and
uptick in eyeballs so pay attention you
don't want to spend money for money sake
so on facebook it's a cost per click
model so you don't want to be generating
clicks without seeing any results so go
ahead and pay attention maximize those
ads that are performing and get rid of
the ones that aren't okay and then
connect the holiday with your products
or services so again think about which
ones you're going to accentuate which
ones you're going to make more prominent
during the holiday season again thinking
back to the facebook ad types i'm
thinking carouseller collection ads if
you can really pump up some of your
products and have a nice promotion with
them you can run some nice collection
ads on facebook moving on to the next
question so somebody may ask you hey how
do you make content go viral okay i
always wondered that myself how does
content go viral it's a great question
so really you're not necessarily in
control but you can certainly do some
things to make it more appealing for the
end user to go ahead and share it i mean
that's what going viral is right a lot
of people sharing it because the more
people that share the more people are
going to look and find it just as
enticing and they're going to turn
around and share it so how do you start
that process really is what it comes
down to well create short form content
short form content is more likely to go
viral in other words a 10 minute video
is probably not gonna resonate with
somebody something cute funny
interesting unique out of this world in
15 30 seconds is probably gonna go viral
so what does that mean make the visual
content like images and video it works
better than bodies of text so make sure
those images and video are really
compelling and then run giveaways to
draw attention and generate brand
awareness and engagement so you can
always
incentivize your users with a giveaway
or some type of promotion that's going
to maybe pique somebody's interest you
know share it with 100 friends and get
10 off as an example so these are some
of the things you can do to make it go
viral of course if you're trying to get
something to go viral you definitely
want to monitor behavior and then tweak
once you figure out how it's performing
okay you may have chosen the wrong
images you may have the wrong promotion
you may find that the contents a little
bit longer than you probably like and
you may want to cut it down some other
things you could do here is use some
trending hashtags and topics on your
post so ride that wave if you will for
any surfers in the audience hey two
people can ride the same wave so if you
got a trending hashtag use that hashtag
with that video or post you can always
ask users to interact okay so you can
always ask them to like or share
especially if they're their audience
because when somebody actually shares it
that means they're sharing it with
somebody else who also has an audience
so that's a quick way to get the ball
going so to speak about bouncing okay so
next question which industries perform
better with different platforms great
question there's a lot of different
social media platforms you got your most
popular ones all the way down to your
least popular ones i mean let's face it
social media platforms are also
geographic so some social media
platforms are more popular in say the
united states than say india or russia
and vice versa we know china has a lot
of different social media platforms that
most americans in the united states
don't even use so you got to keep that
in mind but we're not talking about
geography we're talking about industry
so you got to also think about industry
here so generally the facebook it's
usually food and beverage news and media
e-commerce those are the types of
industries that you might tend to see on
facebook when we talk about e-commerce
you know it could be clothing it could
be you know restaurant okay selling or
it could be a a food company selling you
know foods and beverages you also have
instagram so instagram tends to be more
beauty food and beverage e-commerce so
when we talk about beauty we're talking
about clothes we're talking about makeup
you know maybe shoes dresses unique
styles i see a lot of that on instagram
and then linkedin for example generally
works with you know for me i look at
linkedin as b2b okay so anything you
know interesting in a specific industry
you're probably going to see some news
items and updates on that tips and best
practices and of course jobs a lot of
recruiters on linkedin so linkedin's a
good place for you to really put
yourself out there to find that job you
seek that social media manager job okay
so here's a breakdown if you will of the
top five again in the united states you
know for those users who are watching
this from another country you know you
may find i'll be interested if you could
get some feedback here you know in the
comments section of the video go ahead
and put you know the social media
platform you use in your country and
generally what do you see on that
platform do you see food and beverage do
you see gaming or entertainment do you
see e-commerce so share your thoughts
and knowledge with the rest of us so
next question how would you measure
social media marketing success of an
organization and this is a likely
question a question you're likely going
to get okay how do you measure success
and that's across the board not just
social but ppc email marketing display
affiliate so really you're always going
to have the right answer if you talk and
think about conversion so with
conversions about tracking content
downloads or sales or registrations or
legion or form submissions anything
where you're gonna get something in
return okay so to me that's the general
answer here you know how do we measure
success well it always depends on
strategy but if you're trying to get a
sale from instagram based on your beauty
product or you got a promotion you're
running on facebook and you're running a
lead form type ad okay are you getting
people to enter in that enter in details
on the form submission do you always
want to track conversions from that
perspective okay you also have
engagement okay so your strategy may not
be conversion maybe your strategy is
simply brand awareness and engagement
you want to know how many people
participate in the conversation for
example you may post something that's
really you know hot trends it's trending
it's it's political it could be business
it could be a world of fair you want to
be able to measure how many people react
how many people comment reply repost
retweet share like etc so
engagement metrics vary across different
social media platforms but basically
when it comes to engagement you can
measure it just has to align with the
right strategy you also have awareness
again if you're just simply in it for
brand awareness okay it's all about how
many people are actually looking at it
the total volume of people okay and how
widely your message is spreading okay
what's the reach it could also be just
simply traffic to your website so you
can certainly track traffic to your
websites by clicks or shares so it
doesn't always have to be about
conversion or engagement it can simply
hey we want to drive traffic to the
website it's at 37. what are some things
to focus on when advertising on twitter
okay you can advertise on twitter
whether you knew that or not now you
know twitter is a platform where you can
pay for advertising so
what do you want to focus on when you do
advertise on twitter well you want to
emphasize urgency to make sure users
take immediate action you want to
express discounts and percentages why
well because you're limited in what you
can say on twitter you want to avoid
using hashtags that don't pertain to
your brand and product i know that may
sound like common sense but remember
you're advertising in here so you got to
be really really really careful because
you're paying you're paying for somebody
to either look at that ad or click on
that ad so some other things you want to
keep focus on is your ad copy it's got
to be short and to the point and then
make sure your ads are mobile friendly
again just like most social media
platforms twitter is no different people
are looking at twitter on their mobile
phones so video ads should have
subtitles images in the proper ratio so
you always want to think mobile mobile
mobile mobile because most people are
using mobile on their mobile phones
whether that be in the browser or via an
app okay next question how can you use
social media to promote your event okay
so you got an event coming up i want to
promote it so you're going to turn to
social media and the first thing you do
is have affiliates fans and attendees
share resources about the event okay use
leverage your community in other words
okay you can remarket the event to
potential attendees using facebook ads
so you can do remarketing and
remarketing is basically hey somebody
who's seen it or been there or done that
you're retargeting those people you can
use photos of attendees and social
updates so depending on the event you
can have some really high profile
attendees speaking at the event or just
attending the event so use photos to
drive excitement about the event okay
you can create a uniform hashtag that
can be shared across multiple channels
you can mention the event all social
media bios so don't just limit it to one
you know cross promote it on twitter
linkedin etc and what you could do is if
you've run other events in the past
create a highlight rail from prior
events you know show people hey your
events are the events you must attend
they're the go-to events because they're
popular they're successful good
attendees usually good attendance and
then some other things you could do here
share behind the screens visual content
and again you could share pictures of
guest speakers along with their quotes
okay so you want to do everything
possible at your at your disposal
especially on social media to really
pump up the event next question how can
you perform a b testing on your ads so
for those of you that listen intently on
the email marketing part remember e a b
testing is key with email marketing what
are we testing in email we're testing
subject lines we're testing layout we're
testing call to action so the same thing
here on social media you want to do
continuous a b testing to figure out
what works and doesn't work it's very
simple the great thing about facebook is
they got an a b test feature built in so
you can certainly test different ads
great thing about facebook i like is
that you can simply start out with an
app by running an a b test you could
simply test the imagery it could be a
male versus a female you could test the
call to action a lot of things you could
test so things you can change are again
color of the elements you could change
the positioning you could change the
audience you're targeting the call to
action i mean everything everything
because the whole point is you want to
see which one works which one doesn't
work so testing can be done initially on
broader elements and then smaller finer
details like statements in your ad copy
so you could start out big just by
testing the imagery and so the female
tends to work better in the mail then
you know what works in terms of imagery
well take the next step and start honing
in on say the message and then once you
figure out what message works then you
can move to the next element like cta
some interesting questions you may get
include what are some things to focus on
when setting up your ad creative this
goes back almost to the a b testing you
want to use ad creative that's attention
grabbing and relevant for your business
so use a primary but bold color scheme
so you also want to
stay away from clip art okay so again
align your imagery really is important
on social media don't use some basic
cheap clipart you don't necessarily
always have to use stock imagery either
i mean it could be imagery you took
that's very relevant and unique to your
product but if you do that don't use low
resolution pixelated images use images
that are well lit so decide on the
aesthetic you want for your creative
clean and minimal or colorful and
vibrant it really depends on you know
the advertisement what it is you're
trying to promote so some other things
to focus on here to create attention
grabbing ads show images of people
benefiting from your product and
coca-cola has done this forever when
have you never seen a coca-cola
commercial with somebody with a smile on
your face drinking a bottle of coke i
don't think i've ever seen an
advertisement so when it comes to food
you should always have somebody in there
enjoying the food if it comes to clothes
should have somebody looking like they
really enjoy wearing these clothes and
they look great in them you want to
accentuate that with you know some nice
coloring sticking with your brand
guidelines okay so imagery really is
important here so you do need to make
sure the ad works for your brand without
requiring explanatory copy the image
should basically speak for itself okay
so let's finish up with content
marketing content marketing another big
digital marketing channel a lot of work
out there so if you're going in for an
interview let's review some of the
questions you may get asked okay so
starting out what are the essential
components of a good web content okay so
essential components okay so what do we
want our content to do well we want it
to be useful so web content should be
written in a way which caters to what
the reader wants okay so somebody's not
going to read your content if it's not
useful for them okay this because it
affects reader engagement okay so if
it's not interesting it's not useful
somebody's just not going to read it
plain and simple it also has to be
engaging so listen even if it is
relevant to a user you still have to
write the content so it's engaging so
you want to add elements like imagery
videos hey you can even turn your
content into an infographic okay you
want to do something that's going to be
engaging for the user if it's engaging
they're going to read it and engage with
the content okay and then good content
should have some call to action so
content must be written in a way that
can drive call to action okay so if
you're writing a blog post you know i've
seen a lot of blog posts just simply
start and with good content but it
doesn't leave the user with anywhere to
go so have that call to action put some
internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after you're done
engaging with the good content you write
okay so some other things to think about
some other components for good content
well credibility so you know anybody can
write but are you writing about
something you know what you're writing
about are you a good talking point a
good expert or have experience about
this content so you also want to use you
know information from a legitimate
source okay so you don't want to grab
something in your and use it in your
content that's just not legitimate
because it does hurt your credibility
and the organization's credibility and
then also originality i mean write
something
that nobody else has written so
obviously you don't want to plagiarize
because if you plagiarize and there are
tools out there where people can easily
just put their content in there to see
what else is out there see if somebody
else has plagiarized it so it's very
easy to find people who plagiarize so
don't be that person what i would
recommend create a good content calendar
and come up some ideas before you write
them next question related to content
marketing so what are the types of
content you can create well there are a
lot of things you can create start with
the blog blog to me is always a great
place to start it's a blank canvas for
your ideas your thoughts your opinions
okay that's a great thing about a blog
it accentuates personality you can
create a video videos are always
engaging you can create an infographic
infographics to me are you know hidden
gem instead of somebody reading the same
old same old you're laying this out in a
very visual way that's easy to
understand create a case study okay so
if you're a digital marketing expert
you've done social media for another
client you know write about it you know
show the successes show that you are an
expert show that you've created
successful campaigns and social and in
the form of case study and create a
white paper white papers are good
educational pieces you can also create
an ebook okay ebook hey if you have a
lot of content you want to lay it out
and ebook's a good way to go and you
have a lot of choices here when it comes
to content a lot of choices okay so what
are the advantages of having a content
counter so i alluded to that just a
couple of seconds ago so let's really
break this down here because content
counters to me are so important well
first of all calendar part of content
calendar allows you to think about dates
so
if you're planning something you're
going to have important dates in mind
okay so content calendar it almost
ensures you don't miss anything you know
that's a good opportunity for you to
leverage like you know black friday
cyber monday you know it's probably
important you know when those days are
if you're in e-commerce so that's why
having a content calendar helps it helps
you plan out your content based on
important dates or based on dates that
work for what you're trying to do they
also help because you could stick to a
consistent schedule okay so if you don't
have a content calendar you're probably
just arbitrarily writing content here
and there well what if your users crave
and really engage with the content
they're going to want more sticking to
something consistent is going to really
get people to come back for more they
know when you're going to post they're
going to be waiting for it and if it's
every tuesday morning 8 o'clock hey post
it tuesday morning 8 o'clock your users
will get used to that schedule and it
does help build up your following it
does help to help build up your
community and in the end cultivates a
long-lasting relationship and then
having a content calendar also allows
you to mix up your content okay so you
can see and plan ahead different types
of content in different formats that way
it allows you to mix it up whether it be
a blog post uh an infographic a video
about different topics okay some other
advantages here saving time it just
allows you to prepare for the future
when you can prepare you're efficient
and when you're efficient you're not
wasting time and so to me having a
content calendar is a must because a lot
of us are busy who has time especially
if you're going to work in a new company
so let's say writing content you
definitely want to have a content
counter because you're going to want to
use that time to efficiently plan this
is a new company you're going to start
working at you want to understand who
this company is what they've done in the
past what you haven't done and what you
want to do okay so all of that helps you
plan and prepare and it saves you the
time and effort and hassle down the road
and then at the end of the day you want
to be able to figure out what works so
planning your post puts less strain on
you and your team members as well as
company resources because when you plan
and you post you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that piece of
content or the topic in the content
calendar again it's that simple okay
some other advantages fresh content okay
so having a con content calendar allows
you to always keep content fresh and
you're going to be on a consistent
schedule and you're not going to be
writing about the same things over and
over again so it could be just simply
twitter if you're putting a content
calendar in
it together for twitter well you don't
want to have the same tweets every other
day so it does ensure that you're
getting tweets out there that are fresh
that are new that are different and
again figure out what works a content
counter makes it easier to measure
results and optimize performance so you
always want to you know maybe put some
metrics in with your content calendar so
you can see side-by-side content
historically that is performed content
that is not performed okay so next
question you may get what type of
content works in each stage of the
customer life cycle so you have
awareness engagement purchase
post-purchase advocacy okay so let's
break these down here so awareness okay
so you want people to understand who you
are okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping you out it could be a
cold email a v a video that can
potentially go viral a social media post
introducing a product
you have engagement so you want people
to engage with your content what are you
going to do to get people to engage well
you could certainly write an email and
have people open that email and go to
your website you can have an ebook where
people can actually download and read it
or you can have a blog where people can
comment or landing page where they can
fill out a form submission you have
evaluation so with social media we know
there's a lot of engagement going on but
when you're putting content out there
you can certainly open it up to
testimonials okay you can generate white
papers okay or you can generate case
studies case studies a good way for
companies to evaluate what you've done
in the past if you've worked in it for a
specific product in the past and it's
worked you certainly want to put that
out there for potential clients in that
same industry purchase trying to get
people to purchase what are you going to
do well you can certainly have landing
pages a nice you know website a nice
shopping cart with some nice content
okay onboarding emails get those emails
out there and get people to go back to
the website and purchase of course you
can have product and service details as
well meaning you know one one page
downloadable pdfs that describe the
product okay you post purchase okay so
people who've already purchased you
could certainly send out follow-up
emails and you can do blog round-ups you
know give people an opportunity to see
what features or updates are happening
to the product okay of course case
studies of repeat customers or content
types that detail a new feature or
service okay so if somebody's already
purchased and you may want to send them
some content of another product that
complements the product they bought so a
lot of things you can do to engage with
your user who's already purchased and
then advocacy you want people to help
you out here so have the user generate
the content you can have exclusive
discounts for your community they're
gonna be your advocates so give them
exclusive discounts and then pictures of
customers engaging with your products
okay who's not gonna share that so
you're gonna have people share that
information in other words you can
generate content where hey people can
help you out here and be your advocate
okay so how do you decide what topic and
subject to write on okay well going back
to the content counter that always helps
you to see what you put in that content
calendar but there are some other
methods you can use and you could
certainly identify your target audience
and not only identify your target
audience but what their needs are okay
so you can write content based on
audience you could certainly do some
research with keywords okay what's
trending what keywords are not trending
okay and right around what's trending
for example okay you could certainly
take a look at social media for example
cora i always look at korra core is
interesting entertaining informational
people are certainly having
conversations on quora and you can
certainly analyze those conversations
because they certainly get in depth and
you can decide hey do i want to write a
topic around something that really just
won't go away in terms of conversing
core is a good example of analyzing
conversations they tend to be a little
bit more in depth so some other things
you could do you can look at your
competitors and what kind of
conversations are happening on your
competitors blogs or your competitors
social media platforms and pages you can
keep track of blogs and articles from
subject matter experts commentators
critics and so on okay so you can get
ideas from them another question you may
get which is very important if you're
going to start working for a company you
need to understand the tone the tone of
your content because that is going to
fit and be in line with the company
you're working for okay so you're always
going to have a brand personality so the
characteristics of a brand are the
guidelines based on which the content
strategy is developed the tone of the
content must align itself to the content
strategy your audience profile so you
got you need to determine who your
audience is okay and how the brand wants
to be seen by that audience so you know
if you have an older audience you're not
going to use younger audience ie street
lingo or today's lingo and and the
younger generation uh you're going to
use you know language that's going to
fit the audience you're talking to and
then of course the channel itself so the
content you create must be irrespective
of the channel and consistent with brand
attributes okay so you gotta pick and
choose the channel if it's linkedin for
example hey you know linkedin is more
business oriented okay so you're not
gonna be
you know as humorous as you would be say
on instagram or facebook all of these
have one thing in common again that's
brand guidelines you have to stay within
the brand what is the brand's
personality how do we want to talk to
our audience and what platform are we
using to talk to our audience how do you
promote your content once it's live well
that's always a good question hey you
doing the the work the putting in the
hard work to create this you know it
could be a video and videos take a long
time it could be an infographic an ebook
okay so send it out via email okay if
you haven't an email list send it out
and let people know this content's there
put a link in the email or or even a
piece or snippet or preview of the
content in the email so you're using the
email to broadcast and encourage people
to you know if it's an ebook get the
rest of the ebook okay you can certainly
leverage social media to engage with
your community that's the best you know
just as good as email get out there and
let people know hey i got i got my book
published come and download it you know
you can give a discount to the first 100
people that download it okay you can
always promote your content via ads so
whether that be google or facebook you
always have an opportunity to meet more
prominent by advertising the content
that you have to offer so you can always
reach out on social media again
targeting interesting people directly so
you can always interact with people on
social or you can write for others
attract people from the web to important
pages of your website by guest posting
so you can always go on to a popular
blog post and write something and you
know link it up or or have it be
relevant to the content you've written
so next question how can you determine
how well your content is doing okay very
important again you've done all the work
you've put the content calendar together
you got the content ready to go it's
published you're promoting it social
email guest blogging but you want to
determine how it's doing well depends on
the channel really is what it comes down
to so if it's organic search you want to
be able to see if it's ranking for the
keywords you optimize that content for
if it's social you want to be able to
see if you have engagement shares
comments etc of course you can always
look at analytics and see how much
traffic that blog post is getting or
that page with the white paper is
getting okay so you can always look at
your analytics and look at the traffic
okay and again you can always look to
see if there are conversions in the form
of an inquiry or lead or sale so at the
end of the day you want to align the
content with the channel and you want to
align the kpi with the content and
channel okay so if it's social you're
not likely going to get conversions
unless you're doing paid ads if you're
posting organically on social then
you're probably going to get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so you really
need to decide what goal you want to
achieve with the content marketing
campaign so that goes back to what i was
just saying a minute ago if you have
content you post it on social then
what's the goal what are you trying to
achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes
you need to define buyer personas to
determine the audience best suited for
your content okay so you're always
writing for an audience and you're going
to market that content for that audience
so you always got to keep that in mind
run content audits audits to determine
the best type of content that can be
used in other words how did it perform
what kind of engagement did you get with
the infographic or did that video really
really perform well or do we want to use
you know a blog post next time around or
an image next time around so continuing
on here you want to choose an
appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it wordpress or is it
another platform okay you could start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
counter to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you you
come up with some ideas then you
obviously want to
choose the format and then of course you
want to publish and manage your content
after it's all said and done so these
are the steps involved again just
quickly decide on the goal the kpi
deciding your audience look at what's
worked and not worked in the past get
your content set up in the platform okay
or get the platform ready to go i should
say okay generate ideas with that
content counter i ideally go to the
content calendar for the ideas choose
that type and then publish and manage
and when i say manage i mean again going
back to analytics or going back to the
kpi that you align with that content to
see if it's performing or not okay so
next question here how do you target the
right audience for your content it's a
very good question you're not writing
content for everyone let's be honest
here so you have to collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website based on who
subscribed to your emails based on who's
following you on social media so in
other words you have people interacting
with you okay in different channels and
you need to understand who these people
are so are they fit a certain age range
or generation are they skewed more
female to male education level what's
their affinity or interest okay do they
have a certain income so you need to
really break down your audience here and
you could do that in analytics you could
do that on social you can do that just
by looking at your email list okay that
all those will paint a picture as to who
your audience is
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you